Ja, herzlich willkommen zur Alternativlos, die Folge numero 50. 50.
Hey Frank, wir müssen mal wieder eine Sendung machen.
Echt? Findest du? Na gut, wir haben auch wieder eine Sendung.
Also wir hatten ja, ist jetzt nicht so, dass wir die ganze Zeit rumgehangen haben, sondern wir haben wirklich mehrere Anläufe unternommen, hier eine Sendung zu machen für euch. Und wir haben auch sogar schon Termine gehabt und einen Gast eingeladen. Und das musste dann kurzfristig wegen Covid irgendwie abgesagt werden. Also es liegt nicht nur an uns. Eine gewisse Teilschutt müssen wir, glaube ich, auf uns nehmen, aber es liegt nicht nur an uns diesmal.
Ja und wir geloben diesmal auch einfach keine Besserung. Vielleicht wird es dann ja besser mal sehen.
Ja, wir haben uns gedacht, wir machen jetzt das schöne Sommer und warm, dann machen wir jetzt mal so eine schöne Sommersammelsendung.
Genau, einfach so gut gelaunt mit Cocktailglas und irgendwie Sonnenstammchen und einer lauen Brise. Und dann haben wir angefangen, diese Sendung vorzubereiten.
Ist nicht mehr so viel übrig geblieben von der guten Laune.
Genau, wir werden hoffentlich auf einer positiven Note enden, aber bis dahin könnte es möglicherweise sein, dass die Sommerlaune so ein bisschen leidet.
Es war nicht unser Einspruch, hier eine Nörgel-Sendung zu machen.
Nee, wollten wir eigentlich nicht. Wir wollten eigentlich mal so eine positive, rundum glücklich Sendung machen. So eine, wo man hinterher beschwingt, rausgeht und sich denkt so, ach ja, die Welt ist doch schön. Eine gute Zeit, um jetzt am Leben zu sein. Aber naja, vielleicht kann dieser Anspruch nicht so ganz realisiert werden.
Wobei zumindest teilweise, also ich bin ja ein großer Fan von dem 9-Euro-Ticket, muss ich dir sagen. Auch wenn du dann halt teilweise stehen musst in der regionalbahn, ist das immer noch irgendwie, ist so ein bisschen Gefühl wie Star Trek. Ja, muss ich sagen, so endlose Weiten. Und du steigst in einen Zug und kommst irgendwo raus. Also ich bin so ein Typ, der ich planen dann nicht unbedingt, wo ich jetzt hinfahre. Und das gibt es halt erst seit 9-Euro-Ticket gefühlt. Ja, es gab natürlich früher schon irgendwie VBB, irgendwie Gesamtticket Brandenburg oder so. Aber einfach in irgendeinen Zug steigen und halt rumfahren. Und wenn ich keinen Bock mehr habe, aussteigen und dann gucken, was da ist. Das ist ein ganz neues Fahrgefühl für mich. Und ich als Westberliner, für mich ist auch viel von dem Umland tatsächlich noch ein Neuland, wo ich noch nie war. Also ich bemühe mich da zwar irgendwie Sachen abzufahren, aber so viele Gelegenheit hat man ja auch nicht. Also im Moment bin ich so ein bisschen in Brandenburg am Morgen fahren. Und da gibt es ein paar schöne Burgen und Schlösser und so. Und das ist wunderbar. Was ich da gesehen habe, ist zum Beispiel, also bin ich jetzt zum Beispiel mal nach Bad Belzig gefahren und da gibt es eine Burgenbuslinie, die geht beim Bahnhof ab. Von Berlin ist das ungefähr eine Stunde. Ja, bis zu da mit der regionalbahn. Und dann kannst du in diese Burgenlinie fahren und einfach nur mit dem Bus fahren ist schon Urlaub. Weil der kommt an drei Burgen vorbei und fährt über so. Das ist keine biosphäre, sondern ein Naturschutzpark, wenn ich mich das jetzt hier nicht verkacke. Das heißt, da sind noch alte Alleen, so mit großen Bäumen auf beiden Seiten. Und die Straße aber so eng, dass in der Mitte kein Streifen gemalt ist und so. Und da kartert halt dieser Bus mit dir durch. Und allein diese Landschaft ist schon wunderbar. Und dann sind da so Schilder wie irgendwie alte Schmiede oder Burg Rabenstein, Rabenstein gab es da. Und dann kannst du halt aussteigen, kannst dir diese Burg angucken und dann gehst du halt in den nächsten Bus und fährst weiter.
Und warum hast du das vor dem 9-Euro-Ticket nicht gemacht?
Naja, also ich muss sagen, wenn ich früher Urlaub hatte, dann habe ich eher versucht, irgendwie weiter wegzufahren. Weil irgendwie das Gefühl, jetzt ist jetzt meine Gelegenheit, jetzt muss ich auch ein bisschen Distanz überwinden. Aber so dieses, das 9-Euro-Ticket hat ja so ein bisschen die Anreizstruktur verschoben, jetzt auch mal hier das Umfeld einfach ein bisschen mitzunehmen. Und ich habe also zum Beispiel auch gesagt, ich fahre jetzt einfach mal zu so ein paar Enthalteständen von U und S-Baden, die ich nur vom Namen her kannte. Und das ist einfach eine Sache. Ich glaube, es hat sich auch bei mir was geändert, weil früher hätte ich irgendwie immer irgendwas zu tun gehabt. Und jetzt habe ich mir halt gesagt, das ist jetzt egal, ich mache das jetzt.
Aber ich meine, also Geld kannst ja eigentlich nicht liegen.
Nee, nee, es ist nicht das Geld. Aber es ist, ich habe, also ich habe, ich weiß nicht, das ist, glaube ich, weil meine Eltern so nachkriegsgenerationen sind, wo das Geld knapp war. Und da hieß es dann immer irgendwie nix liegen lassen, alles noch verwerten und Junge, das ist alles was wert, das darf man hier nicht irgendwie verschwenden und so. Das heißt, wenn ich irgendwo das Gefühl habe, ich werde hier genickelt und dimed, wie es so schön heißt auf Englisch, das heißt, irgendwie jeder Schritt, den ich mache, so auch mikrotransaktionen sind mir ein Horror als Vorstellung. Einfach vom Gefühl, da steht jetzt irgendwo jemand und rechnet mit, wie viel er mir in Rechnung stellen kann, finde ich gefühlsmäßig absolut furchtbar. Da kann ich mich nicht entspannen, weil dann muss ich auch rechnen. So was mache ich denn jetzt? Nicht weil ich irgendwie das Geld nicht hätte oder weil es irgendwie knapp wird oder so, sondern einfach das Gefühl, da steht jemand und rechnet, da muss ich auch rechnen. Das kann ich einfach, das ist irgendwie gefühlsmäßig, bringt mich das in eine Nicht-Urlaubsstimmung. Und da hat das 9-Euro-Ticket echt was geändert. Ich eine andere Sache, die ich empfehlen kann. Ich habe mal, in Berlin gibt es so Fähren, die Teil aber von der BVG sind. Und da kannst du hinfahren und mit dem BVG, also jetzt auch mit dem 9-Euro-Ticket, einfach die Fähre mal nehmen. Und das ist dann so ein Boot. Und da fährst du dann halt über so ein See. Und diese konkrete Fähre, die ich da genommen hab, die war eine Solar-Fähre. Das hat mich total geflescht. Die hat überhaupt keinen Auspuff, hat auch nicht für Notfälle noch einen Außenborder oder so. Hat Solar auf dem Dach und Batterien drin. Und ich hab dann den Käpt'n mal gefragt und der meint so, ja, das geht ja irgendwie nicht bei Sonnenaufgang los im Sommer, sondern irgendwie, wenn er da ankommt, ist das Ding schon geladen, so bei 90 Prozent. Einfach von dem Sonnenlicht am Morgen. Und dann meint er so, und jetzt sind wir gerade bei, und guckt da so auf seinen Messer, so 96 Prozent. Das war halt natürlich ein sonniger Tag, klar. Ist auch nicht irgendwie. Aber so, also man kann im Moment schon ganz tolle Sachen machen. Und das kann ich auch jedem nur empfehlen. Jetzt gibt es hier irgendwie noch zurzeit diese Aufnahme, da gibt es noch irgendwie drei Wochen August 9 Euro Ticket. Das ist eine echte Bereicherung für mich gewesen bisher.
Also einfach nur weil diese mentale Barriere, dass du irgendwie dir eine Fahrkarte kaufen musst, wegfällt. Ich kenne das selbe Ding von der Bahnkartonnaz. Also das zur Bahnkartonnaz ist halt fürchterlich teuer.
Aber danach ist große Freiheit.
Danach ist es halt schon alleine nicht darüber nachdenken zu müssen, welchen Zug ich nehme, nicht ein Ticket buchen zu müssen, mich nicht entscheiden zu müssen, sondern einfach zum Bahnhof zu gehen und zu gucken, was fährt denn jetzt gerade so. Ist halt krass. Und so viel kann ich gut nachvollziehen. Das ist halt, ich meine, ein 9-Ohr-Ticket ist ja nur für regional. Aber selbst da, ich meine gerade übrigens um Berlin, ist ja das regionalnetz riesengroß und kommt sehr, sehr weit und ein bisschen umsteigt sogar überall hin. Und ich glaube, dass genau dieser Punkt, dass man mit so einer Geschichte den Leuten Mental Load nimmt, also einfach dieses Komplexität aus der Welt rausnehmen durch Flatrate, hat sich ja an ganz vielen Stellen als zusammen mental gut herausgestellt. Also dass du dich nicht, also stell dir, erinnere dich mal dunkel. Damals, als man irgendwie noch ernsthaft drüber nachdenken musste, wie viel Traffic man dann jetzt irgendwie auf seinem Internet macht. War genau das selbe Ding. Da konnte man es eigentlich nicht so richtig benutzen, sondern es war halt eher so ein Luxus.
In der Sekunde, wo das irgendwie per Traffic abgerechnet wird, ist es halt kein, es ist ein Luxusgut. Ich erinnere mich noch, als die Atomkraft in Deutschland irgendwie groß wurde oder als man irgendwie drüber nachdachte, das wirklich ernsthaft zu betreiben, da ging das Argument rum. Ja, das ist dann so billig, der Strom, dann brauchst du keinen Zähler mehr.
Too cheap to meter.
Ja, das war also nicht nur bei uns auch, sondern auch in anderen Ländern. Und da ist natürlich nichts draus geworden, aber das hätte ich ja super geil gefunden. Denn also dieses Gefühl, dass da jetzt keiner steht und irgendwie guckt, wie viel ich verbrauche und dass ich dann auch nicht gucken muss. Das ist jetzt natürlich in Zeiten der Klimakatastrophe nicht mehr verkaufbar, aber so bei Sachen, wo es keinen Unterschied macht. Also Traffic zum Beispiel oder Wasser war lange Jahre sowas bei uns. Wasser ist in Berlin. Es ist so, dass wir eigentlich immer zu viel Grundwasser hatten, weil die im Osten das Wasser weggepumpt haben aus dem Tagebau. Und das heißt, dass wir hier im Grunde so viel Grundwasser hatten, dass keiner hätte sparen müssen. Ja, und das stellt sich aber raus, dass die Leute dann trotzdem sparen wollten, weil das halt pro Liter abgerechnet wird. Und dann haben die halt sparsamere Waschmaschinen gekauft und irgendwie halbe Spülung beim Klo und so. Und der Bedarf ging runter und das führte dann dazu, dass du auf der Straße sehen konntest, wie die den Hydranten aufgemacht haben, weil zu wenig Wasserbewegung war. Und weil sich dann Keime gebildet hätten.
Na und die Keime hat nicht mehr funktioniert, weil es nicht mehr Spülwollungen gab.
Das kommt auch dazu. Ja, aber so die im Grunde, im Grunde ist so diese vision einer Gesellschaft, wo nicht ständig irgendeiner hinter dir steht und eine Rechnung stellen will, ist einfach komplett weg aus meiner Sicht. Und das finde ich traurig. Wobei teilweise sind wir wieder da, zum Beispiel telefonieren war früher eine Sache, über die man ernsthaft nachdenkt.
Genau, und jetzt musst du noch suchen, wenn du einen Nicht-Flatride-Mobilfunk-Vertrag finden willst.
Ja, oder ich bin sogar noch vor, ich erinnere mich noch an Zeiten, als wir ernsthaft überlegt haben, ob wir jetzt die Großeltern in Westdeutschland anrufen können. Also nicht nur, weil es teuer war, sondern weil die Leitungskapazität auch knapp war. Und da hat die Technik viel weggeräumt. Also eigentlich leben wir in einer tollen Zeit, aber es hat eben auch Nebenwirkungen, die nicht unbedingt toll sind.
Na ja, das ist eigentlich ganz interessant, weil wenn wir uns jetzt angucken, was technisch möglich wäre, also nehmen wir mal Strom. Also dieses To Cheap To Me, da ist eigentlich ein schönes Stichwort.
Du, diese Fähre, da denke ich jetzt seit Wochen drüber nach. Also wieso wir da eine fucking Fähre hinbauen können, die immer irgendwie von links nach rechts und zurückfährt und nie tanken muss, aber die Straßenbahn kann das nicht machen.
Die hat nicht genug Solarfläche.
Ja, aber schon klar, es gibt da Gründe für. Aber wenn wir das bei einer fucking Fähre machen können, dann können wir das so eigentlich...
Wir können das tatsächlich überall machen. Also mal ganz kurz hochrechnen. Ich habe da noch nicht ein paar We-Mai-er-rüber diskutiert. Wir haben halt versucht, irgendwie herauszufinden, was kostet eigentlich Energiespeichern? Weil wir haben jetzt das Problem bei Solar und Wind, dass die halt ja zyklisch sind. Also dass du halt irgendwie Phasen hast, wo nicht genug da ist, um die Last irgendwie komplett zu tragen. Und dann haben wir ausgerechnet, was würde das eigentlich denn kosten, so selbst mit irgendwie so Standard aktueller Akku-Technologie? Also jetzt nicht mal so super High-End, sondern eher so bodenständig, so Lithium-Eisenphosphat, so was halt so die Akkus sind, die halt irgendwie ein bisschen schwerer, ein bisschen größer halten, dafür ewig am 5000 Zyklen.
Natrium schrieb mir gerade ein Leser.
Ja, also so Sachen.
Also Lithium ist doch vergleichsweise... Lithium hat den Nachteil, dass wir in Deutschland keine großen Reservoirs haben. Das heißt, wir können das eigentlich hauptsächlich fördern, indem wir alte Akkus recyceln, was ja auch schon gut ist. Aber wir sind halt nicht wirklich unabhängig, sondern müssen das eigentlich importieren.
Genau, also ich meine, wir haben es halt mal auf der Basis von, also der Kostenbasis von... Was kann ich denn jetzt irgendwie kaufen, wenn ich halt irgendwie günstig kaufe, so durchgerechnet. Und der Hintergrund war unter anderem, das ist ein Bekannter von mir, der hat sich halt eine Solarinselanlage gebaut. Also der hat sich, ich glaube, 300 Quadratmeter oder 280 Quadratmeter Solar hingetan, so auf sein Scheumendach. Nicht super effizient, sondern halt irgendwie so, wie es da halt gerade steht, jetzt nicht aufgestandert, also keine riesigen. Und hat sich dann halt so China-Litium-Eisen-Phosphat-Akkus hingetan. Und bei dem tritt genau dieselbe Phänomen ein. Also der hat gesagt, Einspeisen interessiert mich nicht, ist viel zu teuer, irgendwie diese ganze Bürokratie, ich habe keinen Bock, ich baue meine Inselanlage.
Aber er will nicht beim Fernseher anschalten, irgendwie aus dem Netz Strom ziehen, sondern will von seiner Solarinlage.
Genau, also der hat halt noch einen Netzanschluss, aber den hat er wirklich nur, weil er so denkt, naja, manchmal, keine Ahnung, habe ich selber gebaut, vielleicht geht es ja doch kaputt, so, ne? Und der hat jetzt seit anderthalb Jahren ein bisschen mehr sogar in Betrieb. Und der meint halt, seine Einstellung zu Strom hat sich halt vorstündig geändert, so. Also er hat halt einen, also sein limitierender Faktor ist halt sein Speicher, das riesengroß, hat irgendwie 20 Kilowattstunden, glaube ich, also es...
Haha, falls er mal was schweißen muss, ja.
Genau, ja, genau, um seine Werkstattmaschinen zu betreiben, also, dass er halt ein bisschen mehr hat, aber meint er, normalen Tank kommt vom Dach genug runter, also kein Problem so. Und er hat aber immer so ein bisschen so dieses, dieses, wie viel habe ich denn noch im Akku? Habe ich schon irgendwie unter 30 Prozent, oder was immer so sein Limit ist, was er sich so mental gesetzt hat und so. Er meinte aber unter normalen Umständen hat er halt so ein Gefühl von Fülle. Na, so hat er halt so dieses Gefühl von so, boah, ich könnte mir jetzt eigentlich auch eine Dreinhalb Liter Badewanne kaufen, weil ich muss ja nicht mehr drüber nachdenken, was es kostet, die irgendwie warm zu machen, wenn ich irgendwie mal ein richtig geiles Vollbad irgendwie machen will. Oder mal die Saune anschmeißen. Ja, warum nicht die Saune anschmeißen, kostet ja nix.
Also bei mir ist es die Klimaanlage, wo jetzt in den heißen Tagen habe ich mehrfach drüber nachgedacht, ob ich mir nicht eine Klimaanlage anschaffen würde und hab dann immer gesagt, na ja, also aber der Stromverbrauch und dann bist ja Teil von dem Problem. Und dann sitze ich da halt in der Wohnung irgendwie mit einem Ventilator, der ja auch Strom verbraucht und irgendwie bin im Wesentlichen nicht voll arbeitsfähig, weil es einfach zu fucking heiß ist und das wäre wirklich geil, wenn man einfach ohne schlechtes Gewissen so eine Klimaanlage betreiben könnte.
Ja, macht ja auch.
Ja.
Also das Interessante daran ist halt die Technologien.
Da wollen wir hin. Da wollen wir dahin. Was hält uns auf?
Wenn wir jetzt also die Technologie angucken, die wir gerade haben, dann sind wir bei, keine Ahnung, was haben wir, was ich mit Paar ausgerechnet habe, waren irgendwie so was zwischen 6 und 8 Cent Erzeugungskosten, die halt irgendwie jetzt bei Solar und Wind so typischerweise anfallen. Das glaube ich sogar richtig, was wir damals ausgerechnet haben. Und man hat so, wenn man es speichern muss mit irgendwie Akkuzyklus, also Akku-Preis versus Zyklenzahl, kommt man auf so was wie um die 5 Cent Speicherkosten. Also wir sind de facto bei so 50-50 Erzeugungs- und Speicherkosten, aber die sind immer noch so in der Boypark-Größenordnung 10 Cent.
Das ist immer noch weniger als du aktuell?
Weitaus weniger. Das ist weniger als ein Drittel von was du aktuell aus der Steckdose zahlst. Weil du halt diese ganze Netze zahlst, natürlich Netz. Und irgendwie zahlst halt irgendwie, dass wirklich immer Strom aus der Steckdose kommt. Also das ist halt der Anteil für Verfügbarkeitsgarantie gegenüber den tatsächlichen Stromerzeugungskosten. Also den technisch heute möglichen, nicht dem, was gerade installiert ist, weil das ja teuer mit Braunkohle und Steinkohle und Gas und Atomkraft und so weiter. Das ist aber ist halt ein ziemlich, ziemlich großes Delta dazwischen, was halt dazu führt, dass jetzt Leute, die halt das freie Cash haben, sich eine Inselanlage zu bauen, die machen das jetzt halt. Und zwar massenweise. Das heißt so, ich hab da irgendwie neulich mit so einem Solar-Installateur geredet, der meinte halt so, er muss aufpassen, dass er genug schläft. So, weil er halt einfach die ganze Zeit am Ackern ist. Also er kriegt mehr Aufträge als er, also könnte mehr Aufträge annehmen, als er abarbeiten kann. Weil irgendwie, das meinte jeder, jeder, der irgendwie kann, macht das jetzt. Und natürlich die Leute, die halt irgendwie sich's leisten können, machen halt auch Einspeisungen, weil dann amortisiert sich das von selber. Aber meint halt ganz viele, sagen halt, ich will eine Insulanlage, ich hab da keinen Bock auf diesen Einspeisequatsch, weil irgendwie ist halt...
Na ist halt Bürokratie da, oder?
Ja, und dann hast du so Probleme, dass du halt dann deine Energieversorgung kann nicht halt an deine Einspeisungen abschalten, wenn die sowieso gerade zu viel Solar haben, weil sie nicht wissen wohin damit. Auch so ein Problem. Das heißt also, wir haben halt irgendwie, da kommt wieder das Speicherproblem, weil wir haben jetzt, zu Piekzeiten haben wir halt eine Überkapazität an Solar und Wind. Das heißt, wir erzeugen mehr als wir verbrauchen können. Und da wir keinen sinnvollen Speicher haben, was ja mein Gospel seit Jahren ist, dass irgendwie die ganze erneuerbare Energienzukunft steht und fällt, damit das Speicher gebaut werden und zwar alle Technologien, alle Größenordnungen sowohl großtechnisch als auch kleinteilig verteilt. Stattdessen streiten wir uns drüber, was jetzt der beste Weg ist, wobei eigentlich vollständig klar ist, dass man auch nur 30 Sekunden drüber nachdenkt, dass das Einzige, was hilft, ist einfach alles machen. So alle Technologiegrößen, alle Verfahren, alle Speichermethoden, alles halt einfach bauen, bauen, bauen, bauen, weil sonst kriegen wir die Kurve halt nicht mehr. Also es ist halt jetzt nicht mehr so, dass wir jetzt noch zehn Jahre darüber diskutieren können, ob jetzt Wasserstoff eine gute Idee ist oder ob man doch irgendwie thermische Sandspeicher baut. Nee, was gebaut werden kann, muss gebaut werden, und zwar jetzt und sofort. So alles andere wird halt nicht mehr dazu führen, dass wir das mit diesem Klima noch in den Griff bekommen.
Es gibt da auch so Energien, die vielleicht nicht offensichtlich sind. Da zum Beispiel haben wir jetzt gerade eine Dürre. Und man könnte ja, wenn man, sagen wir mal, Solarstromüberschußen nutzt, könnte man ja eine Entsalzungsanlage am Meer bauen. Der Meeresspiegel steigt ja perfekt. Also es gibt beliebig Nachschub und dann baust du dann eine Entsalzungsanlage und pumpst halt das Wasser inland. Und da kannst du dann die Felder mit bewässern. Was uns da ja von abhält im Moment sind natürlich a. konstruktionskosten und b. dass das Energie frisst. Aber wenn die Energie sozusagen kostenlos aus Solarzellen fällt, könnte man das ja mal einfach machen.
Sie ist ja nicht kostenlos. Also es ist halt so, die Kosten für so eine solarinstallation, ich glaube, was haben wir gerade, 100 Euro pro Quadratmeter? Oder was ist halt so der, wenn du halt so in großen Größenordnung kaufst und die müssen halt irgendwie amortisieren, damit es halt irgendwie finanziert werden kann. Aber das ist halt wieder auch so ein Problem, dass halt die, diese Amortisierungsrechnung ist ja eigentlich darauf aufgebaut, dass irgendjemand irgendwann Gewinn macht. Also so, also mindestens die Banken, die den Kredit dafür gegeben haben. So das ist halt irgendwie so. Und die, und auch da könnte man wahrscheinlich gut, jetzt waren die Zinsen gerade niedrig. Da, also viele Solarfelder wurden halt einfach zu quasi Nullzinsen gebaut, weil hat halt nichts, kostet sich Geld zu bauten.
Ist es nicht auch die KfW, die da die Kredite rausgibt? Also staatlich?
Zum Teil, ja. Ich mein, das ist halt so ein Ding, wo halt einfach die, also man einfach klar sagen muss, Industriepolitik in Deutschland ist halt so eine Geschichte des kontinuierlichen Versagens. Wir waren mal Weltmarktführer in Solarzellen, muss man sich mal überlegen.
Und Windkraft.
Und Windkraft, so. Und weil halt China das dann zwischendurch mal ein bisschen billiger bauen konnte, wurde das hier halt alles komplett abgesäbelt und irgendwie eingestampft, was dazu geführt hat, dass wir jetzt heute den Kram wieder aus China importieren müssen.
Ich fand ja den Hammer jetzt, die Meldung zu Siemens Energy kam gestern rum. Die haben irgendwie eine Milliarde Verlust angehäuft dieses Jahr.
Mit ihrem Gas-Turbinen-Geschäft, oder?
Nee, das war der Hammer daran. Der Verlust kam zwar zum Teil auch von dem Gas, aber der Großteil davon kam von deren spanischer Windkraft-Tochter, wo sie im Artikel meinten, so ja, sie haben in der Vergangenheit ein paar schlechte Entscheidungen getroffen. Ja, offensichtlich, wow, ja, so. Und das ist eigentlich, wo du hinguckst, so, dass wir uns selbst im Weg stehen. Und das ist nicht irgendwie Schicksal oder irgendwie Verkettung ungünstiger Umstände, sondern wir, wir haben Fehler gemacht und wir sind nicht in der Lage, dazu zu stehen und zu fixen jetzt.
Ja, weil die Strukturen, die halt zu diesen Fehlern führen, sind halt ganz häufig in Center-Strukturen. Also Strukturen, die künstlichen Anreizen. Ja, genau, also die Anreizsysteme für Menschen in entscheidungspositionen sind halt häufig so, dass sie nicht langfristig gute Entscheidungen befördern, sondern halt eher nur kurzfristige Quartal- oder jahresorientierte Entscheidungen, aber nicht darauf ausgelegt sind, dass du halt irgendwie Entscheidungen triffst, die noch für die nächsten zehn Jahre gut sind. Und das ist halt so ein grundlegendes Phänomen des Wirtschaftssystems, das wir haben, aber auch der Behörden und der staatlichen Strukturen.
Interessanterweise betrifft es aber China offenbar nicht. Die denken ja durchaus langfristig und planen ordentlich. Wie kommt denn das? Die machen ja also zumindest auf dem Papier eigentlich ähnliche Entscheidungsfindungsprozesse wie hier.
Nee, machen sie aber nicht.
Na die haben auch irgendwie eine kommunale Verwaltung und die haben eine regionale Verwaltung und sie haben irgendwie die Bundesregierung, die irgendwie Vorgaben macht. Das ist ja auch Anreizstrukturen bei denen. Was machen die denn anders?
Und langfristige Planung. Also bei denen sind ja Erfüllungen langfristiger Plenateile Anreizstrukturen, zumindest in den Behörden. Da geht halt auch so viel schief und das funktioniert alles hin und vorne nicht. Aber zumindest haben die halt, also gerade jetzt auch diese dieren ganzen Monster-Infrastruktur-Projekte, ganz viel davon ist halt Schrott, was halt zu irgendeinem Jahrestag fertig werden muss und in fünf Jahren wieder zusammenfallen wird. Vielleicht in 15. Da gibt es halt schon auch klare Probleme. Man muss halt sagen, dass allein die Idee zu sagen, es gibt einen langfristigen Plan und dieser langfristige Plan erfüllt ein politisches Ziel und nicht ein kurzfristiges Effizienzziel. Das glaube ich der Unterschied, weil im Westen ist halt die Denke, insbesondere halt in den Unternehmen, immer kurzfristig effizient. Häufig auch Cashflow, muss man klar sagen. Das ist halt häufig so, dass viel von dem, was passiert in der westlichen Wirtschaft, ist nur dadurch zu erklären, dass Unternehmen kurzfristig ihre Cashflow-Probleme lösen müssen. Und das wird jetzt noch schlimmer werden und Kredite teurer werden. Das führt dazu, dass Unternehmen noch kurzfristiger denken, weil sie eben nicht mal einen Kredit aufnehmen können, der auf zehn Jahre hinaus gedacht ist.
Und die Finanzämter befördern das noch?
Ja.
Das möchte ich mal an der Stelle sagen. Die Finanzämter machen das so, dass als eine Firma zahlt Steuern pro Jahr, oder je nachdem, wie groß die Firma ist, auf die Gewinne. Das heißt, die Firma hat einen Anreiz, ihre Gewinne runterzudrehen, indem sie noch schnell Dinge ausgeben zum Jahresende. Und das heißt halt, dass am Jahresanfang erst mal die Kasse leer ist. Was ja richtig doll scheiße ist eigentlich, weil ein Unternehmen soll ja in der Lage sein, auf irgendeine Krise, wie zum Beispiel jetzt irgendwie Supply Chain, was wir gerade haben, reagieren zu können. Aber hast du halt nicht, wenn du aus Steuergründen versucht hast, deine Profite für irgendeinen Scheiß auszugeben.
Na, solange du deine Lagerbestände halt hast, okay.
Na, aber das ist doch vorbei, dass die Leute Lagerbestände haben. Das ist doch alle Just-in-time-Scheiß.
Nee, aber das führt halt eben, also was halt auch dazu führt, ist, dass eben die steuerliche Gestaltung für Unternehmen geringe Lagerbestände auch bevorzugt. Es ist halt so, dass also niemand wird steuerlich dafür belohnt, de facto, dass er sagt, ich leg mir mal fürs nächste Jahr mein Material hin.
Na, du wirst sogar bestraft dafür, weil das nämlich versteuerbares Kapital ist, ne?
Ja.
Also ich würde jetzt nicht die ganze Schuld den Finanzämtern zuschieben, aber schon einen wichtigen Teil, ja? Also ich bin beruflich im Beratergeschäft tätig und ich kann es also deutlich sehen, dass zum Ende von den Fiskaljahren ist immer noch Kohle da, um noch schnell irgendwie einen Beratervertrag zu machen. Also bei uns ist Dezember ist eigentlich immer voll, ja? Und Januar ist eher leer. Und das liegt daran, ja?
Ja, das ist bestimmt eine Förderung der Wintersportindustrie.
Ja, genau. Ganz super.
Aber die ist ja mit dem Klima jetzt bald erledigt.
Du, ich dachte ehrlich gesagt schon seit 30 Jahren, dass die erledigt ist.
Na, dann haben sie Schneekanonen gebaut.
Na, die haben sie auch damals schon gehabt, aber es war halt irgendwie klar, dass das nicht dasselbe ist auf so Schneekanonen, irgendwie Schnee. Ich bin früher, ich bin früher, bin ich ganz gern Ski gefahren als Kind mit meinen Eltern. Und ich weiß noch, dass unsere, die Ferien, in denen wir gefahren sind, also als ich jung war, gab es noch keine Winterferien, sondern da gab es halt die Weihnachtsferien, die waren eigentlich zu kurz, um da irgendwie groß was zu machen. Und es gab die Osterferien, die waren im April. Und im April ist eigentlich kein Schnee mehr da. Aber damals gab es halt noch Schnee. Inzwischen gibt es Winterferien, das heißt, jetzt gibt es auch noch eine Chance, irgendwie Schnee mitzunehmen, wenn er da ist. Aber wir sind halt früher in den Osterferien in die Alpen gefahren und haben dann so die letzten Ausläufer von dem Schnee immer mitgenommen. Und da haben die dann eben auch mit Schneekanonen irgendwie Schnee verteilt. Und das war nicht dasselbe. Das sind ganz andere Kristallstrukturen. Das merkst du total. Das friert dann auch fest. Und so. Also das ist nicht ist nicht so schön. Aber also ich habe damals daraus geschlossen, dass ich als Erwachsener nie wieder Ski fahren muss, weil das ist eh bald vorbei. Und da das bereue ich heute ein bisschen. Da habe ich zuvor schnell. Aber wahrscheinlich ist es besser, weil das ist ja auch für die Umwelt nicht gut, wenn die Hänge sind alle total im Arsch, wenn du da im Sommer mal vorbei fährst. Das sieht aus wie so eine Marslandschaft. Da wo irgendwie Skifahrer vorbeigekommen sind, der Boden ist halt erodiert.
Durchkomprimiert und dann erodiert. Tja, naja, also ich glaube, dieses Problem ist auch eines von sich nicht trauen. Also dass wir jetzt sehen, dass irgendwie Habeck und Co. jetzt so plötzlich, wuppterdiwuppter, da so Flüssiggast-Terminals an die Küste stellen können und alle total schockiert sind, dass es offenbar irgendwie doch geht, wenn man dann so unbedingt will.
Na, vor allem gab es die Ansage, ne, wir fangen jetzt schon mal mit dem Bauen an, obwohl die Genehmigung noch nicht durch ist.
Genau, so Tesla-Style.
Ja, wobei Tesla schon gesagt haben, so what the fuck, was macht der denn da? Und diese Amis immer, weißt du, so diese Wildwest-Methoden und so. Ja, nix, macht der Habeck auch.
Also das erste Anzeichen, also ich meine, gut, ob es eine gute Idee ist, da Flüssiggast-Terminals hinzustellen, kann man darüber streiten, aus sowohl sagen wir mal im weitesten Sinne Souveränitätsgründen als auch irgendwie aus natürlich Umweltgründen.
Naja, und wo kaufst du denn Flüssiggast?
Das meine ich auch mit Souveränitätsgründen. Also ist halt so, entweder Amis oder halt irgendwie Sklaventreiber. Naja, und aber letztendlich ist es halt die Frage, halt zeichnet sich da, weil wir ja so ein bisschen Optimismus verbreiten wollten, zeichnet sich da quasi so ein Umdenken ab in die Richtung zu sagen, okay, wir müssen uns mal anerkennen, wir haben uns da irgendwie ziemlich in die Scheiße geritten mit irgendwie der Politik der letzten Jahre, Jahrzehnte, die Zeit läuft uns davon, wir müssen jetzt mal dringlich was tun, egal ob jetzt Klima oder Versorgungssicherheit, ist ja egal. Und wir müssen jetzt einfach mal uns überlegen, ob wir irgendwie wieder groß denken. Also tatsächlich irgendwie dieses, das geht ja sowieso nicht in die ganze Bürokratie und das wird doch sowieso nie was, einfach ablegen und sagen, okay, wir machen das jetzt einfach mal. Und zwar nicht nur Großprojekte, sondern eben auch sowas wie Solar-Insel-Anlagen. Und einfach die Strukturen, die verhindern, dass die Technologien, die wir haben, effektiv benutzt werden können für das, was jetzt getan werden muss, dass diese Strukturen einfach mal weggemacht werden, dass die halt einfach ignoriert werden, dass die halt sich nicht immer als das wesentliche Hindernis heraus schlägt. Ich hab irgendwie gerade im radio auf dem Weg hierher gehört. Alleebäume in Brandenburg. Alleebäume finden wir eigentlich alle super. So werden, Zahlen sind jetzt nur so grob richtig, pro Jahr werden 5000 davon gefällt, weil die halt alt sind oder Autos dagegen fahren oder halt irgendwie die krank sind oder vertrocknet sind oder whatnot. Und ungefähr 1000 werden gepflanzt. So das heißt, wir verlieren jedes Jahr in Brandenburg 4000 Alleebäume. Und dann fragte da der radiomoderator oder sein Kollegen, der da irgendwie auf Außengeschichte war, so war er ja irgendwie, why? So also warum werden nicht mehr gepflanzt? So und dann stellte sich halt raus, dass es da eine unglaublichen Dschungel an irgendwelchen Regularien gibt. So dann muss halt der Mindestabstand, muss halt irgendeine Anzahl von Metern sein, die wiederum dazu führt, dass die nicht mehr auf den Straßengrundstücken stehen können, die dem Land gehören, sondern sie dann den Ackerstreifen von den Bauern abkaufen müssen, damit sie die Alleebäume dahin stellen können und so weiter und sofort.
Das sind alles so Bestandsschut im Moment, ja. Deswegen dürfen die da noch stehen. Ah nein, da ist Scheiße.
So und dann hast du halt irgendwie so Sachen wie, ja, wenn die Straße angepasst wird, dann müssen sie die trotzdem bekloppt, ja. Und dann hast du halt irgendwie so wieder diesen Interessenkonflikt. Der Bauer will natürlich sein Land nicht verkaufen, weil irgendwie das ist halt teures Ackerland. Irgendwie was irgendwie seine Einnahmequelle ist. So davon haben wir jetzt eh zu wenig. Versus halt irgendwie so ein abstraktes Ziel, wie unsere Nachfahren werden da in 50 Jahren nicht auf dieser Straße halt irgendwie zu Staub zerfallen, weil es halt eben nur Schatten gibt. Das sind halt so diese Konflikte, wo langfristige Planung und langfristiges Absehen von Trends nicht mehr optional sind. Also wo es klar ist, dass die das kurzfristige Denken, sowohl kurzfristige Profite als auch kurzfristige Incentives und motivationen uns nicht mehr zum Ziel führen. Und dass wir uns von dem Gedanken, dass Effizienz das Maß aller Dinge ist, also im Sinne von Effizienz des Kapitaleinsatzes verabschieden müssen. Das ist genau dasselbe, was wir vorhin hatten, diese diskussion über so quasi Flat-Rate-Systeme.
Ich glaube, wir haben im Wesentlichen dasselbe auch schon im Kontext IT-Security geredet. Weil da ist es im Grunde genauso. Wenn du als Firma anfängst, als einziger in deiner Branche in Security zu investieren, hast du auf dem Markt einen Nachteil gegenüber den ganzen Hasardeuren, die dann halt gehackt werden und so tun, als sei das halt wie so ein Unwetter, kann man nichts machen. Ja, das ist halt billiger, das nicht ordentlich zu machen. Und ich, deswegen glaube ich, das ist nicht die Politik, also es ist auch die Politik, aber es ist nicht nur die Politik, sondern es ist eigentlich ein Feature des Kapitalismus, der dich dafür bestraft, wenn du langfristig irgendwie Sachen verbessern willst, aber dafür kurzfristig irgendwie Ausgaben hast.
Ich habe gerade ein Buch gelesen, The People's Republic of Walmart.
Der Titel überzeugt ja schon direkt.
Zufallsfund, kannst du mal in die Notes tun, ein Zufallsfund. Die These, die da drin ausgerollt wird, das ist halt ein, ich will jetzt nicht alle Details davon verteidigen, aber die These ist gut, nämlich die sagt, wir haben ja irgendwie diese diskussion Planwirtschaft versus sozusagen freie Marktwirtschaft, die ja verhindert, dass wir in so eine langfristige Denke reinkommen, weil wir glauben gelernt zu haben aus dem Ende des sozialistischen Versuchs, dass eine Planwirtschaft nicht funktionieren kann. Das war ja sozusagen so die allgemeinen, auch in den Schulen gelehrten Lehre, das kann halt nicht funktionieren, weil die Welt viel zu komplex ist und es halt unmöglich ist, irgendwie alles abzusehen und das halt alles zu planen. Und daraus dann halt irgendwie die entsprechenden Folgerungen kommen.
Ich glaube, da springst du über das Ziel hinaus gerade. Ich glaube, das war viel billiger. Die haben einfach gesagt, guck mal, der Kommunismus ist gescheitert, deswegen ist Planwirtschaft auch gescheitert.
Kann sein, aber wenn man ein bisschen weiter reingeht, ist die diskussion schon ein bisschen komplexer. Also die gingen auch zum Beispiel um die kubernetesche Planwirtschaft und so Sachen. Und da war es ja dann auch so, dass halt diese, die eine Theorie war ja zu sagen, so okay, wir haben nicht genug Daten, deswegen konnten wir nie einen ordentlichen Plan machen. Die andere, ja.
Ich sage immer, Ausreden sind eine nachwachsende Ressource. Da hat es noch nie drin geklappt.
Die andere, das andere war halt, dass halt durch Planwirtschaft halt irgendwie private Initiative und Kreativität wegfällt, beziehungsweise gedämpft wird und demzufolge ist halt irgendwie nicht möglich. Es ist halt irgendwie das volle Potenzial der Menschen zu nutzen. Und die dritte These ist natürlich, dass halt irgendwie ein System in seiner Instabilität halt dazu führt, dass du halt irgendwie einen faschistischen Kontrollfreak-Apparat dahinstellst, der halt irgendwie die Leute daran hat zu rebellieren, was dann halt zu den entsprechenden Effekten geführt hat mit millionen von Toten und so weiter. Die These, die die in diesem Buch aufziehen, ist insofern interessant, weil sie sagen, okay, gucken wir uns mal die großen Konzerne an, die richtig großen Konzerne, wie zum Beispiel Walmart. Die halt komplett vertikal integriert sind. Also die halt tatsächlich sozusagen von der Erzeugung bis hin zum Verkauf im Wesentlichen alles machen. Das, was Apple quasi tut, also die halt so, ist auch ein vollständig vertikal integrierter Konzern. Das heißt also, die machen halt, also das weiß nicht, ob sie inzwischen irgendwie auch Minen für seltene Erden haben, also würde mich nicht wundern. So, bis hin zum Telefon.
Sie haben sich auf jeden Fall Kontingente gesichert.
Genau, also bis zum Recycling machen die ja quasi alles, von so einmal quer durch. Und haben kontinuierlich auch die Anzahl ihrer Zuliefer reduziert, bzw. deren Werke sind de facto von ihnen gemanagt. Der Zuliefer kümmert sich halt nur um die Details und so. Und ausgehend von dieser These, also von dieser Beobachtung, haben sie dann gesagt, okay, warum machen die das? Dann haben sie gesagt, okay, einer der wesentlichen Gründe ist, dass die Ineffizienzen in der Übermittlung des Nachfragesignals, also nehmen wir an, es gibt hier ein einfaches Beispiel Modetrend, der sagt, Leute wollen jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, blaue kurze Glitzerhosen kaufen. Dann führt es halt dazu, dass sich dieses Signal, die Leute kaufen jetzt hier blaue kurze Glitzerhosen, durch die gesamte Lieferkette durchschaukelt. Also bis halt irgendwie am Ende halt irgendwie das Material, aus dem der blaue Glitzerstoff gemacht wird, wird dann halt mehr nachgefragt, was halt dazu führt, dass halt irgendwie die Jahr-Latenz einfach ist. Naja, es ist nicht Jahr-Latenz, aber es führt dann halt dazu, dass es am Ende eine überproduktion von blauem Glitzerstoff gibt. Also das ist halt sozusagen so dieser sonnende Whiplash-Effekt, also dass sich halt quasi so eine Welle immer stärker aufschaukelt hat, durch die Supply Chain durchschaukelt. Und den kriegst du halt damit raus, dass du halt alles selber in der Hand hast. Das heißt also du weißt halt am Ende, meine 50 Filialen haben heute 5.800 blaue Glitzerhosen verkauft. Der Trend fällt leicht. Das heißt also wir müssen jetzt nicht noch mehr blaues Glitzer machen, sondern das, was wir halt da haben, reicht halt. Also wurde sozusagen quasi dieses Supply Chain Smoothing heißt es, dadurch, dass du alles komplett integriert hast und halt nicht irgendwie mit 1000 Interfaces und 15 verschiedenen motivationsstrukturen und irgendwie Quartalsberichten und so weiter dazwischen hast, sondern einfach alles in einem drin hast. Und dass daraus, also die These dieses Buches, daraus halt die Effizienz kommt. Und die argumentieren halt aus einer quasi ja sozialistischen Perspektive, sind halt so ein paar Altlinke, die dieses Buch geschrieben haben, also amerikanische Altlinke, die sagen halt, okay, wir haben jetzt die Technologie. Also wir haben jetzt quasi den Punkt erreicht, wo man auf der Basis von dem, was jetzt Amazon und Walmart und Apple und Co. machen, halt quasi einen kybernetischen Sozialismus bauen könnte, in dem halt irgendwie tatsächlich eine Planwirtschaft möglich ist. Ich halte das für falsch, weil jede dieser Unternehmen hat eine Spezialisierung und die haben ein relativ klar abgegrenztes Handlungsfeld. Aber...
Ich würde auch Apple und Walmart nicht vergleichen wollen. Also Apple ist integriert, aber Walmart ist eigentlich bekannt dafür, dass sie den Whiplash-Effekt weiter reichen und einfach ihr Risiko minimieren. Und das hinten da ständig die ganze Zuliefererpleite geben.
Ja, ja, ja, klar. Das beschreiben die da auch. Aber trotzdem ist halt diese, sozusagen dieses integrations-ding, also dass sie, je weiter du nach hinten in die Lieferkette kommst und je besser du dann dein Nachfragesignal nach hinten übermittelst, desto mehr kannst du auch tun. Also desto mehr kannst du zum Beispiel durch Marketing, durch Preissteuerung auch nicht rein marktwirtschaftliche Ziele erreichen. Also dass du halt sagst, okay.
So wie Umweltschutz?
Genau, wie Umweltschutz zum Beispiel. Also ein positives Beispiel ist zum Beispiel Patagonia. Also eine Outdoor-Marke ist halt eher Premium, die aber schon immer Vorreiter waren in Recycling, in faire Arbeitsbedingungen und so weiter. Und sich da auch wirklich Mühe geben und richtig viel Geld dafür ausgeben, das auch zu ihrem Bestandteil ihrer Marke gemacht haben und so weiter. Der Kram ist, den du halt irgendwie kaufst, wenn du halt irgendwie kein schlechtes Gewissen haben willst und so. Und bei denen ist es aber eben genauso, dadurch, dass sie sehr viel direkt vertrieben vertreiben, dass sie halt Eingeräten haben, dass die halt bis tief hinten in die produktion gucken, also dass quasi so dieses gesamte Ding halt einmal durch ist, dass die damit halt einen viel Waste halt reduzieren. Und da fiel mir eine interessante Parallele auf, nämlich dazu, wie im Osten die erfolgreichen Unternehmen funktioniert haben. Die haben nämlich den Handel ignoriert. Also gab es im Osten so diese handelsorganisationen, also so HO und Konsum und so und dann noch so ein paar andere, die halt so spezialisiertere Konsumgüter machten, also zum Beispiel die Warenhäuser. Und das Interface zwischen den Produzenten und diesen handelsorganisationen war halt so die Vollkatastrophe. Es hatte halt überhaupt nichts mit irgendeiner Form von Koordinierung zu tun gehabt. Das ging immer schief, war immer irgendwie die handelsorganisation, immer zu viel bestellt, weil sie wussten, sie kriegen sowieso nicht, was sie bestellen. Und so also halt so diese Nummer, ne?
Du, das war auch gerade meine exzellente Frage, ja.
Genau, noch mal kurz fertig machen. Es gab auch so ein paar Ausnahmen, denn die hatten eigene Läden. Also die haben halt tatsächlich eigene Läden für spezifische Güter gemacht, die sie dann halt direkt verkauft haben. Und das funktionierte dann erstaunlicherweise vergleichsweise gut, gab immer noch mangel und war immer die ganzen Probleme zu lieferer, Probleme und irgendwie diese ganzen Dinge. Aber es war halt ein bisschen besser. Also es hat daran hat sich gezeigt, dass das spürbar nicht nur irgendwie mit war. Und das also das fiel mir dann dadurch dazu ein, dass halt also diese eigentlich genau dasselbe, was zum Beispiel Apple da gerade tut, die halt sagen so okay, unser premierer Verkaufsweg ist halt unser Online-Shop und unsere Läden. Also die halt quasi unmittelbar jeden Nachmittag irgendwie oder jeden Abend, wahrscheinlich sogar am Stundentakt sagen können, wie viel von diesem Telefon verkaufen wir denn eigentlich gerade. So und wie sieht denn eigentlich unsere Trends aus? Und dann eben auch direkt unmittelbar nachsteuern, bis runter zu den Zulieferern, wie viel Chips bestellen, wie viel Fertigungskapazität brauchen wir bei TSMC und Samsung und so weiter und so fort. Das heißt also, dass quasi diese, das ist halt so ein bisschen auch die Idee in diesem Buch, dass sie quasi sagen, dass wir jetzt sozusagen dadurch, dass die digitale integration von Verkauf zu, da war schon zuliefererproduktion, die Möglichkeit ergibt, auch exogene Ziele zu erreichen. Also zum Beispiel Klima, Recycling, Umweltschutz und so weiter. Und gut, deren These geht dann halt weiter und sie sagen, wir müssen einfach nur den ganzen Scheiß unter eigenen und weiter betreiben. Aber da gibt es wahrscheinlich technische Detailprobleme. Aber tatsächlich ein lesenswertes Buch wegen dieser Idee zu sagen, so eigentlich haben wir Technologie, mit der halt so was möglich ist. Wir brauchen nur längerfristige Ziele. Und jetzt muss ich den ganz großen Bogen zurück zu China machen. Wie so funktioniert es in China an einigen Stellen etwas besser? Der Grund ist, dass die nicht aufgegeben haben, langfristige Ziele zu setzen. Wie die Partei da agiert, ist ja nicht, dass sie versucht, die Ökonomie zu mikromanagen. Das haben sie gesehen, am Osten, das hat nicht funktioniert. Sondern was sie tun, ist, die setzen langfristige Metaziele. Also die sagen halt zum Beispiel, das ganze Belt-and-Roads-Ding, da gibt es ja tausend Vierschläge drin.
Aber am Ende haben sie eine Seitenstrasse.
Genau, was sie gesagt haben, wir wollen mehr Häfen auf ausländischen Territorien unter Kontrolle haben. Wir wollen eine durchgehende Bahnstrecke nach Europa haben. Das heißt, es gibt halt quasi strategische Ziele, die gesetzt werden und die sich dann übersetzen in einzelne, kleinere Handlungen, die aber mit relativ großer Autonomie der einzelnen Unternehmen und Strukturen gemacht werden. Bis dahin dazu, dass die mit Policy-Sachen experimentieren innerhalb von China, so dass sie halt den Provinzen sagen so, hier ist unser Metaziel, wir wollen mehr Wohnungen. Also wir wollen bis dann und dann, keine Ahnung, 50 millionen Wohnungen haben. Und die Umsetzung des Ziels, also sozusagen, wie kommen wir denn eigentlich dahin, wird aber im Zweifel den Provinzfürsten überlassen. Die können sich entscheiden.
Und die Freiheit ist relativ groß, die die haben. Also bis zum politischen System. Ja, also wir haben Shenzhen zum Beispiel, was eine Freihandelszone ist, weil sich da eben, also ich weiß gar nicht, was zuerst war, was zuerst eine Freihandelszone, und dann kam die ganzen...
Ich glaube so war es ja.
Jedenfalls ein Großteil der Elektronik der Welt kommt halt von da. Und die haben ein, würde man sagen, westlicheres System. Also jetzt nicht komplett. Oder Hongkong ist aus Sicht von China auch sowas. Obwohl sich das jetzt angleicht natürlich.
Gut, aber ich will da jetzt nicht das Loblied auf irgendwie...
Nee, aber also ich will sagen, die Freiheit ist relativ groß, die die Provinzfürstner haben. Es ist nicht nur, dass die halt ein Ziel kriegen, die sie autonom verfolgen können, sondern sie können also auch an den Parametern drehen.
Ja, aber letzten Endes ist der wichtige Teil jetzt für diese diskussion ist, Ziele setzen. Also tatsächlich das Setzen von Zielen und das Gestalten von Incentive-Strukturen, die dazu führen, dass diese Ziele nicht mit irgendwie einem Regelwust erreicht werden. So, weil wir haben zum Beispiel das Problem, dass wir halt in der EU haben wir viele große Metaziele. Wir wollen halt irgendwie eine bessere Umwelt, wir wollen unseren Klimaschutz und so weiter und so fort. Also diese ganzen Dinge haben. Aber am Ende manifestiert sich das dann in nochmal 5000 Regeln mehr.
Die Bananenkrümmung, die berühmte.
Ja, ach, das geht ja noch viel weiter. Also wenn du halt irgendwie wirklich so was zum Beispiel tun musst, um irgendwie Elektroschrott zu verhindern, ist ja ein großes Ziel. So wir wollen halt weniger Elektroschrott haben. Was sich dann am Ende sozusagen rauskommt, ist dann halt, wenn du halt irgendwie versuchst, ein Elektronikprojekt als Unternehmen zu machen, musste dir eigentlich mehr als eine Person einstellen, die sich nur mit den Regularien beschäftigt. So was halt heißt das bestimmt, warum wenn so Kickstarter oder so, diese ganzen Dinge. So warum sind da ganz viel so, naja, so Basle-Projekte, wo du halt nur so eine Platine und ein Gehäuse zum selber drum umschrauben bekommst. Weil die dir niemals realisieren könnten, mit allen Regularien einzuhalten, wenn sie halt irgendwie das Ding als Gerät in der EU registrieren müssten. Also da sind wir halt an so einem Punkt angekommen, wo hatten wir schon mehrfach dieses Thema, wo halt die Regeln so gemacht werden, dass eigentlich nur noch Großunternehmen sie halt erfüllen können, wenn sie halt irgendwie, weil denen halt die Kosten im Vergleich zu ihrer Größe egal sind. Das ist auch so ein Kritikpunkt, den ich an diesem People's Republic of Wormatting habe, nämlich dass die die Betrachtung dazu, dass am Ende solche Strukturen primär Großunternehmensstrukturen sind, wo du eigentlich sagst, wir können halt so eine Welt nur erreichen, indem wir möglichst viele Oligopole haben in möglichst vielen Bereichen, die dann halt nach entsprechenden Incentives und Vorgaben arbeiten, ist halt nicht jetzt so eine Welt, in der ich gerne leben wollen würde, weil es halt dazu führt, dass halt irgendwie Leute, die außerhalb von solchen Oligopol-Strukturen arbeiten wollen, Leute, die halt Probleme haben, in Konzernen zu arbeiten, dann da halt keinen Platz mehr haben, sondern halt alles irgendwie nur noch in so bürokratischen Monster-Strukturen, die halt nach irgendwelchen Compliance-Regeln geführt werden. Ja, am Ende nicht. So, aber letzten Endes ist halt so die Frage, wenn man überlegt, wie sieht denn da so ein Ausweg aus, aus diesem ganzen Problem, ist, glaube ich, die Idee des Setzens von Metazielen und des Experimentellens ermitteln der besten Wege zur Umsetzung. Und wenn man dann welche Identifizierter die dann zu skalieren, schon der richtige Weg. Also quasi ein Metaziel, ein gutes Metaziel setzen, was nicht zu granular ist und dann Möglichkeiten schaffen, innerhalb der existierenden Systeme und Strukturen zu experimentieren, um gute Möglichkeiten der Erreichen dieses Metaziels zu finden und Abschluss der Experimentierphase, die dann halt daraus zu skalieren.
Ich bin ja immer ein Befürworter von Sunsetting bei Gesetzen, fällt mir bei der Gelegenheit an. Also dass du sagst, nicht nur wir haben ein langfristiges Ziel und hier ist eine Idee, wie wir es erreichen, sondern du sagst dann auch, und das sind die Kriterien, an denen wir erkennen, ob dieser Weg der richtige ist. Ja und in einem Jahr, das gilt jetzt erstmal nur für ein Jahr, und nach einem Jahr gucken wir nach, ist das erreicht, und wenn ja, können wir das verlängern. Aber ansonsten ist es automatisch tot, zurückgerufen. Und das würde ich mir mehr wünschen. Ich glaube, das ist so der Weg. Aber ich wollte noch eine Sache sagen, die mir jetzt sozusagen wie Schuppen vor den Augen gefallen ist, als du von dem Osten erzählt hast und den wenigen Unternehmen, die da funktioniert haben. Wir haben gerade so einen ähnlichen Effekt im Grafikkartenmarkt. Ja, da gab es nämlich die ganzen Krypto-Miners, die haben die GPUs gekauft und haben damit Ethereum gemeint. Und die Grafikkartenhersteller haben gesagt, oh ist die Nachfrage groß, das ist ja super. Und konnten gar nicht schnell genug produzieren, weil dann kam ein bisschen Covid dazwischen, dann gab es irgendwie Lieferketten, blabla. Und dann haben die halt die Preise erhöht. Und zwar also 50 Prozent und mehr. Eine Grafikkarte, wo du früher irgendwie 500 Euro gezahlt hättest, die haben jetzt irgendwie 1500 Euro aufgerufen.
Eine Grafikkarte?
Ja, für die Highend-Grafikkarten sind also wirklich Mondpreise.
Krass.
So, und jetzt ist ja gerade der Crypto-Markt zusammengebrochen.
Und Crypto-Coin, eigentlich sagen wir auch Cyber-Coin dazubeißen, es handelt sich um den perfekten Zusammenfluss von Geld, das du dir einfach nehmen kannst. Und heute existieren das Software, deswegen nicht so gerne Cyber-Coins.
Gut, also Cyber-Coins. Jedenfalls, warum ich den Fall besonders lustig finde, ist, weil der größte Hersteller von Grafikkarten, Nvidia, hat gerade größere Probleme. Erstens ist ihnen der Markt plötzlich weggebrochen für die Grafikkarten. Das heißt, die Preise nähern sich jetzt wieder der unverbindlichen Preisempfehlung an und die ist aber auch schon plus 50 oder plus 80 Prozent. Das heißt, immer noch krass überteuert. Aber Nvidia hat jetzt eine Klage am Bein von ihren Investoren. Die haben nämlich unterwegs gefragt, wie ist denn das? Sind das denn Crypto-Miners, die eure Karten kaufen? Und Nvidia hat gesagt, nein, nein, das alles geht an die Gamer. Und jetzt stellt sich halt raus, ne, ne, das ging überhaupt nicht an die Gamer. Das waren alles Crypto-Miners und die Investoren fühlen sich jetzt in der Gange. Also das ist das erste Problem. Das zweite Problem ist, jetzt kam raus, Nvidia hat irgendwie Kosten von über einer Milliarde Dollar nur für das Lagern von Grafikkarten, die sie gerade nicht loswerden. Das heißt, und das dritte, warum ich das überhaupt erwähne, Nvidia ist einer der lautesten selbst proklamt Marktführer für KI. Das heißt, wenn jemand in der Lage sein sollte, ein Kybernetiksystem zu bauen, was anhand der Marktdaten, die in Echtzeit vorliegen, sagen kann, was gerade passiert wäre, ist Nvidia gewesen. Und trotzdem sind die genau in diese Falle reingelaufen und es funktioniert halt gar nicht. Gut, da kam jetzt auch noch raus, dass die eine Marge von über 60 Prozent hatten und sind jetzt oft bei 42 Prozent abgestürzt, wo ich immer noch denke, das ist ja unfassbar. Und das ist nur die Marge von denen, nicht von dem Channel, der auch noch mal draufsteht. Das heißt also, die Preise, die für Grafikkarten müssen noch mal deutlich sich halbieren oder so, bevor wir da in in reeller region vorkommen. Aber also das mit der Kybernetik ist ein schöner Traum. In der Praxis funktioniert es nicht. Und ich glaube, ein Großteil davon liegt gar nicht daran, dass wir die Daten nicht haben oder nicht in der Lage sind, die zu bewerten, sondern dass alle auf dem Weg lügen. Ja, im Kapitalismus haben wir eine Supply Chain. Und beim Grafikkartenmarkt konnte man das super beobachten. Da gab es dann nämlich irgendwie Leute, die sich beschwert haben, dass ihr Versender der Wahl, irgendwie so jemand wie Amazon oder Alternate oder so, keine Grafikkarten liefern konnten. Weil die halt wirklich nicht lieferbar waren. Weil jede, die so lieferbar war, sofort gekauft wurde von irgendwelchen Minern. Und dann ging halt das Geschrei los. Und dann haben die angefangen, ihre Zahlen mal zu nennen. Einige wenige von denen. Und da kam dann raus sowas wie, ja, also wir haben hier gerade irgendwie eine Lieferung von 5 gekriegt, bestellt hatten wir 500. Und die haben halt mehr bestellt, als sie akut brauchten, weil sie ja gesehen haben, wie viel Nachfrage da war. Das heißt, wenn diese Zahlen jetzt, also mal angenommen, es gäbe ein Kybernetik-System und da kommt jetzt die Anfrage von dem Channel rein, sie möchten gern 500 haben, dann ist das aber schon eine Lüge. Gar nicht mal, weil die irgendwie bösartig sind, sondern weil sie halt sehen, wenn ich 1000 bestelle, kriege ich 10. Dann bestelle ich jetzt mal irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 2000, damit ich so viel kriege, wie ich haben wollte. Und ich glaube, das ist inhärent, dass alle Leute auf dem Weg versuchen, ihre eigenen Geschicke irgendwie zu verbessern, indem sie lügen.
Da haben wir jetzt aber gerade ein interessantes Problem identifiziert. Nämlich, warum bestellen die mehr? Weil sie sehen, wir kriegen nicht genug, also quasi selbes Phänomen wie im Osten. Also wollen wir uns Lagerbestände hinlegen.
Nee, sie wollen wichtig aussehen.
Nee, nee, nee.
Lager hat keiner mehr.
Nee, nee, Moment.
Jede Grafikkarte, die reinkommt, ist sofort verdampft.
Warum haben die 500 bestellt, selbst wenn die pro Woche nur 100 verkaufen? Weil sie wissen, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sie in vier Wochen nichts bekommen, hoch ist. Und die wollen möglichst wenig traurige Kunden haben, weil die nämlich woanders hin. Das heißt also, die haben alle versuchen schon, sich Lagerbestände aufzubauen.
Ich glaube, es ging nicht um Lager. Es ging darum, du sagst, ich will 500, und du weißt, du kriegst nur 50. Das heißt, du siehst eine akute Nachfrage nach 100 und dann bestellst du 500, in der Hoffnung, dass du 50 kriegst.
Genau.
Also niemand hat wirklich damit gerechnet, dass die 500 kommen, die sie bestellt haben.
Genau, weil halt sie prozentual beliefert wurden, anstatt ihrer Bestellmenge. Aber das Interessante daran ist, was wir gerade jetzt festgestellt haben, ist, dass quasi die jetzt ja aufgrund der Supply Chain-Probleme und der generell absehbaren, immer unschöner werden gesamtsituation, notwendige Aufbau von Lagerbeständen, um halt irgendwie gegen Probleme weiter oben im Stream gesichert zu sein. Also bei egal was, sind nicht nur Handelsgüter. Gas zum Beispiel ist ja der beste Weg, irgendwie sich was in eine Reserve zu legen oder jemanden zu kennen, der eine Reserve hat. Was aber wiederum dazu führt, also Lagerbestände sind ja eigentlich dann eine Verzerrung der Datenlage des kybernetischen Signals. Also sozusagen, was wir da haben, sind dann quasi so Jitterbuffer, die halt sozusagen die Effizienz des kapitalismus, also sozusagen des kybernetischen Sozialismus, Kapitalismus, quasi einschränken. Dafür gibt es gerade glaube ich keine Lösung aus. Interessante Beobachtung.
Na ja, es gibt die Lösung, dass du einen Teil davon irgendwie per langfristigen Vertrag klärst und den Rest versuchst halt am Spotmarkt zu füllen, was halt funktioniert, außer es funktioniert nicht. Und dann funktioniert es halt richtig doll nicht.
Naja, beziehungsweise klar, ich meine, das Problem ist halt dann nur, dass wenn deine kurzfristigen Incentives halt auf Profit sind, wie wir es jetzt gerade im Gasmarkt gesehen haben, dann machst du halt deinen Speicher nicht voll, sondern nimmst halt das billige Gras, was du gerade kriegst, um deinen Speicher voll machen zu können und verkaufst es teuer am Spotmarkt, anstatt das für den Winter hinzulegen, was du dann brauchen würdest. Deswegen müssen wir jetzt diese Gasumlage da machen, um halt diese Zocker da halt irgendwie zu bailouten, was mich wirklich maßlos ankotzt, ehrlich gesagt.
Es sind ja nicht nur Zocker, sondern es hat ja auch eine politische dimension, habe ich neulich gelernt. Nämlich sind gerade in Frankreich die Hälfte der Atomkraftwerke offline, weil die Franzosen die halt auf Verschleiß gefahren haben und nicht gewartet haben. Und jetzt sind die halt, im Sommer ist es sowieso schwierig mit Atomkraftwerken, weil die nämlich ihr Kühlwasser normalerweise in den Fluss abgeben und dann am Fluss gebaut werden. Und wenn du gerade einen sehr heißen Sommer hast, ist das Flusswasser so heiß, dass du, wenn du das zu kühlende Kühlwasser, was noch heißer ist, einleitest und das hat eine zu hohe Temperatur, dann gehen die Fische sterben.
Na nicht nur die Fische, das ganze Ökosystem.
Das Ökosystem bricht zusammen, deswegen gibt es Regularien und deswegen hat man im Sommer immer wieder, müsst ihr mal irgendwie in die Archive gucken, immer wieder Atomkraftwerk so und so muss abgeschaltet werden, weil das Flusswasser zu warm war. Ja und das heißt jetzt im Sommer, also einige sind in Reparatur, andere ist einfach zu heiß geworden und die Franzosen haben halt auf Atomkraft gesetzt und um diese Lücke aufzufangen, wird jetzt das Gas aus unseren Speichern nach Frankreich weiterverkauft.
Das Gas, was hätte in die Speicher gehen sollen.
Ja, aber das ist ja nicht nur, weil die Franzosen gerade gut zahlen, sondern das ist auch ein Teil der europaweiten Solidaritäts-Reson. Das ist Politik auch. Also unsere Politik hätte ja genauso sagen können, ne wir brauchen hier selber für den Winter. Unsere Winter sind schlimmer als in Frankreich. Ja, keine Ahnung, also hätte man ja machen können, aber hat man halt nicht gemacht. Also es ist nicht nur Zocker, sondern es ist auch Politik dabei.
Naja, also wenn man sich anguckt, die...
Also ich bin ganz auf deine Nier, aber es ist halt nicht nur Zocker. Das Problem ist so ein bisschen größer.
Ja, okay. Das wäre schon, ja, okay, ja, sicher. Allerdings...
Aber es ärgert mich auch maßlos, dass wir jetzt Uniper irgendwie bailouten sollen.
Also, ich meine, Uniper muss man ja mal klar sagen, das wird die Bad Bank gewesen, ne?
Von Ion, ja. Ion hat gesehen, das mit dem Gas und Öl, das hält nicht mehr lange. Wir wollen eigentlich irgendwie was Ordentliches machen, eigentlich ein bisschen Greenwashing machen.
Die Kinder.
Ja, naja, gut. Aber also was dieses ganze Feld auszeichnet, ist das Level an Propaganda. Einfach und zwar aus allen Richtungen, nicht nur aus den Richtungen der Bösen, sondern auch so die Umweltschützer haben halt alle in der Agenda.
Und das deutsche Umwelthilfe. Ja, das ist ja, ich hab ja immer sehr große Sympathien für Leute, die sich um Umweltschutz kümmern, aber diese deutsche Umwelthilfe, da hört es ein bisschen auf. So, also, meine, das ist halt irgendwie so.
Das trifft halt niemanden, der es nicht verdient hat. Insofern bin ich da noch so ein bisschen zurückhaltend mit Kritik. Aber naja, ich meine, du musst dich halt fragen, willst du das einfach weiter laufen lassen oder willst du sagen, okay, dann ziehe ich da jetzt aber so viel Kohle raus? Wie geht es aus den Automobilherstellern? Also das ist schon irgendwie, man, da kannst du dich halt irgendwie auf so ein guerrilla Selbstschuss irgendwie zu berufen versuchen. Ich fand das nicht so klar, aber ich, also, ja, ich sehe da eine Kritik und ich kann sie nachvollziehen. Also, mein, aber ich kann auch nachvollziehen, was die da machen.
Also, wenn ich jetzt mir, wenn ich mir so die Umweltbewegung angucke, ich habe ja viel mit denen zu tun, weil ich halt auch viel für Aktivisten, halt kommunikationssicherheitsberatungen zu machen und Trainings mache für irgendwie, naja, wie, wie man sichert man seine kommunikation irgendwie für irgendwelche aktionen und so. Und ich habe ja da so den Ansatz zu sagen, so ich helfe irgendwie allen Menschen, die halt irgendwie, soweit es mir vergönnt ist und ich in der Lage dazu bin, die halt irgendwie positive Veränderungen anstreben und keine Nazis sind. Und ich habe halt auch viel mit Leuten zu tun, die ja, sagen wir mal, auf der eher jüngeren, eher schon verzweifelten Seite jetzt bei der Klimabewegung sind. Also da gibt es eine Menge Menschen, die, also ich glaube auf Reddit wurde das mal unter so Climate Dooming zusammengefasst, also die halt quasi sich soweit in den, in die Idee, dass, also wie der Name jetzt mal für die letzte generation noch sagt, die also soweit in der Erkenntnis oder in dem Glauben, ich würde es nur offen lassen, dass es mit dem Klima halt jetzt irgendwie wirklich richtig kritisch ist und wir halt irgendwie nicht mehr viel Zeit haben oder eigentlich gar keine Zeit mehr haben und wirklich jedes Mittel außer Menschen umbringen gerechtfertigt ist, befinden, die kann ich verstehen. Also es sind halt irgendwie Leute, die sind halt irgendwie Teenager oder Anfang 20, die haben ihr Leben noch vor sich und die sehen, dieser Planet geht vor die Hunde. Und einfach auch nicht mehr nachvollziehen können, nicht mehr verstehen können, dass also der, dass halt niemand offensichtlich irgendwas ernsthaft zu unternehmen gedenkt und die sich dann halt auf Autobahnen kleben und sagen so, okay, ihr seid jetzt alle scheiße wütend auf uns und vielleicht steckt auch ein Rettungswagen im Stau, aber wir wissen einfach nicht mehr weiter. Also wir wissen einfach nicht mehr, was wir jetzt sonst noch machen sollen, weil wir haben echt lange noch demonstriert und irgendwo fahren geschwenkt oder ein paar Bäume besitzen, wir müssen jetzt einfach mal Sachen machen, die wehtun, weil sonst wird es noch mehr wehtun. Ich bin da immer nicht so ein großer Freund von Radikalisierung, aber einerseits ich kann die verstehen und ich bin da halt, also wahrscheinlich würde ich, wenn ich 20 Jahre würde ich da auch auf der Straße sitzen, so muss ich klar sagen, das ist halt so ein Ding, wo ich viel Sympathie für habe, auch jetzt wenn nicht unbedingt für die einzelnen aktionen. Bei diesen Leuten, die das aber quasi in diesem strategic litigation Feld machen, also gerade insbesondere in der deutschen Umwelthilfe, fehlt mir diese Sympathie und zwar deswegen, weil das Leute sind, die in der Regel älter sind, die einen mehr strategischen Weitblick haben und die in dem, was sie tun, nicht besonders zielführend agieren in jedem Einzelfall, sondern eher so eine impulsreaktion machen, wie zum Beispiel halt jetzt dieses, okay, wir versuchen halt irgendwie, diese Flüssiggas-Terminals zu verhindern und es uns doch scheißegal, wenn hinterher Rentner erfrieren oder die Industrie ausgeht oder so. Also es heißt immer die Industrie, so die dann ausgeht, so als wenn die Industrie irgendwas Böses wäre. Die hat nun mal leider dafür gesorgt, dass dieses Land in einem relativ ordentlichen Wohlstand ist und den größten Teil der Arbeitsplätze in diesem Land, die noch irgendwie ein Produktivgewerbe sind, ist halt die Industrie.
Naja, aber ist das eine Ausrede?
Das ist keine Ausrede, aber die Frage ist...
Wenn du siehst, dass die Dinge kaputt machen und niemand zieht sie zur Rechenschaft, ist das dann nicht sozusagen deine Pflicht, die aufzuhalten?
Die Frage ist halt, hältst du sie auf, wenn du ihnen das Gas abdrehst? Also ist...
Auf jeden Fall. Ich würde sagen, das ist der erste tatsächliche Hebel, den wir gegen die haben. Also wenn ich jetzt sage, aber wir...
Na, wer ist denn dann die?
Na, so Leute wie VW, irgendwie Porsche. Also gerade Porsche, von denen irgendwie gerade rauskommt, dass sie hinter diesen, irgendwie sehr nah an der FDP dran warten, als es um aktuelle Politikfragen ging. Da ging es dann halt um E-Fuel, was eine große Verarschung ist. Da geht es um die Idee, dass man vielleicht aus CO2 und Solarenergie irgendwie einen Benzinersatz synthetisieren kann. Und dann müssen die armen Autohersteller nicht innovationen betreiben und Elektroautos bauen, sondern man kann irgendwie die alte Scheiße weiterfahren. Und da kam dann raus irgendwie, das war plötzlich einer der wenigen wirklich übelen Punkte im koalitionsvertrag. Und da kam dann raus, das hat die FDP reingeschrieben und der Porsche-Chef hat sich dann auf irgendeiner semiöffentlichen Veranstaltung damit gebrüstet, dass er das ja sozusagen da rein hat schreiben lassen von der FDP.
Moment, diese E-Fuels-Geschichte ist wieder genau so ein Punkt, wo ich irgendwie echte Probleme mit habe mit ideologischer Verblendung und zwar von beiden Seiten. Weil letzten Endes ist es halt so, dass der Energiegehalt von flüssigen Kohlenwasserstoffen ist durch nichts zu toppen. Also so ernsthaft nicht. Ich hab das mal ausgerechnet für meinen Fahrrad-Akku. Ich fahre einen relativ großen Fahrrad-Akku. Das ist halt so ein Ding, das hat halt so, keine Ahnung, was ist so eine Viertel-Bierkiste so ungefähr groß, wiegt irgendwie 10, 12 Kilo oder so. Ist halt eine Lithium-Eisen-Phosphat-Akku. Also halt schon ein seriöser Akku. Darf ich mal ausgerechnet, wie viel Energie steckt denn da drin, wenn ich es in Benzin umrechne? Sind 2 CL, das ist ein Schnapsglas. Nur also dimension und Gewicht. Das heißt, es ist nicht so, dass diese Idee, E-Fuels zu machen, im Sinne von da, wo wir diese Energiedichte brauchen, Autos gehören nicht dazu.
Also Flugzeuge, können wir darüber reden.
Flugzeuge ist ein Ding.
Wobei, bei den Flugzeugen ist auch nicht klar, ob das in Ordnung ist, wenn die da oben ihre Abgase halt in höheren Schichten abgeben. Da sollte man eigentlich auch gucken, ob man da nicht irgendwie...
Aber trotzdem ist es halt so, dass jetzt gerade passiert ist, halt mit diesem E-Fuels ist ja nur diese Porsche-Nummer, damit irgendwie die weiter ihre Verbrenner-Porsches irgendwie Röhr-Röhr fahren können. Führt dazu, dass die Forschung daran in Deutschland mal wieder kaputt gemacht wird. So, und dabei ist tatsächlich synthetische Kohlenwasserstoffe herstellen mit Hilfe von Katalysatoren und Solarenergie eine Sache, die wir dringend brauchen werden, weil wir nicht alles mit Batterien lösen können werden, weil wir teilweise die Energiedichten gar nicht hinbekommen, weil es teilweise total erschwachsinn ist, zwei Tonnen Akku durch die Gegend zu fahren, wo du auch einfach einen 50-Liter-Tank synthetische Kohlenwasserstoffe dahin tun könntest. So, die du mit optimaler Verbrennung auch mit einem hohen Effizienzgrad da durchziehen könntest. Das heißt also, das ist so ein Ding, was mich gerade wirklich angekotzt.
Da ist Porsche ja auch nicht dran an der optimalen Verbrennung.
Nein, aber Porsche ist nicht das Problem.
So ein Otto-Motor ist irgendwie nicht...
Das Problem ist nicht Porsche an der Stelle. Das Problem ist, dass immer in bester deutscher tradition eine Technologie, weil sie mit irgendeinem dieser Player, die sich daneben benehmt, assoziiert wird, plattgemacht wird, anstatt weiter daran zu forschen. Das wird mit Wind passiert, weil Windräder die arme Vögel auch wieder irgendwelche Umweltfreilies, die halt irgendwie gloppen.
Sag mal, ist da irgendwas dran? Das kann mir doch keiner helfen.
Nein, natürlich ist Quatsch.
Die drehen sich doch gar nicht schnell genug um so einen Vogel.
Ja, es gibt da schon Probleme. Deswegen wäre Solar viel sinnvoller. Aber Solare wurde auch platt gemacht, weil Hill kriegen ja Billige aus China. Und außerdem, irgendeine Solarfabrik hatte mal ein Umweltproblem mit irgendeinem Abwasser. Das ist halt das Problem. Und das ist halt dieser Grund, dieses Grundproblem, was ich mit diesen Leuten wie dieser Deutschen Umwelthilfe habe. Das ist da kein strategisches Denken gibt, sondern ein kurzfristiges Spendenoptimierungsding. Und sie versuchen immer, möglichst bei allem alles, was irgendwie so aussieht, als wenn es mal ein bisschen größer gedachter Fortschritt wäre, platz zu machen. Da habe ich ein Problem. Das ist von der anderen Seite genau das selbe Problem. Da hast du Leute, die Umwelt- und Klimaschutz als ein Herr-in-Herser, dieser Kleinkram da nebenbei, den können wir doch mal ignorieren, weil uns geht es ja um das große Ganze. Aber es findet halt keine sinnhafte Abwägung statt und keine Überlegung zu sagen, lass uns mal da weiter dran forschen. Deswegen haben wir keine Speichertechnologien. Warum haben wir keine Speichertechnologien? Weil Power-to-Gas zum Beispiel ist ja genau das selbe Ding. Wir haben jetzt auf der einen Seite diese Regierungsfantasten, die sagen so, die Wasserstoffwirtschaft wird uns alle retten. Auf der anderen Seite haben wir die Leute, die sagen sehr, mit diesem Wasserstoff wird ohnehin nie was, es kann nie was werden, weil der pfeift durch alle Dichtungen und der Druck und bla, und es wird sowieso alles nichts. Und guckt hier die Effizienzbetrachtungen an und die wasserstoff-kara-folion-di kostet irgendwie 80.000 Euro. Ja Herrgott, das ist vielleicht gerade so. Aber das heißt doch nicht, dass wir daran aufhören sollten zu forschen und zu entwickeln. Das sind Technologien, die wir alle, alle, alle brauchen werden. Jeden einzelnen von diesen Technologien, egal ob es jetzt Wasserstoff ist, bessere Akkus, Wärmespeicher, synthetische Kohlenwasserstoffe, werden die einfach mal alle brauchen. Die Welt ist zu groß und zu komplex, um sie mit einer Silver Bullet Technologie zu erschießen.
Gut, aber dann kann ich ja meine, meine Verachtung für Porsche einfach umlenken. Dann bin ich jetzt nicht sauer auf Porsche, weil sie mit E-Fuels irgendwie eine Mogelpackung machen wollten, sondern weil sie indirekt verhindert haben, dass da Forschung gemacht wird. Kann aber doch auf dieselben Leute sauer sein.
Beziehungsweise halt Forschung in die falsche Richtung getrieben wird.
Also weißt du, mein Problem ist ja auch nicht daran zu forschen, sondern das dann zu tanken. Ich finde das eine tolle Idee, irgendwie OCO2 aus der Luft zu ziehen. Und das würde ich dann aber in so ein Salzbergwerk per tanken oder keine Ahnung sequestrieren irgendwo. Das willst du dann nicht wieder verbrennen.
Also ganz ehrlich, momentan sind Elektroautos ein reiches Spielzeug. Von meinen Bekannten kann sich vielleicht 5% ein Elektroauto leisten. Die in vielen Stellen gibt es momentan und auch noch auf die nächsten 10 oder 15 Jahre hin. Keine ökonomische, und zwar im Sinne von des privaten Cash Flows, von dem, was die Leute an Geld haben, was sie von ihrem Gehalt leisten können. Alternative für viele Leute. Transporter zum Beispiel, Camper. Ein Freund fragte mich neulich, sag mal, wenn du deinen alten Camper irgendwie, wenn du den abgestößt, dann kaufst du doch irgendwie bestimmt ein Elektro-Auto, nicht so. Von was? So wie, wenn die Transporter, die irgendwie auch nur so ansatzweise in der Reichweitenkategorie sind, die kosten irgendwie fast 100.000 Euro. Das ist ein Luxusauto. Der gesamte Automarkt, also was wir an Neuwagen haben, ist ein Bruchteil von dem, was wir an Gebrauchtautos haben. Und warum? Weil die Leute es halt auch bezahlen können müssen. Und vor diesem Hintergrund wäre tatsächlich E-Fuels ein Fortschritt. Es wäre tatsächlich eine Möglichkeit, jetzt relativ zügig dafür zu sorgen, dass man die existierende Verbrennerflotte, und die wird halt noch eine ganze Weile existieren. Alleine deswegen, weil wir jedes Jahr zwar eine million Autos produzieren, aber da fahren einfach mal nochmal 50 millionen andere Autos rum.
Na, aber du kannst doch nicht in die, auch nur in diese Liga kommen, preismäßig, wie das einfach aus dem Boden sprudeln lassen.
Na natürlich kommst du da hin.
Du musst da, du musst dich da erzeugen.
Du hast gerade einen Liter Diesel, das kostet gerade 1,80 Euro. So, der Preis wird vermutlich nicht weiterfallen. Ja, so, es ist halt so, also sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass er weiterfällt. Oder vielleicht denn mal kurzfristig. Wieso sollte, wenn wir Solarenergie für irgendwie drei bis sechs Cent die Kilowattstunde haben, es nicht möglich sein, zu demselben Preis einen Liter Diesel zu produzieren? Es gibt keinen Grund.
Naja, also ich, es gibt bei der ETH Zürich auf dem Dach so eine testinstallation, da kommt irgendwie so was wie pro Woche eine Tasse raus, wenn ich das jetzt richtig in Erinnerung habe. Also das Verfahren gibt es einfach noch nicht, was das leisten soll, überhaupt einen Liter zu machen. Und dann brauchst du ja nicht einen Liter, sondern du brauchst irgendwie Riesen.
Es gibt die Verfahren, natürlich. Also du musst halt sie halt nur mal skalieren.
So und ich meine, es müsste halt jemand, müsste man mal.
Nee, ich meine, es gibt ja auch zum Beispiel Algenbasierte Verfahren, mit denen du Diesel machen kannst. Die aus Glasröhren, in denen irgendwelche genetisch-ingeniierten Algen leben, die durch die Sonne gepumpt werden und am Ende kannst du aus diesen Algen halt Diesel machen. Gibt's, so muss man nur mal skalieren, ist immer noch drei bis sechsmal so teuer wie das, was du halt momentan aus dem Boden pumpst. Ja klar, aber weil diese Anlagen so groß sind, dass du sie irgendwie als Uni-Projekt betreibst und nicht irgendwie weil dieser so ein raffineries-produktionsstreckender Halt aufbaut. Ich will jetzt hier nicht das hohe Lied von E-Fuels singen. Ich sage nur, das ist halt eines der, also wir haben hier gerade mal gewandt.
Keine Technologie verdammen wir, wenn sie alle brauchen.
Genau, also ich meine, wenn ich jetzt mal hier so gucke, also ja Wikipedia sagt halt irgendwie, auf Benzin umgerechnet entspricht das etwa Herstellungskosten von 3,20 Euro Steuern nicht mit eingerechnet. Da sind wir jetzt gerade. Das ist sozusagen das, was wir jetzt sozusagen die, so heißt, wir sind nicht mal eine Größenordnung entfernt vom Ziel. Das ist weniger als eine Größenordnung.
Gut, eigentlich wollten wir über Propaganda zu sprechen. Wir sind ein bisschen schief abgebogen.
Na ja, wir sind nicht schief abgebogen. Wir haben schon über Propaganda geredet, also nehme ich das tatsächlich alle Seiten gerade nicht mehr sachlich argumentieren, sondern alle Seiten halt einfach nur noch Propaganda fahren. Das ist halt der Default Mode der gesellschaftlichen kommunikation. Das ist halt das geworden, was früher Bildzeiten Black Propaganda hieß. Das machen mittlerweile alle, und zwar ohne Hemmung und ohne...
Früher war das so eine taktische Sache, die hat man eingesetzt, wenn irgendwie hart waren gerade. Und heute ist halt immer und überall.
Das ist halt so der Default Mode. Und das ist halt so ein Ding, was mich auch nicht besonders optimistisch sein lässt, dass wir in der Lage sein werden, solche Veränderungen durch Änderung von Politik hinzubekommen. So, also ich glaube halt tatsächlich eher, dass halt so was wie in dem Augenblick, wo man halt Regularien aus dem Weg räumt, die kleinteilige positive Veränderung ermöglichen, dass wir dann Veränderungen sehen werden. Also so was wie die bürokratischen Hürden für Solarinselanlagen abschaffen, die halt dazu führen, dass sich jeder einfach auf seine, die Fläche, die er halt hat, oder sei es auch der Vermieter auf dem Dach, halt irgendwie, der halt einfach Solarzahlen hin tun kann, die halt einfach mal nur das Haus versorgen. Why not? So was spricht da irgendwie dagegen, außer dass irgendwelche Energiekonzerne halt ein paar Milliarden investiert haben, die dann halt nichts mehr wert sind.
Na angeblich haben sie das ja gerade aus dem Weg geräumt, die Hürden, die es da gab für Anlagen bis, ich weiß nicht, 180 Kilowattstunden oder so was, weil die... Also angeblich gab es da gerade einen Durchbruch, habe ich irgendwie noch nicht.
Es gab eine Änderung, die insbesondere die Einspeiseverordnung betrifft, um sicherzustellen, also um es zu ermöglichen, dass auch aus so Inselanlagen eingespeist werden kann. Das sind die Einspeisevergütungen, die da halt gezahlt werden, so dass es sich eigentlich nicht lohnt.
Weißt du, ich habe ja, also jetzt ein bisschen scherzhaft, aber so, habe gestern gelesen, dass in Spanien die Eiswürfel alle sind. Und dann dachte ich mir, weißt du, wenn wir hier irgendwie kein Geld für die Einspeisung kriegen, dann machst du mit der Überschussenergie halt Eiswürfel.
Du fährst die mit E-Fuel nach Spanien.
Du musst hier gar nicht nach Spanien fahren. Wir haben ja hier auch irgendwie Scheißhitze. Also das ist dann nicht so, dass es nichts gibt, was du mit der Energie sinnvoll tun könntest.
Das ist nicht klar.
Es gibt doch genug Mist zum Anhalt machen.
Gut, ich meine, es muss sich halt eben doch lohnen. Das ist halt das Problem. Die Anlagen, die dafür gebaut werden, müssen halt irgendwie finanziert werden. Das muss sich nicht lohnen, es muss finanziert werden.
Das wäre nicht einen substanziellen Unterschied. Also viele Leute sind inzwischen so weit, dass es sich nicht lohnen muss. Sie würden sogar ein bisschen Verlust in Kauf nehmen, weil sie sehen, dass die Zeiten schlimm sind und dass es nicht besser wird. Die meisten Leute wären zufrieden damit, wenn sich das nicht lohnt. Aber es soll sich rechnen. Sie möchten nicht irgendwie draufzahlen, dass andere Leute illegale Straßenrennen veranstalten, mit ihrem Energie irgendwie. Aber ich meine, auf der anderen Seite ist ja diese ganze Propagandasache eröffnet ja auch manchmal so ein bisschen Möglichkeiten. Ich fand zum Beispiel sehr auffallend, dass wir jetzt ein halbes Jahr lang nichts von Terroristen gehört haben.
Ja, bis sie mal wieder die beiden rechten Hände von Bin Laden erschossen haben.
Ja, jetzt läuft der Krieg jetzt lang genug, dass wir wieder Zeit haben, uns anderen Sachen zuzuwenden. Aber das eicht so ein bisschen, was ist denn eigentlich wirklich wichtig? Wenn sie während einem Krieg darüber berichten würden, dann ist es wohl wirklich wichtig, aber ansonsten halt nicht. Und diese ganze irgendwie, so auch der Israel-Palästina-Konflikt war jetzt ein halbes Jahr ruhig, jetzt kommt er wieder hoch.
Du meinst, der Krieg ist jetzt einfach, in der Ukraine ist jetzt einfach gesettelt genug?
Der ist jetzt einfach Teil der Normalität. Jetzt kommen wieder die anderen Meldungen. Aber du kannst halt sehen, Propaganda ist ja auch in Konkurrenz mit anderen Propagandameldungen. Du siehst jetzt halt, welche Propagandameldungen gerade wichtiger sind als andere.
Na gut, ich meine, dieser Ukraine-Krieg ist ja, wird sich ja jetzt in so einem, wie ich ja schon von der Weile mal geschrieben habe, halt in so einem Forever War-Zustand begeben. Das heißt also so ein, da gibt's von John Scalzi, gibt's die Forever War-Serie, ist halt so eine, ist ein ziemlich guter sci-fi Autor, der beschreibt da halt auch so, ich glaube, eben sind die in Mittelamerika angesiedelt, primär weil halt so Konflikte, die halt einfach...
Aus Sicht von Amerika, das sind ihre Ziele.
Die, also die halt schon immer da sind, waren und schon und immer da sein werden und die halt einfach nicht aufhören. Und die alle Tendenzen moderner Kriegführung weisen halt darauf hin, also die Berichte, die halt so mich so erreichen aus der Ukraine, sind halt so, das hätte so halt erster Weltkrieg, nur halt mit Drohnen und Electronic Warfare. Das heißt also, es gibt halt immer wieder irgendwie eine neue Wunderwaffe, die jetzt irgendwie das Kriegsblatt wenden wird, wie jetzt halt, keine Ahnung, diese Long Range Artillerie oder so, die jetzt...
Apropos Wunderwaffe, im Technikmuseum kann man eine V2 von innen sehen. Ja, also mich interessiert ja weniger so die Mechanik des Krieges, sondern die, was die Leute glauben. Ja, und meine Beobachtung im Moment ist, dass beide Seiten glauben, sie können gewinnen. Und daher gibt es keinen Ausweg durch Verhandeln, solange beide Seiten glauben, sie können gewinnen und hätten dann einen Vorteil, wenn die weiter kämpfen.
Gut, ich meine, aus Sicht der Ukraine, vollständig nachvollziehbar, ja?
Na, auch die Russen. Also bei den Russen ist es so, dass es inzwischen selbst bei Umfragen, die im Fernsehen laufen, also nicht irgendwie fringe unterdrückt, sondern Umfragen, die im Fernsehen laufen, da sagen so was wie 60 Prozent irgendwie, ja, so eigentlich. Also nur noch 60 Prozent sagen, wir machen jetzt mal weiter Krieg. Und es gibt jetzt so eine Klasse, die sich zusammengefunden hat, so nach dem Motto, na ja, wenn wir schon einmarschiert sind, dann machen wir das auch zu Ende. Aber es ist nicht so, dass die Leute aus Überzeugung finden, wir müssen jetzt mal die Ukraine platt machen, sondern es ist eher so, dass die glauben, na ja, also das ist besser, wenn wir weitermachen, als wenn wir jetzt rausgehen. Sondern es ist so eine Abwägung und sie sehen noch eine option auf einen Sieg. Und solange die Leute den sehen, wird es weiter Krieg geben. Das finde ich ziemlich offensichtlich. Da kannst du da auch nichts mit verhandeln reißen, weil beide Leute glauben, sie müssen einfach auf Zeit spielen. Sie sind ja am Gewinnen gerade.
Na gut, ich meine, aus Sicht der Ukraine...
Ja, das Weiterkämpfen ist völlig klar.
Ist halt irgendwie Verhandlung.
Ich wundere mich ja, dass die Ukraine nicht langsam stinkig wird, dass die von den Amis immer genau so viel Waffen kriegen, dass sie nicht verlieren können, aber nicht genug.
Was sollen sie tun?
Dass sie gewinnen können. Naja, die könnten zumindest mal irgendwie ein bisschen unangenehm rumbrutten machen. Wie hieß dieser Botschafter bei uns, der die ganze Zeit rumgenervt hat? Warum haben die nicht sowas in Amerika, so jemand?
Naja, weil sie nicht riskieren wollen, dass die Amis den Saft abdrehen.
Also ich meine, das können die Amis doch nicht machen.
Naja, die westliche Freiheit wird bis zum letzten Ukrainer verteidigt, aber die Balance müssen die schon irgendwie halten.
Naja, aber die Ukrainer lassen sich ja verheizen. Aber die wären halt, also ich an deren Stelle wäre wirklich ungehalten, dass ich da nur so irgendwie Verteidigungswaffen kriege.
Na, die sind froh über alles, was sie kriegen können.
Ich war jetzt ehrlich gesagt erstaunt über die Breite des Spektrums zwischen den Meldungen. Die lagen ja schon die ganze Zeit weit auseinander. Nach dem Motto, Ukraine stand in ihren Medien irgendwie kurz vor Moskau und die Russen haben kurz vor Kiev. Aber jetzt gab es halt gerade Meldungen, wo man denkt, eigentlich ist es doch jetzt so ein bisschen zettelt gerade. Da hieß es dann auf der einen Seite, die Russen sind gerade dabei, Richtung Westen weiterzugehen. Das haben irgendwie die britischen Dienste verkündet. Und gleichzeitig liest du aber im anderen Medium, dass sie keine munition mehr haben und im Donbass irgendwie ihre aktionen zurückfahren. Und ich denke mir so, können wir uns auf so eine Basisfakten einigen vielleicht?
Tatsächlich ist der Krieg ein bisschen kompliziert. Das passiert genau beides parallel.
Die haben keine munition und gehen trotzdem irgendwie weiter nach Westen?
Naja, es hängt immer davon ab, wo die Front ist ein bisschen größer.
Was wollen sie denn im Westen? Ich dachte, die Sache ist gelaufen, wenn sie den Osten unter Kontrolle haben.
Na die wollen eigentlich mindestens die Krim halten, den Landkorridor halten und halt den Osten halten.
Ja, aber jetzt heißt es halt, sie wollen nach Westen in Richtung Moldawien.
Ja genau, das dritte Kriegsziel wäre halt gewesen, Transnistrien anzuschließen, also Odessa einzunehmen und die Ukraine vom Schwarzen Meer abzuschließen. Das Problem ist halt, dass du kannst halt im Krieg eigentlich keiner Seite wirklich glauben. So, also das ist halt so dieses... Also so die Sachen, die ich jetzt aus der Ukraine höre, sind halt zum großen Teil einfach von Leuten, die vor Ort sind, die halt einfach sich die Sachen selber angucken, die zum Teil auch einfach da an der Front sind. Und das ist halt so, dass ganz viel von dem, was hier in den Medien berichtet wird, ist halt nur ein super kleiner Ausschnitt von dem, wie die Realität da vor Ort aussieht und wie die, also wie tatsächlich auch die Kriegführung aussieht. Und das hat auch damit zu tun, dass sie unglaublich schnell iteriert. Also du hast halt ein unglaubliches Tempo an Veränderungen von Taktiken. Sachen, die letzte Woche funktioniert haben, gehen plötzlich nicht mehr. Das heißt also, dass halt diesen selben Mechanismus, den wir halt an den Aktienmärkten haben, dass jede größere, jedes größere Pattern, was du halt irgendwie siehst, mit dem du halt dann mal ein paar folgliche Trades machen kannst, funktioniert halt nicht lange, weil irgendwie andere Leute darauf die Idee kommen. Genauso hast du da halt im Krieg. Das heißt, du hast halt so Taktiken, die halt irgendwie so Atelier-Einsatz mit Drohnen kombinieren oder direkt bewachnete Drohnen oder Einpeilen von Mobiltelefonen und so weiter, die dann halt wiederum für Atlerieschläge benutzt werden. So das funktioniert halt immer nicht lange. Es funktioniert halt eine Weile. Und bis die Gegenseite dann halt verstanden hat, wie das Pattern funktioniert und sich gegenaktionen ausdenkt. Und wenn man sich die Geschichte von so relativ statischen Konflikten anguckt, also insbesondere in erster Weltkrieg, wo man da ein bisschen mehr reinzoomt, also bis runter so auf quasi einzelne Frontabschnitte, würde ich mal so sagen, oder auch einzelne, also jedenfalls so die, wie schnell sich da Sachen verändert haben, als plötzlich Panzer auftauchten oder große Mengen Maschinengewehre verfügbar waren oder plötzlich Atlerie mit großer Reichweite verfügbar war. Und jedes Mal war es so ein, ja jetzt haben wir die Wunderwaffe, die den Krieg wenden wird. Also wenn du die Sachen von damals liest, auch so Tagebücher oder auch so offizielle Militärgeschichte oder jetzt aktuelle Militärgeschichte, die ja die Archive durchgearbeitet haben, dann siehst du wirklich wortwörtlich zum Teil dieselben Sachen. Also wirklich so dieses so jetzt haben wir die neue Wunder-Atlerie, die halt irgendwie, damit können wir irgendwie die munitionsdepost des Feindes hinter der Front irgendwie abschießen. So näher konnten sie dann ein paar Wochen lang. Bis sich dann der Feind halt überlegt hat, okay, dann machen wir keine großen munitionsdepost mehr. Sondern bewegen, das ist halt irgendwie anders. Oder hier jetzt haben wir halt irgendwie unsere tollen neuen Panzer, mit denen wir halt irgendwie den Durchbruch schaffen werden durch den durch den Frontabschnitt und dieser mörderische Meatgrinder von Stellungskrieg wird endlich durchbrochen werden durch die neue Wunderwaffe Panzer. Na was kam halt denn ab, es wird Panzerabwehrgeschütze.
Im Moment haben wir ja in der Ukraine diese Geschichte mit dem Atomkraftwerk, was die Russen besetzt haben sollen, wo dann die internationale Atomenergiebehörde irgendwie Memos verschickt hat, so nach dem Motto, ja die lassen unsere Inspektoren nicht mehr gucken, die haben die Sensoren abgeklemmt. Hast du da irgendwie was von Leuten, die da in der Nähe wohnen gehört? Das finde ich eine sehr unklare situation, was da gerade tatsächlich passiert und wie viel Sorgen man sich machen muss.
Da muss ich da schon Sorgen machen, weil die...
Beide Seiten haben behauptet, die jeweils anderen hätten auf das Atomkraftwerk geschossen, was ja schon so ein bisschen doof ist.
Na gut, es geht um Supply Röschner und die Russen haben dieses Atomkraftwerk erobert. Also besetzt, muss man sagen. Die haben... Da gibt es auch Videos von... Das war so der eine Moment von diesem ganzen Ukrainenkrieg, wo ich wirklich, wirklich schlecht geschlafen habe, wo die Russen halt sich... Also die wurden halt mehrfach aufgehalten, auch von der lokalen Bevölkerung, auf der einen Zufahrtsstraße, weil die sich heute auf die Straße gestellt haben und sagten, wenn ihr da ins Kraftwerk fahren wollt, dann müsst ihr irgendwie über uns rüberfahren. Und zwar du da. Du in dem Panzer musst jetzt über mich rüberfahren, wenn du dieses Atomkraftwerk willst. Und es hat die eine Weile aufgehalten. Am Ende haben sie es umgangen und haben dieses Atomkraftwerk erobert. Die Ukraine haben halt irgendwann den Kampf eingestellt, weil sie halt gesehen haben, okay, die Russen machen sich nicht so viel Gedanken darüber, dass jetzt da etwa sechs laufende Atomreaktoren sind. Sondern es waren zwei damals noch, vier waren shutdown. Es gibt also Video und ich hab's live im Stream gesehen, weil die Videokamera auf dem Verwaltungsgebäude von diesem Atomkraftwerk online war. Man konnte also live zugucken, wie die Russen da halt mit Schützenpanzer waren in dieses Atomkraftwerk rein sind und geschossen haben und also wirklich auch in ein Gebäude in Brand geschossen haben. Bis die Ukranierinnen halt aufgegeben haben. Man konnte im Internet live zugucken, wie ein in Betrieb befindliches Atomkraftwerk unter einsatzscharfer Waffen erobert wurde. Das war nicht so gut für den Kopf. Das war dann halt auch so, wo ich mich dann eine Nacht lang beschäftigt habe, wo gibt es denn eigentlich simulationen über irgendwie Fallout-Ausbreitung?
Da gibt es tolle Webseiten, da trägst du eine position, irgendwie Megawatt.
Naja, und vor allen Dingen die aktuelle Windrichtung in verschiedenen Höhenlagen ist ja das Problem. Kacke, man hat ja dann auch noch relativ schnell einen Fallout-Wind-Simulator irgendwie in seine Webseite reingegangen. Jedenfalls, die Lage ist halt so, dass die Russen haben die ukrainische Atomkraftwerksbesatzung da festgehalten unter extrem menschenunwürdigen Bedingungen und haben denen gesagt, ihr macht jetzt hier Arbeit, jetzt hier weiter. Und jetzt haben sie, und dieses Kraftwerk versorgt, immer noch ein Großteil der Ukraine. Und jetzt haben sie aber halt, quasi benutzen sie dieses Atomkraftwerk als ein Mittel der Erpressung. Das heißt, die haben da Atlerichtstellungen hingetan und beschießen die Ukrainer vom Gelände des Atomkraftwerks aus. Mit Atlerie. Weil sie wissen, dass wenn die Ukrainer zurückschießen, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit groß, dass sie einen eigenen Reaktor treffen.
Okay, das heißt, die Ukraine könnte jetzt aber theoretisch sagen wir mal, den gesamten Strom einfach nicht mehr abnehmen. Und dann müssten die Russen das Kraftwerk ausschalten, weil sie...
Würde auch nicht viel ändern, weil da ist genug radioaktivität und genug Brennstoff, dass...
Ja, aber es wäre dann immerhin eine Dirty Bomb und nicht irgendwie...
Da kannst du nicht wissen, weil du es irgendwie in einen Atomreaktor triffst, in dem noch Brennstäbe drin sind. Da wird keiner irgendeine Vorhersage machen, was dann passiert.
So wie Scheiße.
So, das heißt also, die Russen benutzen quasi dieses Atomkraftwerk als Erpressungsmaterial, Faust, Pfand, Safe Zone in dem Sinne. Und die Ukrainer sind jetzt halt in der misslichen Lage, dass sie halt, wenn sie dieses Problem weg haben wollen, wird es halt ein unglaublich teurer Infanterieangriff werden, den sie halt ohne schwere Waffen führen müssen. Ja, das ist halt so die Lage da gerade. Und es gibt wohl einzelne Berichte, ich weiß nicht, wie glaubwürdig die sind, dass sie zumindest Einheiten um das Atomkraftwerk mit präzisionswaffen angegriffen haben, also wo sie sozusagen gesagt haben, okay, wir sind uns hinreichend sicher, dass die Rakete A, klein genug ist, um nicht die Hülle zu geschlagen, und B, halt genau genug ist, dass sie nicht in den Reaktor fällt. Das ist wahrscheinlich das, was damit gemeint ist, dass die Russen gesagt haben, die Ukraine hätten das Kraftwerk beschossen, aber das ist Fog of War, kann man nicht genau sagen, ob das jetzt wirklich, also welche Sache dazu trifft. Aber das sind halt so diese üblichen Sachen, die halt in so einem Krieg passieren, dass beide Seiten versuchen, sich so irgendeine Art von Vorteil zu verschaffen in einem relativ statischen Konflikt, wo beide Seiten eigentlich nicht stark genug sind, um jetzt den großen Durchbruch zu erzielen. Also am Ersten Weltkrieg gab es sowas auch, Giftgasangriffe. Giftgasangriffe waren genau das, das war genau der Versuch, diese statische situation zu durchbrechen. Das ist halt so ein Ding, was da wir jetzt aus der wirtschaftlichen Sicht heraus eine situation haben, wo die große Frage aus Sicht des Westens eigentlich nur ist, wird die westliche Rüstungsindustrie schnell genug hochgefahren, um die Ukraine dauerhaft zu versorgen? Versus wie lange halten die Russen gegen die Embargos durch? Das ist sozusagen die Metafrage, die hier so ein bisschen dahinter steht. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich trau mir nicht, zu deiner Prognose abzugeben, weil zum einen ist halt so die Geschwindigkeit, mit der die westliche Rüstungsindustrie von so einem Manufakturbetrieb auf ernsthafte, ernsthaften produktionsausstoß umgestellt wird, ist mir gerade nicht so richtig erschließlich oder sichtlich gefühlt. Nicht besonders schnell.
Du, ich war erstaunt, wie klein offenbar die Lager der westlichen Militärs sind.
Ja, und die produktionsraten.
Nicht nur die produktion, die haben ja auch nichts auf Lager gehabt. Also wenn hier irgendwie ein Krieg gewesen wäre, hätten wir auch nichts gehabt. Nicht nur wir, also die NATO hätte irgendwie...
Die Amis haben halt, zumindest was Atelier angeht, haben die halt noch große Reserven so. Aber die westliche Kriegsindustrie...
Aber das sind auch Erlenkraketen bei denen, wenn die sind, oder?
Nee, nee, die haben auch richtig normale Atelier. Aber die westliche Rüstungsindustrie funktioniert bisher nach dem Prinzip, alle fünf bis sieben Jahre gibt es einen größeren Konflikt. Und in der Zeit dazwischen füllen wir langsam mal die Lager wieder auf. Und die Bundeswehr geht ja sowieso nach, die zynischen Kommentare der anderen Militärs über die Bundeswehr sind so, ja, ist halt immer noch wie früher, die können halt Blitzkrieg irgendwie, wenn es nach drei Monaten nicht vorbei ist, dann ist da nicht mehr viel. Wenn du jetzt dann guckst, diese Panzerhubitze 2000, das war ja wohl echt eine Lachnummer.
Ja, bei unseren Tests haben wir nur so 100 Schuss gemacht pro Tag.
Genau.
Und die Ukraine so halt Dauerfeuer natürlich, weil es halt ein Krieg ist.
Also darauf ist das Gerät aber nicht ausgelegt.
Wie mit dem G36. Anyway, also jedenfalls diese Frage, wenn man sich so westliche Rüstungsindustrie anguckt, ist das halt an vielen Stellen Manufakturbetrieb. Das heißt, da werden halt eine medrascher Fertigung. Es wird auch so wie Hochglanz-Dinger.
Weißt du, das sieht im Prospekt gut aus, aber mehr halt nicht.
Nee, die können schon was. Also ich meine, deutsche Rüstungsindustrie muss man klar sagen. Also an vielen Stellen sind die wirklich führend. So das Problem ist halt, also das jetzige Problem für die militärstrategische Ausrichtung des Westens in diesem Ukraine-Krieg ist halt nur, alles, was da gemacht wird an so Lenkwaffen oder hochentwickelten Flugabwehrsystemen, aber auch bis runter zu panzern, ist halt Manufakturbetrieb. Da werden halt so Dutzende pro Monat per Hand zusammengeschraubt. Das heißt also, wir sind da nicht in einem Stadium, wo jetzt irgendwie wie so ein VW Wolfsburg da halt irgendwo so ein Werk steht, wo halt dann jeden Tag ein paar tausend Lenkraketen rausfallen. Das gibt es halt nicht. Das hat niemand. Das ist eine nicht existierende technische Anlage. Es gibt auch kein Werk, wo jeden Tag 25 oder 30 Panzer vom Bahn fahren. Haben wir nicht.
So, wenn wir früher fuhren, also die Russen haben sowas, aber die kriegen die Supply Chain nicht.
Auch bei denen fahren keine 30, 40 Panzer am Tag vom Band. Das ist halt auch langsamer. So und weil sind halt irgendwie, muss halt im Vergleich zu früher zum zweiten Weltkrieg, was so der letzte massenproduktionskrieg war, da war es halt natürlich so, dass halt die gesamte Wirtschaft darauf umgestellt wurde. Und dass also der Anteil der Kriegswirtschaft an Bord und Sozialprodukt dann halt auch einfach ein signifikanter, zweistelliger Prozentsatz war. Also in Deutschland glaube ich sogar über 60 Prozent. Also Nazi-Deutschland waren halt glaube ich über 60 Prozent. Bord und Sozialprodukt war halt, das Bord und Landsprodukt war halt Kriegswirtschaft. Selbst in Amiland war es über ein Drittel, also brutal groß. Und die haben ja in den USA, wenn man sich so anguckt, den Moment, wo die USA sich auf den Kriegsantritt vorbereiten, dann sind hier hingegangen und sind zu ihren Autounternehmen gegangen und zu ihren sonstigen Großindustrieen gesagt, was müssen wir denn tun, um mal eine Umstellung auf kriegsproduktion zu machen? Wie können wir denn Panzer so schnell produzieren wie Cadillacs? Und dann sind die ja zu Cadillac gegangen, gesagt ihr baut jetzt mal Panzer. Dann hat Cadillac halt Panzer gebaut, wie sie vorher halt Autos gebaut haben. Aber dieser Moment ist nicht da. Also diesen Moment haben wir momentan nicht. Und man kann sich darüber streiten, ob es gut oder schlecht ist. Also wirklich einfach nur sagen, es ist jetzt nicht da. Wir haben nicht die industrielle Fertigungskapazität für die spezifische kriegsproduktion, die jetzt da gebraucht wird, um momentan, wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht, was gerade passiert, aber das, was ich gerade sehe, sieht nicht so aus, um Russland da halt quasi tot zu rüsten. Das ist halt auch der Grund, warum die Ukrainer so wenig kriegen, weil da ist halt zum Teil einfach auch nicht viel.
Ich habe ja den Eindruck gehabt bei jetzt bei der Luftabwehr, bei dem G-Part weiß ich es nicht so. Aber der Eindruck war, die Panzer, die wir denen geben, sind zwar die letzte generation, aber die Bundeswehr hat selber auch nichts Neues, sondern das ist alles noch irgendwie in der Planung. Meinst du, wir halten da Sachen zurück, weil die einfach irgendwie zu high-tech sind und das irgendwie...
Nee, also die Bundeswehr hat irgendwie die Beschaffung eines neuen integrierten Luftabwehrsystems letzten Jahrzehnte halt einfach verpennt. Das war halt so nach dem Ende des Kalten Krieges, wussten die halt nicht mehr so richtig, was brauchen wir jetzt eigentlich für Luftabwehr? Und hat dementsprechend halt endlose Jahre mit irgendwie neuen spezifikationen und Studien und so weiter zugebracht. Das ist was, was halt der momentan, also sozusagen der Weltmarktführer in diesem Bereich ist halt irgendwie ISIS, Iris, Entschuldigung, Iris, was es in verschiedenen Varianten gibt, sowohl zum ans Flugzeug schnallen, als auch zum vom Boden aus anwenden und so. Und das sind halt, sagen wir mal so von Luftabwehr, Lenkflugkörpern schon so top of the game so. Die Ukraine hat die auch jetzt angeboten bekommen. Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass sie die aus Bundeswehr bestimmt angeboten bekommen hat, sondern vom Hersteller. Weil die Bundeswehr hat bisher davon nur so quasi so ein Proof of Concept und so ein Demonstrator so beschafft. Und das ist halt genau so ein Ding, was halt an ganz vielen Stellen man sieht. Also die Bundeswehr wurde systematisch kriegsunfähig abgerüstet. Das heißt also in einer Welt, in der wir keinen Krieg mehr hätten, haben die Consultants ganze Arbeit geleistet. Das heißt also, da wäre halt tatsächlich also die systematische Kriegsunfähigkeit der Bundeswehr ist eigentlich sichergestellt zum momentanen Zeitpunkt.
Ja, das ist ein hervorragender, einen guten Job haben die gemacht.
Haben die einen guten Job gemacht. So in der Welt, in der es jetzt wieder Krieg gibt, ist halt die Frage, ist das halt noch die richtige, also ist das halt das, was man haben will und braucht? Ich bin da tatsächlich zwiegespalten. So einerseits bin ich halt von meiner Grundüberzeugung her Pazifist, auf der anderen Seite.
Wir müssen einfach McKinsey nach Russland schicken. Das dauert dann so ein bisschen, aber das ist am nachhaltigsten.
Das ist eher so ein bisschen ein Langfristprojekt, aber es wäre tatsächlich einfach so einfach so McKinsey nach Russland und China schicken, um sicherzustellen, dass es überstrukturierte Kriegsunfähigkeit gibt.
Genau, und so ein bisschen Compliance-Experten hinterher, damit auch cyber schön in den Boden gerammt wird.
Ja, das wäre auf jeden Fall der richtige Ansatz dabei.
Warum wirken denn die Russen gerade so schwach, wenn wir der Ukraine nur Schrott liefern?
Wir liefern nicht nur Schrott, wir liefern denen nur das, was wir haben, in kleinen Stückzahlen. Also ich meine, das stimmt auch wiederum nicht. Also ich meine, einiges davon, was wir da liefern, ist schon Zeug, was man bisher auch noch nicht so richtig gesehen hat. Also gerade so die fortgeschrittenen Panzerabwehrminen und auch...
Also die präzisionsartillerie hat wohl die Russen echt überzeugt. Da ging so ein Video rum, wie die gestaunt haben auf so einer Brücke, wo du halt die Einschläge sehen konntest und die waren jeweils so unter einem Meter von voneinander entfernt.
Ja, also meine, klar, also das ist halt schon so ein Zeug, was der Westen dahin liefert, ist halt zum Teil alt, aber in der Regel halt nicht Schrott. Und man muss halt auch klar sagen, vieles davon ist halt auch endlos overingeniert, weil es halt 30 Jahre Lagerzeit in der spezifikation stehen hat.
Also ich habe mich ja mehrfach amüsiert, als es dann hieß. Irgendwie, ja, also das Gerät haben wir geliefert, aber die munition, die die Norweger geliefert haben, geht nicht in unsere Artillerie. Da muss irgendwie ein Software Update eingespielt werden. Und da so, ey, die Jungs wirklich? Ja, aber so ist das halt. So ist das heute auf dem Battlefield.
Naja, ich meine, die munition wird halt beim Schuss aus dem Lauf programmiert. Und wenn da halt die Datenfelder nicht passen, dann passen halt die Datenfelder nicht, das ist halt doof.
Hätten sie mal XML genommen?
Ich fürchte, die haben da XML genommen.
Ja, aber warum sieht denn die Russen so schlecht aus? Oder ist das Propaganda?
Das ist scherz zu sagen. Also ich glaube, dass die Russen haben halt mehrere Probleme. Eines davon ist, dass sie, glaube ich, das Level an korruption, was sie da haben, massiv unterschätzt haben. Also ich glaube, die russische Führung wusste schon, dass sie ein extrem korruptes Militär haben. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass sie wussten, dass es so korrupt ist. Das zweite Problem ist, dass der Anteil des russischen Militärs, der auf ein professionalitätsniveau gehoben wurde bei den letzten Reformen, dass es so adäquat für so einen Krieg ist, war halt klein. Also damals, als die Krim eingenommen haben, haben alle ein bisschen gestorben, so was, das kriegen die Russen hin? So eine operation, wo sie quasi plötzlich da sind und irgendwie kaum ernsthafte Kampfhandlungen stattfinden und die schaffen es halt mal so, schwuppdiwuppdiwipp, die Krim einzunehmen. Und das hat niemand, hatte niemand den Russen damals zugetraut. Na ja, war halt dann so, dass die Einzahl der Einheiten, die das halt konnten, also die halt quasi so eine super gut durchgeplante Special forces-operation machen konnten, war halt auch nicht so riesengroß. Die brauchten halt auch nicht so viel für die Krim dafür. Die sind halt, glaube ich, zum einen Opfer des Glaubens an die Wirksamkeit ihrer eigenen Propaganda geworden und des Glaubens an die Wirksamkeit ihrer infiltration. Also die sind da, glaube ich, wirklich hingefahren mit irgendwie unsere Infiltratoren haben dieses Land eigentlich im wesentlichen Schnelles. Wir müssen nur hinfahren und uns einsammeln und so.
Es gab ja die Meldung am Anfang, dass die ihre Dressuniformen dabei hatten in den Panzern, weil sie annahmen, es gäbe gar keine Gefechte, sondern die würden da halt einfach empfangen als Befreier.
Die haben halt einfach nicht dafür geplant, dass es halt irgendwie so ein unglaublich hingezogener, langer, ultra-blutiger Konflikt wird und sich entsprechend auch nicht vorbereitet. Das heißt aber nicht, dass das halt nicht passieren kann. Ich meine, bei den Russen ist es glaube ich so ähnlich wie mit dem Westen. Am Beginn jedes Krieges, der halt irgendwie angefangen wurde, hast du halt immer diese optimistische Einschätzung, wie wann es halt vorbei ist. Das ist in jedem modernen Konflikt. Also seit...
Nicht nur in modernen, glaube ich.
Also ich kenne jetzt so die Sachen von vor 1870, kenne ich nicht so gut, aber bis dahin so, die kenne ich ganz gut, die Kriege. Und in jedem dieser Kriege hast du halt die Erwartung, dass es relativ schnell vorbei ist. Und wenn es dann nicht so ist, waren alle Seiten immer sehr unangenehm überrascht. Und dann hat es einen Augenblick gedauert, also in der Regel so was wie ein bis zwei Jahre, bis die Realität sich manifestiert hat, dass man diesen Krieg jetzt ein paar Jahre machen wird und entsprechend die Wirtschaft und die ganzen Strukturen halt so umstellt, dass es halt auch die Mobilisierungsstrukturen für die Armee, die indokrination der Bevölkerung, um den Nachwuchs für die Armee sicherzustellen, die indoktrination der Geschäftswelt, also der Business People, um sicherzustellen, dass die Unterstützung der Unternehmen für diesen Krieg da ist und so weiter. Das hat halt immer eine Weile gedauert. Und das glaube ich auch so ein Ding, das wir jetzt auf beiden Seiten sehen, dass also diese, je länger dieser Konflikt sich hinzieht oder diese russische invasion in der Ukraine sich hinzieht, ich muss mal beim korrekten Wörding bleiben, desto mehr wird dieses Einstellen auf diesen Krieg und diese Umstellung der sowohl der Gesellschaft als auch der Wirtschaft auf die Ziele dieses Krieges auf beiden Seiten passieren.
Na, aber wenn du jetzt von Jahren redest, das ist ja nun deutlich hinter dem Wirkungs, hoffentlich irgendwie Spektrum von so sanktionen. Können die so lange aushalten, die Russen?
Na klar, die westlichen sanktionen sind totally overrated. Ich meine, das ist halt so, also ganz ehrlich, dieses Gerede von wegen hier, unsere gassanktionen werden die Russen dekniert. Deswegen ist das völliger Bullshit. Klar, möglicherweise wird es halt irgendwie dazu führen, dass sie ein paar Rassfelder ausmachen müssen und vielleicht werden die auch nicht wieder angehen. Das kann alles sein.
Aber die Russen kriegen halt auch keine Elektronik mehr eingeführt und so. Also ist ja schon so ein bisschen mehr.
Die Überlegung, dass sanktionen dazu führen, dass ein Land nicht mehr in der Lage ist, sein Militär zu betreiben, bietet die jüngere Vergangenheit hinreichend viele Anhaltspunkte dafür, dass die Bullshit sind. Der Iran beliefert die russische Armee jetzt mit Drohnen. Das heißt, die Iraner, die nun wirklich unter den härtesten sanktionen, die die Welt so zu bieten hat, sind gerade, sind in der Lage, Drohnen zu bauen, die besser sind, als was die Russen gerade selber bauen können. Nur mal so als Benchmark für wie wirksam sanktionen angeblich sind. Nordkorea hat es unter einem sanktionsregime, was genauso hart ist wie das gegen Iran, geschafft, nicht nur Atomwaffen zu bauen, eine Wasserstoffbombe zu bauen, sondern auch noch das wahrscheinlich von so Mini-Staaten effizienteste Cyber-Angriffscore aufzubauen, auszubilden und in Betrieb zu halten, sodass ein Profit-Center geworden ist, weil diese ganzen Kryptobüro-Nummern da leer räumen.
Wollt ja gerade sagen, die zahlen für sich selbst.
So, und dann will mir jemand erzählen, dass wir es schaffen, mit sanktionen Russland in die Knie zu zwingen. Bullshit. Natürlich, sanktionsbrechen, sanktionsumgehen, alle denken mal, die Russen müssen sich ja dann eine neue Elektronikwirtschaft aufbauen und so weiter. Ja, völliger Unsinn. Ich meine, was haben wir gerade gesehen hier? Diese Iskander, die sie gerade auseinandergenommen haben.
Ja, mit der ganzen Westelektronik.
Ja, aber das Westelektronik von vor 30 Jahren, und die fliegen trotzdem. Da ist nur ein bisschen modernerer Glonass-Empfänger drinnen, aber der Rest läuft auch nur auf einem 386er. Na klar, kannst du da mit Waffen bauen. Also ist das jetzt nicht so, dass... Ja, natürlich, die Russen haben jetzt Probleme, dass sie irgendwie keine Ahnung, keine Schmierlager für ihre Panzer zusammenkriegen, weil sie halt so blöd waren, das halt nicht selber zu produzieren. Denkst du, das wird die davon abhalten, das auf die Reihe zu kriegen? Denkst du, das wird die Chinesen irgendwo abhalten, nicht mal die Augen zuzudrücken, wenn irgendjemand diese Gleitlager schmuggeln will? Der Iran ist in der Lage, Drohnen zu bauen. Der Iran ist in der Lage, Atomwaffen zu bauen, wenn sie unbedingt wollen. Und die sind sanktioniert bis zum Gettner. Nein, das wird nicht passieren. Das sanktionsregime führt zu nichts anderem, als dass die Russen ein bisschen länger brauchen. Das ist das Einzige, was du damit kaufen kannst, dass die Russen länger brauchen und dass sie zwischendurch bestimmte Waffenarten nicht in dem Maße zur Verfügung haben werden. Das ist nicht wirkungslos. Es ist schon so, dass es klar ist, dass jetzt insbesondere moderne atleri-munitionen bei den Russen auch langsam knapp werden, dass deren Lenkwaffen knapp werden, dass sie jetzt anfangen, tatsächlich Luftabwehr-Raketen, also irgendwie Boden-Boden-Raketen, einzusetzen, weil sie halt nicht mehr so viel Rumliegen haben, was sie nicht in Reserve halten wollen, für den Fall, dass der Konflikt noch mal eskaliert uns mit der NATO losgeht. Muss man auch mal bedenken, dass die Russen jetzt nicht all-out machen, weil sie halt davon ausgehen müssen, dass die Sache so weit eskalieren kann, dass sie in einen Krieg mit der NATO kommen und dann wollen sie halt nicht nackig dastehen. Das ist übrigens auch einer der Gründe, warum die NATO nicht alles liefert, was sie hat, weil würdest du darauf wetten, dass das nicht noch größer wird? Ich nicht.
Wie ist denn das mit den Atomdrohungen von Russen? Muss man da nicht ernst nehmen?
Naja, also die Russen haben ja eine Nuklear-Doktrin, die sie neulich geupdatet haben, vor ein paar Jahren, zwei oder so. Und da habe ich mir die Mühe gemacht, die mal zu lesen, weil das war mir schon irgendwie wichtig für die Alten-Meinbildung. Und ich habe die neulich noch mal nachgelesen, als der Krieg losging. Und die Russen haben...
Aber das war doch sogar noch eine Verschärfung, von wegen noch weniger Vorwand, die einzusetzen.
Naja, die Doktrin ist, würde ich jetzt, kann man nicht so in einem Attraktiv zusammenfassen, ist ein bisschen komplexer. Im Endeffekt sagen sie, dass sie Atomwaffen nicht einsetzen, es sei denn, es findet ein Angriff gegen russisches Territorium statt, der mit konventionellen Mitteln nicht aufgehalten werden kann. Oder die Integrität des russischen Staates bedroht. So, und jetzt kommen wir halt zu diesem, zu so ein paar blöden Details. Dass die Russen die eroberten Gebiete, also die besetzten Gebiete in der Ukraine, möglichst schnell russifizieren wollen, also quasi sagen, wir machen hier eine Abstimmung, wollt ihr irgendwie haben, ins russische Reich, und dann werden alle erschossen, die nicht mit Ja stimmen, und dann wird es halt irgendwie in Russland angeschlossen, führt dazu, dass de facto diese Gebiete unter den russischen Atomdrohschirm kommen. Das heißt also, dass in dem Augenblick, wo sozusagen diese Gebiete als offiziell russisch deklariert sind und die Ukrainer versuchen, die zurückzuerobern, die Russen nach ihrer eigenen Nukleardoktrin sich sozusagen das Recht zurecht definiert haben, taktische Atomwaffen einzusetzen.
Na gut, aber die Doktrin ist ja nun nichts, was sie tatsächlich faktisch zurückhalten würde. Die könnten sie auch irgendwie kurzfristig ändern.
Naja, diese Doktrin...
Ist das eine reelle Bedrohung, meinst du, dass die da rumnuken würden?
Eine Nukleardoktrin macht man... Eine Nukleardoktrin ist wie ein Ehevertrag. Den machst du, also eine Nukleardoktrin schreibst du zu Zeiten, wo du in Ruhe sorgfältig und lange drüber nachdenken kannst und nicht, wenn du im Stress bist. Also nicht, wenn halt der Konflikt schon losgegangen ist. Und das machst du aus gutem Grund. Das machst du nämlich, weil du sicher sein willst, dass wenn du halt, also wenn die Kacke am Dampfen ist, dass du über alle wesentlichen Probleme schon mal nachgedacht hast, alles durchgespielt hast und dafür Lösungen gefunden hast, die du aufgeschrieben hast und die du dich hältst, die das optimale Outcome für deine Ziele sind. So, dafür schreibt man Nukleardoktrin. Deswegen, so sind auch die westlichen Nukleardoktrin geschrieben.
Ja natürlich, aber da kannst du dich jetzt nicht wirklich drauf. Ja, aber es gibt irgendwie, da können wir jetzt nicht klagen, wenn sie sich nicht dran haben.
Nee, aber der Punkt ist, dass eine Nukleardoktrin führt, ist halt also...
Also du meinst, sie halten sich da schon dran.
Eine offizielle Nukleardoktrin ist auch eine Versicherung, also sie hat mehrere Aufgaben. Zum einen sagt sie dem Gegner, wo sind deine roten Linien? Also pass auf, wenn du mich hier bis hierhin an die Wand zurückdrängst, sehe ich mich willens in der Lage, Nuklearwaffen einzusetzen. Das ist halt diese russische türtholme-definition. Das Zweite ist, damit wird impliziert eine Abschreckung. Das heißt, du sagst nicht, ich habe Nuklearwaffen, ich werde sie nicht einsetzen, sondern hier sind meine Regeln, nach denen ich meine Nuklearwaffen einsetzen werde. Also du versicherst deinem Gegner, ich habe Nuklearwaffen und ich werde sie einsetzen, wenn ich mich dazu genötigt sehe. Die dritte Aufgabe von so einer Nukleardoctrin ist, dass man darüber auch seine eigenen Leute, also quasi einen eigenen General und so weiter und so fort, ein bisschen, das heißt nicht ein bisschen hart an die Kondare nimmt und sagt so, pass auf, ihr könnt euch nicht darauf verlassen, dass euch die Nukleartropen raushauen werden, wenn ihr dann Scheiß baut. Das wird nicht passieren, sondern nur unter diesen Regeln, die wir uns hier selber gesetzt haben. So für alles andere seid ihr zuständig, dafür seid ihr mit den konventionellen Streitkräften zuständig. Das heißt also, dass die Einsatzhürden, die definiert sind in so einer Nukleardoktrin, haben halt mehrere Zwecke und die sind halt dementsprechend eigentlich auch so ein Ding, auf das man sich ziemlich weitgehend verlassen kann. Also dass es halt ein Land gegen seine eigene Nukleardoktrin handelt, dann muss die Scheiße schon richtig den Ventilator treffen. Also das ist halt so, wenn die Ukraine anfangen würden, im größeren Umfang russisches Territorium, also jetzt nicht neu russisches Donbass-Territorium, sondern halt so altes Russland mit Raketen zu beschießen. Das wäre halt so ein Punkt, wo die Russen auch schon offenbar angesagt haben, jedenfalls dürfte es der Grund sein, wieso die West der Westen keine Langstreckenwaffen geliefert hat, also jetzt bis in russisches Territorium reichen. Und die Ukraine hat gesagt, ihr dürft auf gar keinen Fall russisches Staatsgebiet beschießen mit unseren Waffen, weil dann klar ist, okay, das wäre halt nukable Offens. Und dafür sind halt Nukleardoktrinen da, dass du halt weißt, worauf du dich da einlässt. Dementsprechend würde ich sagen, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die Russen taktische Nuklearwaffen einsetzen, in dem Fall, wo die Ukraine anfängt, ihr Territorium zurück zu erobern und zu dem Zeitpunkt halt schon die, die Russifizierung in Anführungszeichen passiert ist, das ist der Punkt, wo ich anfange, meinen Gargazäler zu putzen. Natürlich hat die Ukraine jegliches Recht, diese Territorien zurück zu erobern. So, don't get me wrong. Das ist dann eigentlich der kritischste und gefährlichste Teil dieses Krieges für den Rest der Welt, nicht nur für die Ukraine. Ja, weil in dem Augenblick, wo jetzt, nehmen wir mal an, hypothetisches szenario, die Ukraine erobert den Donmas zurück oder ist gerade dabei und die Russen würden wahrscheinlich erst mal so was machen, wie Nuklearwaffe in großer Höhe zünden, um einen EMP auszulösen, zu sagen, sie hat übrigens gerade unsere rote Linie überschritten oder sie würden eine sehr kleine Nuklearwaffe einsetzen, um klarzumachen, okay, hier sind wir jetzt gerade an dem Punkt, wo wir unsere Einsatzdoktrinen, es uns erlaubt, Nuklearwaffen einzusetzen. Die Frage ist, was dann passiert. So, im optimalen Fall setzen sich dann alle Seiten hin und finden eine Verhandlungslösung, die irgendwie zumindest dafür zuführt, dass nicht noch mehr Nuklearwaffen eingesetzt werden. Im nicht optimaleren Fall könnte es dazu führen, dass so ein Konflikt dann wirklich sehr hässlich wird. Nicht nur hässlich, so wie es jetzt ist, sondern so nuklearhässlich. Das ist tatsächlich das Problem, was ich sehe, so dass die Russen in einer offensivoperation gegen momentan oder gegen ukrainisches Territorium nuklearwaffen einsetzen, halte ich vor allem nahezu ausgeschlossen. Da haben die keinen Grund für und das wäre halt ein... Also es passt in keine kalkulation, nicht mal eine Putin möchte noch irgendwie als der Großeltern in die Schiedsbrüche eingehen, kalkulation. Dass sie taktische Nuklearwaffen einsetzen, in dem Augenblick, wo sie die Territorium russifiziert haben und die Ukrainers zurückerobern, halte ich für möglich.
Du sagst jetzt, Verhandlungslösung. Ist das denn überhaupt möglich, mit Putin zu verhandeln? Also ich sah neulich so einen Podcast gehört und da kam das Argument, so wir haben ja als ein paar Russland-Experten, Gelehrte an Unis, haben wir mal geguckt, ob Putin jemals deeskaliert hat und wir haben keinen Fall gefunden. So kann man mit so jemanden überhaupt verhandeln.
Also im Falle...
Und zwar zurück bis zu seiner Zeit als Bürgermeister in St. Petersburg.
Also im Falle, dass ein Einsatz von taktischen Nuklearwaffen im Ukraine-Krieg passiert, ist verhandeln wahrscheinlich das falsche Wort. Also wahrscheinlich handelt es sich dann um einen Austausch von Erpressernoten, bis eine Seite dann eine Lösung findet, die nicht so aussieht, weil sie die Kleinen beigegeben hat, aber zumindest diesen Konflikt nicht mehr weiter eskaliert. Beide Seiten, sagen wir so, beide Seiten sind eigentlich am besten dran, mit einem langgezogenen konventionellen Konflikt, der unterhalb der Nuklear-Schwelle bleibt, wie im Kalten Krieg. Also wir sehen ja de facto einen neuen Kalten Krieg an der Stelle, so als wo halt also die, immer ein Proxy-Konflikt zwischen dem Westen und Russland dem Westen durchaus zu Passe kommt, aber aus verschiedensten Interessengründen. Und auf der anderen Seite, wo die Russen glauben, dass ihnen nicht nochmal in Afghanistan passiert. Und eine Nuklearisierung des Konfliktes hätte das Problem, dass es für auch die Machtbasis von Putin selbst unkalkulierbar wird.
Ich weiß aus dem Kalten Krieg, dass sie experimentiert haben mit Mini-Nukes, die man irgendwie aus Artillerie verschießen kann. Und das ist irgendwie nie wirklich weit gekommen.
Die gibt es auch noch.
Also nehmen wir mal an, es gibt die Waffen noch in diesen Einsatzfähigen. Meinst du, das könnte passieren?
Ja, das wäre das, womit ich rechnen würde. Also ich würde damit rechnen, dass wenn halt, also wenn wie gesagt der Saferleintritt Ukraine erobert, die Art zurück, was durch von den Russen aus ihrer Sicht russifiziert worden ist, dass die Russen mit irgendwie sowas wie eine 1,2 Kiloton Nuke, die sie eher performativ einsetzen, also die jetzt nicht unbedingt ein meteorsches Ziel erfüllt, sondern halt quasi nur die Signalisierung handelt, zum ihr habt die Nuklearschwelle erreicht, ist, das wäre das, was ich denken würde, was passiert. Und der Westen ist halt auch nicht in der position, dann weiter zu zocken. Also weil das Problem ist halt einfach, die Russen sind in der Art und Weise, wie ihre Atombewaffnung funktioniert auf dem Level von Doktrin und Einsatz für so einen Konflikt mal härter aufgestellt als der Westen, weil beim Westen ist halt Atomwaffeneinsatz immer quasi Präsidentenentscheidung. Also de facto müsste halt beiden entscheiden, was jetzt passiert. So alle anderen sind nicht in der Lage. Also kein anderes NATO-Land würde diese Entscheidung treffen. In Russland und der sowjetunion damals war es halt so, dass es eine Freigabeentscheidung, also ein Freigabeentscheidungsprozess gibt, der, wenn er getroffen ist, die Möglichkeit, taktische Nuklearwaffen einzusetzen, auf die Ebene von, ich glaube, Frontkommandeuren runterdelegiert.
Ach du Scheiße.
So, das heißt also, die sagen, der Typ an der Front, der gerade überrannt wird, ja. Also halt von der, der…
Na der hat aber keinen Grund, irgendwie jemals nicht auf den Knopf zu drücken.
Genau, also und der Punkt ist halt, das wird, also die, die russische Doktrin sieht halt vor, dass dieser Punkt kommuniziert wird. Das heißt, die sagen dann halt an, guten Tag lieber Westen, ihr habt jetzt gerade unsere rote Linie überschritten, wir haben unseren generellen in diesen fünf Frontabschnitten die Freigabe für eine anzutaktische Nuklearwaffe gegeben, wenn sie in eine position kommen, dass sie halt nicht, ja, also dass sie position nicht halten können. Und dann ist der Westen halt in der richtigen scheißsituation. So, was willst du machen, dann kannst du den Ukrainern sagen, geht mal, macht mal nicht weiter, ihr dürft euer Territorium nicht wieder zurückerobern.
Wir hätten gerne unsere Waffen zurück.
So, wer, oder keine Ahnung, wo die Software an unseren Waffen hört, auf zu funktionieren oder was auch immer, ist halt eine richtige scheißsituation. Es ist halt so eine situation, wo es halt keine wirklich gute Antwort für den Westen drauf gibt.
Was sagt denn die NATO-Doktrin für den Fall, dass, sagen wir mal, Russland jetzt die Ukrainen nuket? Ukraine ist ja nicht Teil der NATO, aber sie ist irgendwie...
Die NATO würde in dem Fall erst mal nichts... Also die würde halt ihre Einsatzbereitschaft für den Einsatz von Nuklearwaffen erhöhen, wozu alle möglichen Maßnahmen gehören, und würde primär sich auf den Fall vorbereiten, dass von russischen Territorium mit kurzeren Mittelstreckenwaffen NATO-Territorium angegriffen wird, was halt zum Beispiel heißen kann, dass von Kaliningrad aus Berlin genugt wird. So, das ist halt technisch im Bereich des Möglichen und wir hätten dann, keine Ahnung, sieben halb Minuten oder so vor der Zeit. Das ist nicht so lang. Irgendwie so was, jedenfalls so eine hohe einstellige Minutenzahl. Und naja, also ich meine, was dann halt passiert, ist halt irgendwie, dass die NATO halt irgendwie die...
Ja gut, aber das ist irgendwie klar, dass dann die NATO reagiert.
Aber wenn es jetzt nur, also nur in aller Zeit... Also wenn es einen taktischen Nuklearwaffeneinsatz gibt, dann, also die Szenarien sind da durchgespielt, die sind ja häufig geübt, es ist halt die NATO macht ja Manöver für sowas, hängt es davon ab, wie der politische Wille aussieht.
Also es gibt keine Autorespons?
Nein, gibt es nicht. Es gibt also eine politische Entscheidung, wie darauf zu reagieren ist. So und da gibt es die unterschiedlichsten optionen, die auch alle schon geworgen sind. Also zum Beispiel könnte die NATO halt zum Beispiel sich entscheiden, okay, je nachdem was passiert. Also wenn die Russen eine 2-Kilo-Ton-Nuke gegen ukrainische Stadt einsetzen oder gegen ukrainischen, keine Ahnung, konzentrationsraum von einer division und da halt Tausende von Toten oder Zehntausende von Toten gibt und halt verseuchtes Territorium würde direkt so schlecht anders aussehen, als wenn die Russen, keine Ahnung, über dem Schwarzen Meer quasi eine performative Nuke detonieren, um zu zeigen, ihr habt eine Nuklearschweile erreicht. Und dann kann es halt sein, dass die NATO zurückgeht und sagt so, okay, ja, so weit wollten wir jetzt nicht spielen. Oder sie sagen, okay, wir detonieren eine EMP-Nuke über eurem russisch besetzten ukrainischen Territorium. Das ist dann alles möglich, das ist halt eine politische Entscheidung, die dann getroffen wird, wenn es halt so weit ist. Es gibt halt für all diese Fälle durchgespielte War Games. Die Frage ist halt nur, ob die dann irgendjemand liest. Also wenn sozusagen der Shit erreicht ist. Du hörst dich an War Games, also den Film.
The only good move is not to play.
Genau, und du siehst halt dieses Szenarien mit irgendwie the Pakistan Gambit und wie es alles hieß, so diese ganzen verschiedenen Szenarien, die dann am Ende durchflattern. So, während er zu diesem The only winning move is not to play kommt, da geht er auf dem Schirm richtig was los. Und das ist halt keine fiktion. Also von diesen Szenarien gibt es halt viele. Und es gibt ja auch eine sehr, sehr große strategic play military simulation community im Internet, die halt den ganzen Tag.
Natürlich gibt es die.
Also die halt den ganzen Tag in, ich glaube, so drei, es gibt so drei verschiedene, vielleicht könnte uns ja noch was in den Kommentaren, so drei verschiedene große simulation game communities. Und davon sind auch einige, in denen halt taktische Luftwaffe-Einsatz passiert, also in den Games passiert. Und da sieht man dann halt auch, wie vielfältig halt die Resultate sein können. Sie hängen halt ausschließlich davon ab, wer redet dann mit wem? Wer nimmt dann das Telefon ab? Was sind die Moves, die halt passieren, wenn diese Schwelle erreicht ist? Gibt es dann halt den Telefon auf, der sagt, okay, wir hören jetzt mal eine Woche auf? Oder wir machen jetzt erstmal einen temporären Waffenschlägstand und gucken mal, was passiert? Oder geht es weiter? Ist die, Mr. President, wir müssen eine harte Linie demonstrieren?
Gehen Sie in die Air Force One und bleiben Sie airborne. Also es ist ja etwas sehr Interessantes passiert. Nämlich haben die Amerikaner jetzt eine zweite Front aufgemacht in Form von Pelosi, der Sprecherin des Unterhauses, die Taiwan besucht hat. Und das ist jetzt noch nicht ganz klar, ob das irgendwie, ob Ukraine jetzt einfach die Büchse der Pandora war und jetzt knallt es halt überall oder ob das irgendwie eine strategische Idee war. Oder ich habe ja im Blog die Theorie geäußert, dass die Pelosi einfach sich gedacht hat, das ist jetzt nicht mehr mit persönlichem Risiko verbunden, weil wir China in der Ukraine gezeigt haben, dass sie da nicht einmarschieren können, ohne dass es einen ewigen Krieg mit Unterstützung des Westens gibt.
Schwer zu sagen.
Aber du bist so ein bisschen auf der Büchse der Pandora-Theorie, ne?
Ja. Also wir sehen es an allen möglichen Ecken jetzt gerade halt irgendwie Kosovo, ne?
Auch das südchinesische Meer jenseits von Taiwan ist die ganze Zeit schon am Eskalieren.
Also jetzt halt so Balkan, Kosovo.
Ja, das kommt auch noch dazu.
Selbes games-szenario, das halt so Israel, Palästina geht auch wieder los, Türkei, Syrien. Türkei, Griechenland geht gerade wieder los.
Die haben heute ein Schiff rausgeschickt, um nach Gas zu buddeln im Mittelmeer.
Das ist halt so, dass, sag mal, der, die momentane, also meine momentane Sicht ist, dass dieser, dieser Ukraine-Angriff durch Russland in der Büchse der Pandora in dem Sinne geöffnet hat, dass die Möglichkeit, politische konfliktsituation militärisch zu lösen, im Mindset von vielen Führungsfiguren in der Politik weltweit was verändert hat. Also nämlich dieses, also dieses, wir können jetzt, man kann dieses Militär ja auch mal einsetzen. Jetzt haben wir schon die ganzen Jahrzehnte irgendwie da Milliarden und millionen reingepumpt. Dann können wir doch irgendwie den ganzen Kram auch mal benutzen.
Ich war sehr erstaunt.
Also bei Djan Armenien, ne? War zum Beispiel auch so ein Ding. Also bei Djan Armenien war halt genau so ein Ding, wo jemand eine Entscheidung getroffen hat, wir führen jetzt diesen Krieg, systematisch die Waffen besorgt hat, die Unterstützung besorgt hat, die politischen Allianzen besorgt hat, um halt irgendwie jetzt diesen Konflikt da mal zu lösen. Also zu lösen, in Anführungszeichen, ne?
Ich war halt erstaunt, weil ich mir dachte, also aus spieletheoretischer Sicht, wenn ich jetzt, sagen wir mal, irgendwie Oberbefehlshaber der NATO wäre und ich hab meine Hände mit der Ukraine voll und dann kommt irgendwie ein Pizzle Warlord und macht irgendeinen Krieg, dann hab ich doch nicht mehr die Zeit, mit dem irgendwie rumzuverhandeln, dann sitzt doch mein Triggerfinger viel schneller oder nicht. Also aus meiner Sicht wäre das Risiko für irgendjemanden jetzt Krieg auszuprobieren, viel höher, weil die Leute alle keine Zeit haben, sich irgendwie mit irgendwelchen Leuten auseinanderzusetzen.
Ich glaube, dass der Westen in dieser position ist.
Ja, aber die Russen noch auch oder nicht? Oder meinst du, die können jetzt noch irgendwo anders einen Krieg anfangen?
Nö, die Russen glaube ich nicht.
Wobei im Iran blubbert das auch vor sich hin, oder? Da haben die Russen ja so ein paar Luftabwehrstellungen stehen. Da las ich… Äh, Syrien, Entschuldigung.
Also ich glaube, was da passiert ist, eher, dass alle Seiten jetzt quasi dieses, okay, jetzt ist Konflikt-Time.
Wie im ersten Weltkrieg so, äh ja, super, jetzt geht's los.
Dass der Westen durch die ukrainischen Erfolge gegen die Russen sich jetzt so ein bisschen so, naja, was geht denn noch so, fühlt?
Ja, super, na, gar nichts geht, weil wir unsere Hardware gerade auch hier gegeben haben.
Zumindest in Europa, aber… Völlig bescheuert. Naja, pff, ich meine, also Serbien, Kosovo, ne, also ist halt so ein Ding so, dieser Konflikt, also im Westen wurde es ja wieder so dargestellt, als wären irgendwie die Serben jetzt halt da irgendwie, da halt schon wieder irgendwie losmarschieren, um rundum zu massakern. Aber de facto ist es halt so, dass die westlichen Verbündeten im Kosovo und Albanien halt die Lage da nachhaltig über die Zeit eskaliert haben, indem sie halt die Serben innerhalb des Kosovo immer mehr drangsaliert haben. Und damit den Serben natürlich den Prima-Vorwand gegeben haben, zu sagen so, okay, wir müssen jetzt nochmal was tun.
Und jetzt ist der Zeitpunkt, weil die alle...
Ich glaube, die Serben hätten jetzt eigentlich sich eher an einen anderen Zeitpunkt gewünscht als irgendwie jetzt gerade so, weil die Russen halt gerade irgendwie zu tun haben, die halt ihre Verbündeten sind. Aber letzten Endes ist dann halt auch die Frage, wie viel sozusagen aus Sicht des Kosovos ist jetzt halt wahrscheinlich der Zeitpunkt, sich halt diese särbischen, indisch-sarbischen Territorien halt da irgendwie das Problem für die aus deren Sicht mal zu klären und die irgendwie einzunehmen. Und die sind ja vom Westen halt irgendwie hochgerüstet worden. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass da halt, also in diesem Balkonkonflikt gibt es immer keine Guten und keine Bösen. Das sind halt beide Seiten haben halt irgendwie, du hattest da neulich dieses Video irgendwie.
Ja, es gab ein tolles Video über Charping, der ja damals den Krieg sozusagen losgetreten hat.
Genau, das kannst du vielleicht nochmal hier verlinken, weil irgendwie das war wirklich auch erhellend, um mal die Komplexität von diesem Konflikt zu verdeutlichen und das irgendwie die, jetzt zu sagen, irgendwie die bösen Saben oder irgendwie was auch immer, wer gerade der Bösewicht ist, ist halt unterkomplex und dann muss ich da irgendwie tatsächlich die genauen Details angucken. Aber dieses, soll man dieses, jetzt, wir können jetzt mal gucken, was wir noch so an Battlefields haben, die so ein bisschen eingefroren sind, die wir jetzt mal los, wieder aufmachen können, ist glaube ich im Westen bei den Hawks schon so ein Ding, so. Und man muss zu dieser China-Taiwan-Geschichte.
Aber so viel Hawks gibt es doch da außerhalb der USA gar nicht mehr. Ich meine, die Briten hätten früher immer schön mitgemacht.
Die Briten sind jetzt gerade quasi, oh, da sind die, die sind da, die treiben die Kraft. Nee, aber diese China-Taiwan-Nummer ist halt, man muss ja immer, wenn man sich für diese Dinge interessiert, halt auch die offiziellen Dokumente lesen. Und eines dieser Dokumente, also einige, einige Sets von Dokumenten sind halt auch wie die Amerikaner die chinesische militärische Schlagkräftigkeit einschätzen. Und es gibt eine nicht kleine fraktion im amerikanischen Militär, die sagt, der Zeit, genau, wenn wir jetzt noch 10 oder 20 Herren warten, dann werden wir einen Krieg mit China nicht gewinnen können über Taiwan. Dann werden die uns einfach mit uns den Boden wischen. Und das ist ein bisschen so das, was mich in dieser Pelosi-Nummer halt auch so beunruhigt ist, dass die beide Seiten so routiniert agieren. Also die Chinesen hatten offensichtlich das Playbook von was machen wir dann?
Sie hatten es schon alles ausgegeben, aber die wussten genau, die Leute standen schon am Ufer, mussten nur noch kurz in ihre Manöverboote steigen.
Genau, das war so ein, so ein, so ein, ja, so ach hier, und hier haben wir das Playbook Pelosi-Besuch. Wie, dann führen wir diese 25 Militärmanöver durch. So oder? Und das ist halt so ein, und wann immer du halt so ein, so ein Anzeichen dafür hast, dass eine Seite nicht, also dass keine Seite überrascht ist, davon wie sich dieser Konflikt entwickelt, macht mir das große Sorgen, weil beide Seiten dann offensichtlich schon so weit in ihrem Denken vorangeschritten sind, wie das Game weitergeht, dass...
Von deinen Rennen durch eskalieren.
Genau, dass das halt so ein, so ein, so ein durcheskalationsautomatismus halt dabei geben kann, so. Das ist halt so ein bisschen sowas. Deswegen, also ich hätte halt eigentlich auch gesagt, so keine von den Seiten hat jetzt Interesse daran, jetzt diesen Konflikt zu eskalieren, aber...
Also die Rolle Thais war, das finde ich auch sehr ambivalent an der Stelle. Also jetzt gab es die Meldung, dass der, ich glaube, es war der Außenminister von Taiwan, der irgendwie meinte, ja, also das Manöver da, das sieht aus, als wenn das jetzt irgendwie einfach so, so durchläuft und dann blockiert das unsere Supply Chains. Und dann sind wir im Arsch. Also das heißt so, als wären Taiwan tatsächlich das Manöver für nicht nur irgendwie Posturingheld, sondern das soll uns hier wirklich gerade schaden. Was mich ja überrascht hat, weil so habe ich das nicht gelesen.
Ja, schwer zu sagen. Also was da zu sagen, teilweise ist es auch super komplex in politischen, also da gibt es ja auch irgendwie sehr unterschiedliche fraktionen, die jetzt...
Und es gibt immer wieder wunderbare Parlamentschlägereien.
Genau, aber die haben unter anderem auch damit zu tun, mit den irgendwie eher pro-chinesischen, eher nationalistischen, also sozusagen nicht pro-chinesischen fraktionen. Also schwierig, also weiß ich nicht genau über Taiwan in Politik, um einzuschätzen, welche Äußerung von wem da jetzt halt irgendwie einzuordnen ist.
Aber wir sollten vielleicht sagen, wieso wir überhaupt im Westen über Taiwan reden. Man könnte ja auch sagen, das ist einfach ein innerchinesischer Konflikt, scheiß drauf. Aber es betrifft uns ja schon, denn in Taiwan sitzt TSMC und das ist einer der größten, so Chip-Produzenten der Welt.
Der größte.
Also ich weiß nicht mit wieviel Abstand, aber das sind die einzigen, die im Moment die kleinsten Strukturaufflösungen hinkriegen. Und wenn ihr ein Computer oder ein Smartphone habt, dann seid ihr Kunden von TSMC indirekt. Und wenn die Chinesen kommen und TSMC irgendwie die Supply Chain zumachen oder den Export irgendwie behindern, da gab es gerade ein Memo von Apple, was nur durch die Presse ging. Die haben ihren taiwanesischen Kollegen geschrieben, die sollen sich bitte peinlich an die chinesischen exportrestriktionen halten. Und da überhaupt nicht auch nur den Hauch eines Vorwandes liefern, weil Apple sozusagen annimmt, wenn da irgendwas schimmelig aussieht, dann nutzen die Chinesen den Vorwand. Und was man vielleicht auch erwähnen muss, das ist, dass China selber versucht, eine TSMC-ähnliche ship-produktion aufzubauen. Aber das scheitert im Moment daran, dass es exportrestriktionen gibt für Hightech-Güter nach China. Und China muss das halt alles selber nochmal neu erfinden und ist so ungefähr 10, 15 Jahre zurück. Das heißt, wenn China jetzt in Taiwan einmarschiert und die Tech von TSMC mitnimmt, wäre das allein schon Gewinn für China, unabhängig davon, wie es mit Taiwan weitergeht.
Da gab es ja eine sehr klare Ansage von dem Chef oder Schleifvertretenden Chef von TSMC.
Naja, also ich weiß nicht, ob der da noch groß was zu sagen hat.
Nee, nee, der meinte halt.
Dann macht er seine Fabrik kaputt oder wie. Das ist auch richtig doll Scheiße für uns, weil die Fabrik baut unsere Computer.
Nee, das ist ja nicht nur eine Fabrik, sind ja irgendwie mehrere Dutzend.
Naja, klar, aber...
Nee, aber du kannst davon ausgehen, dass diese Fabriken auf einem soliden Fundament aus Dynamit gebaut sind. Also da wird nichts, es ist halt vollkommen klar.
Ja, aber unsere optionen sind halt alle Scheiße, egal wie das da ausläuft irgendwie.
Naja, also jedes Mal, wenn der Westen versucht hat, die SNC dazu überreden, eine Fabrik im Westen aufzubauen, haben die Taiwanese gesagt, so, ah, könnten wir.
Das ist bei unserer Lebensversicherung was, was du willst.
Bei unserer Lebensversicherung, deswegen nicht so gerne.
Auf absoluten Nachvollziehbarheit, natürlich.
Insofern ist halt so der, also der Westen ist wohler, wird da nicht anders können, als zu versuchen, Taiwan zu verteidigen. So in der einen oder anderen option. So und ich meine, letztendlich ist halt für die Chinesen, das ist halt auch so ein völlig irrational, ne? Also ich meine, also wenn diese Taiwan-Issue nicht wäre, also die Chinesen sagen ja, ist gut, okay, wir gehen zurück zur vorigen Politik, wir assimilieren die in 100 Jahren, wenn wir die wirtschaftlich irgendwie, wir kaufen die nach und nach auf und dann so.
Aber das ist ja tatsächlich die Politik.
Gewesen, gewesen, bis Xi das geändert hat. Das ist der interessante Punkt, deswegen ist es halt so total irrational, dass China jetzt quasi sagt ja, wir werden uns das Meteor zurückholen und diese gesamte, dieser gesamte, also diese gesamte China-Taiwan-Verhältnis jetzt in den letzten Jahren so dermaßen eskaliert ist, hin, also weg von, langsam wird es eher eine Soße und es wird halt irgendwie gegenseitige Beteiligungen und so. Hinzu reiserestriktionen, investitionsrestriktionen, import-export-restriktionen und so weiter und so fort ist eine politische Änderung, die unter Xi passiert ist. Das heißt also tatsächlich, was da geschehen ist, dass Xi gesagt hat, das dauert mir ja alles zu lange. Bis das mit der assimilation passiert ist, ist irgendwie viel zu lange. Und ich will, dass das bei mir im Geschichtsbuch steht.
Scheiße, immer die Geschichtsbücher.
Oder was auch immer jetzt genau gesagt hat, aber sozusagen die implikation davon. Wenn es dieses Problem nicht gäbe, wenn die Chinesen sagen würden, ja Gott, das interessiert uns eigentlich überhaupt nicht so, lass mal irgendwie schön ein Business machen und irgendwie zusammen Afrika erobern, oder was auch immer sie dann gerade…
Sie verdienen ja auch gut daran, wenn sie Taiwan machen lassen. Das darf man ja nicht unterschätzen. So der Ex-Exporter aus China auf dem Papier.
So dann wäre die Gesamtweltlage plötzlich viel entspannter. Es gäbe halt einen Major-Conflikt, der jetzt so aussieht, als wenn er mit Sicherheit passieren wird, und zwar in den nächsten zehn Jahren passieren wird, vielleicht in den nächsten 15 Jahren auf jeden Fall passieren wird. Das ist halt so ein Ding, was halt irgendwie eigentlich… Also es gibt ja so immer diesen Versuch zu sagen, Geschichte aus den geopolitischen Realitäten zu erklären, also aus der Geografie, aus dem, wie halt irgendwie die ökonomischen Grundvoraussetzungen von Ländern sind, aus dem, wie sich Länder in der position in der Welt, die sie halt geografisch haben, mit irgendwie Handelsströmen und so weiter und so fort, positionieren, und zu sagen, okay, das ist eigentlich viel wichtiger als jetzt irgendwie einzelne Personen oder als einzelne Akteure oder auch nur einzelne politische Parteien. Und dann hast du aber immer wieder so diese Fnords dazwischen durch, wo du halt denkst, also eigentlich könnte den Chinesen, diese Taiwan auch wirklich echt egal sein. So wir könnten sich halt sagen, das ist halt dieses Land da vor unserer Küste, okay, vor 50 Jahren die Großväter und so, aber lass mal ein Business machen so. Also wie es ja auch lange Jahre war. Also wo es ja, wie es ja, mein, es war ja zwischendurch, sah es ja so aus, als würde da nie irgendwas passieren, als würde das einfach so gemütlich halt irgendwie so eine Koexistenz halt sein, wo man halt irgendwie gemeinsam viel Geld verdient und Investen ausnimmt.
Also teilweise ist das ja auch heute noch, also die Geopolitik funktioniert ja tatsächlich teilweise auch heute noch so. Die Südchina, South China Sea, das blubbert auch in der Weile vor sich hin und da gibt es durchaus irgendwie geografische Gründe, warum das blubbert. Aber die Mittel, die die alle verwenden, sind so, wie soll ich sagen, also peinlich geradezu. Also wenn man jetzt heute irgendwie in die News guckt, nach South China Sea, dann finde ich hier gerade China Launches Law Enforcement Whistle, um irgendwie Disputed Islands zu patrouillieren. Und dann sagen alle, die anderen würden ihre Schiffe bulligen. Die anderen haben aber angefangen, das ist so Sandkasten alles. Aber es ist halt eine der zentralen Handelsrouten der Welt. Und da gehen einmal Chinas Exporter durch, bis die neue Seidenstraße fertig ist.
Naja. Ja, wir wollten noch ein bisschen positive.
Eigentlich wollten wir lauter positive Sachen erzählen und jetzt sind wir hier schon wieder. Aber es gibt noch eine andere Frage, die ich an der Stelle wichtig fand, nämlich dass TSMC eigentlich ja nur die Fabrik baut, die Chips baut, aber die Maschinen in der Fabrik, die kommen von anderen Leuten unter anderem von einer niederländischen Firma inzwischen auch im Besitz von nicht EU Investoren, ASML und so eine Heuschrecker, die gekauft wurden, in letzter Stand, ja also jedenfalls.
Die haben eine Heuschrecker, ASML kaufen lassen?
Ich hab auch gestaunt. Also das ist jedenfalls eine holländische Firma, die die Belichtungsmaschinen baut für extrem ultraviolette Belichtungen und das sind so die, das ist ja der aktuelle Stand der Technik und die sind im Wesentlichen die einzigen, die diese Maschinen bauen können. Aber selbst die bauen die halt nicht, sondern integrieren die eher. So die Optik kommt dann von Carl Zeiss und so. Und ich finde, da muss man mal drüber reden, ob in unter diesen Umständen überhaupt eine digitale Souveränität erreichbar ist. Wenn die Leute, die die krasseste Elektronik bauen, die es heute gibt, das ist halt auch nicht ein Land. Ja, nicht mal die Taiwanese sind da souverän, sondern sind halt angewiesen auf Importe.
Naja, meine, das ist halt so ein, die Welt ist halt so komplex geworden, um halt mit auf Technologiesouveränität in allen Aspekten abstellen zu können. Also du hast ja eigentlich, bist du ja an so einem Punkt, wo du sagst, du versuchst irgendwie mindestens die Basics selber in der Hand zu haben, um nicht in kritischen Punkten eine Abhängigkeit zu haben. Aber es gibt inzwischen so viele kritische Punkte, dass du halt irgendwie, also dass du halt eigentlich keine wirklich Chance hast, irgendwie als einzelnes Land. Deswegen, wie gesagt, glaube ich auch nicht, dass die Russen jetzt halt anfangen werden, in der Großiris im Kontakt der Fertigung irgendwie hochzufahren, sondern die werden maximal sich noch irgendwie in einen, keine Ahnung, 35 Nanometer oder sowas bauen, geschmuggelten Komponenten oder irgendwie sonst irgendwas, um halt irgendwie halbwegs, ok, akzeptabel mit der Elektronik bauen zu können, aber die werden niemals 5 Nanometer Zeug bauen. Das brauchen wir nicht.
Aber das lohnt sich auch gar nicht.
Nee, ich meine, ich kann sie eh in China bei Sandwürgen kaufen, dann ist das halt irgendwie... Trotzdem glaube ich, dass ein Stück weit technologische Souveränität notwendig ist, im Sinne von, dass du Dinge wie z.B. Software selber in der Hand hältst, also dass du halt in der Lage bist, die funktionsbestimmten Eigenschaften von, also die umüber funktionsbestimmten Eigenschaften von Digitalsystemen selber in der Hand zu haben. Und da glaube ich, dass die Idee von technologischer Souveränität nicht völlig bekloppt ist, was jetzt halt irgendwie Chip-Fertigung angeht. Na ja gut, ich meine, wir kriegen jetzt halt eine Intel 5nm-Fab, die kommt halt nach Magdeburg, glaube ich. Magdeburg oder Dresden, Magdeburg war es, glaube ich. Jedenfalls irgendwann nach Ostdeutschland.
Also aus Spanien kriegt man das nicht, Spanien? Ja, es gibt mehrere. Intel ist in Verhandlung. Die EU ist da, seit wir von digitaler Souveränität reden, ist die EU plötzlich, ist da einige Fördertöpfe aufgenommen. Und Intel hat da sehr gute Deals.
Genau. Und meine, Intel hat dann sozusagen gesagt, okay, die Taiwanese wollen nicht aus verständlichen Gründen, aber ist halt klar, wenn es halt irgendwie in China versus Taiwan losgeht, dann wollen wir halt zumindest noch eine option haben, dass wir noch irgendwas machen können. So, und dazu gehört halt irgendwie, dass wir uns gut mit Samsung stellen und dass wir halt irgendwie noch eine eigene Fabrik haben, in der man irgendwie so eigene Fabriken haben, in der man Zeug bauen kann. So, ich meine, jetzt könnte man halt natürlich eine superfiese spekulation machen. Der Ukraine-Krieg ging erst los, als Nord Stream 2 fertig war. Und also, dass halt Nord Stream 2 nicht online ging, also nicht anging, war quasi eher so ein unvorgesehener Hick-Up. Die haben es ja noch ein paar Monate lang probiert, bevor sie dann losgelegt haben und gesagt haben, okay, scheiß drauf. Man könnte jetzt natürlich spekulieren und sagen so, okay, wenn Intel jetzt anfängt, neue Fabriken zu bauen, mit denen halt die sozusagen die Abhängigkeit von Taiwan und damit natürlich auch ein Stück weit von China sich halt irgendwie erledigt, ist das möglicherweise halt die Deadline, der erste mögliche Punkt, an dem die Chinesen loslegen. Also dass die Chinesen sagen, okay, wenn wir jetzt irgendwie TSMC kaputt machen, bevor der Westen halt irgendwie self-sufficient ist, dann ist deren motivation halt irgendwie, uns Krieg zu führen halt dramatisch hoch. Hingegen, wenn halt irgendwie der Westen halt irgendwie jetzt nicht mehr so auf Taiwan angewiesen ist, dann ist seine, sein Willen halt sich wegen Taiwan in einen Krieg mit uns zu stürzen, halt einfach dramatisch reduziert.
So, ich habe hier mal gegoogelt, ich finde hier gerade keine Neuschrecken, das war, ich muss mich irgendwie wechselt haben.
Also ich finde, das sind Phillips und der Rest ein Streubesitz.
Ja, allerdings ist es so, dass die Amerikaner ASMC irgendwie erzählt haben, sie dürfen nicht nach China exportieren.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen schwierig.
Die Frage ist, auf welcher Basis?
AsML hat auch relativ viel Technologie zusammengekauft, also die haben viel selber entwickelt.
Ja, die haben auch zwei, drei, vier. Die haben übrigens auch in Berlin eine Firma gekauft, die dann kurz sich in Flammen aufging, komischerweise.
Berlin Glas? Sind die abgebrannt?
Also die eine Fabrik ist in der Verzapfung, ja.
Oh, interessant. Okay, na gut.
Da gab es auch noch komische spekulationen, aber die waren noch nicht beteiligt.
Okay, also der AMI-Hebel über AsML funktioniert so, dass die für die vorhergehende chip-generation, also sozusagen eins größer als fünf Nanometer, was war neun oder so, es war zwölf.
Ne, sieben gab es auch.
Sieben. Jedenfalls, also vor ExtremUV haben die Lichtquellen von einer amerikanischen Firma, die sie gekauft haben, verbaut. Und das ist der amerikanische Hebel. Naja, weil die machen ja nicht nur EUV, die machen ja auch noch mehr. Aber um nochmal sozusagen den Bogen zurückzumachen, so diese Frage, wie groß sind die wirtschaftlichen Abhängigkeiten? Wie schnell wirken sanktionen? Welche Folgen hat die Nichtverfügbarkeit von bestimmten Dingen? Da glaube ich, diese strategische Wirtschaftskriegsführung. Das ist halt so ein Ding, was einerseits unterschätzend, andererseits überschätzt wurde. Was der Westen gerade mit den sanktionen versucht gegen Russland, ist halt strategische Wirtschaftskriegsführung.
Naja, nur hat Russland halt nicht so die fetten, irgendwie höheren Industriezusammenbau, sondern das sind größtenteils Rohstoffexporte, was die machen. Insofern ist ja der Hebel auch nicht so groß. Du kannst halt aufhören, denen den Scheiß abzukaufen. Aber es ist ja eine viel größere Hebelwende zum Beispiel dafür sorgen, dass das TSMC keine Wafers mehr kriegt.
Oder China halt bestimmte Vorprodukte nicht kriegt. Oder andersherum Europa kein Kram mehr aus China bekommt. Dann sind wir ja im Arsch. Also wenn wir keine antibiotika mehr haben, dann haben wir irgendwie nichts mehr.
Ja, das habe ich neulich gelesen, dass seit ein paar Jahren haben unsere Apotheken das Problem, dass diverse Sachen einfach nicht lieferbar sind. Und das erkennt man als Kunde daran, dass man irgendwie ein Rezept hat. Und dann sagen die, können sie auch dieses Mittel hier nehmen? Das ist dasselbe. Ja, das liegt daran, dass es ursprünglich hier gar nicht lieferbar war. Und das liegt daran, dass sehr viele unserer Medikamente, obwohl die Pharmakonzerne deutsch oder europäisch sind, trotzdem in China hergestellt werden. Und da gab es dann halt irgendwie Covid-Lockdown oder sowas.
Die Rohstoffe, also sozusagen die Wirkstoffe, sind halt in der Regel Tabletten, die schon hoffentlich noch je gepresst sind. Aber genau diese gegenseitige Abhängigkeit macht halt die Aussicht auf einen Konflikt mit China für den Westen extrem unattraktiv.
Was ja gut ist, aber auf der anderen Seite kam ich ja her von der Frage, kann man sich da überhaupt wehren? Ist es überhaupt realistisch zu sagen, wir werden jetzt irgendwie unabhängig in irgendeinem Aspekt? Eher nicht, oder?
Du kannst deinen Schmerz reduzieren. Das alles.
Ja, aber du bist immer noch tot am Ende, wenn sich die Sterne richtig stellen.
Also klar, unter extrem ungünstigen Umständen geht das halt überhaupt nicht. Also wie gesagt, meine spekulation mit Intel ruht ja aus genau dieser Überlegung. Wenn die Chinesen halt sagen, unter welchen Umständen ist denn der Westen bereit, jetzt in einen ernsthaften Krieg über Taiwan zu ziehen und nicht nur halt irgendwie ein bisschen hier und da zu machen, wäre halt irgendwie, der Westen hat auch noch andere optionen für seine Chips.
Ja, aber das ziehst du nicht mal eben aus dem Boden, so eine Fabrik.
Ne, eben, deswegen denke ich, dass die Deadline ist, also beziehungsweise der erste Zeitpunkt, ab dem es losgehen kann.
Also Intel baut auch in Amerika gerade die produktionen aus.
Und Samsung wird auch gerade sehr, sehr hart umgarnt, um woanders Fabriken zu bauen. Ja, was haben wir noch so?
Tja, geht das alles so weiter jetzt? Meinst du, die Supply Chains wären nie wieder normal in Scare Quotes?
Ne, glaube ich nicht, dass die normal wären.
Also haben jetzt einfach zu viele Leute gemerkt, dass man da Kohle mitmachen kann, wenn die Supply Chain irgendwie ein Problem hat?
Pff, naja, nicht mal das, sondern das Problem ist halt eher, dass die Leute legen sich jetzt alle Lagerbestände hin. Und die inflation führt natürlich auch zu einem starken Incentive, sich Lagerbestände hinzulegen, auch wenn es steuerlich extrem ungünstig ist. Beziehungsweise macht man halt seine Firma dann halt eben nicht in Deutschland, sondern macht einen beteiligten Land, wo man halt irgendwie sich die Lagerbestände aus dem unversteuerten Einkommen hinlegen kann.
Die Ukraine sagst du.
Nee, aber keine Ahnung, in welchen Ländern das halt so ist, aber es gibt halt dann auch diese Möglichkeit schon. Das führt aber wir uns dazu, dass dann halt ein Nachfrageeinbruch passiert. Na, also weil, wenn du halt irgendwie erstmal eine Wahl aus Lagerbeständen bedienen kannst, dann kaufst du natürlich weniger bei deinem Zulieferer ein. So, und dann hat der halt sozusagen dieser Wibblecheffekt.
Oder du kaufst zu viel ein und der projiziert falsch, wie viel weiter du demnächst fragst.
Also jedenfalls, es wird nicht, also die Normalisierung der Supply Chains ist nicht absehbar, weil dieser Peitschenschlag-Effekt in allen möglichen Varianten und Formen mehr dimensional zu einem überproduktion, große Lagerbestände unter produktion, Lagerbestände werden wieder alle, gibt wieder mehr Nachfragee als produziert werden kann und so weiter. Beziehungsweise produktionsanlagen werden runtergefahren, weil halt irgendwie schon zu viele Lagerbestände sind und so weiter. Also dieses ganze Oszillieren wird halt nicht viel weniger werden. Jetzt ist einmal quasi der Stein in den Teich geschmissen und jetzt laufen die Wellen halt durch. Und je nach Komplexität, also nicht ein Stein, sondern irgendwie viele Steine.
Je nach Komplexität der Herstellungsautomatisierung kann man sowas auch nicht mal eben runter und hochfahren, sondern das dauert dann irgendwie ein Monat, bis das wieder läuft.
Ja, wenn ein Monat, optimistische Betrachtung.
Naja, also bei so einer Chip-Fabrik noch ein bisschen mehr. Aber ja, bei Lieferketten ist mir auch aufgefallen, dass wir immer noch davon ausgehen, dass das alles mal eben gefahren werden kann. Und da kommt uns langsam die Klimakatastrophe so ein bisschen dazwischen. Ich habe neulich so ein Video geguckt von dem Marc Wennecke aus London. Der war gerade Mitte Juli in London, als da gerade diese heißen Tage waren und der mir berichtete, was sie da in aktionen machen. Und eine der aktionen war, dass sie Schienen weiß angemalt haben, damit die mehr Sonnenlicht weg...
Weil die Stoßwungen in ihren Schienen zu klein sind, für die Temperatursinnung, für die sie geplant haben.
Ja, also so Notfall, offensichtlich irgendwie panik-notfallaktion. Und eine andere Sache hat ja da so eine Brücke gezeigt, wo sie, so ne eher alte Metallbrücke, da haben sie dann so weiße Folie über die, über die tragenden irgendwie Stahlseile und die Anker am Ende gelegt, so und links auch. Und gesperrt war sie auch.
Davon habe ich da auch ein Foto gesehen, das war noch sogar noch schlimmer. Da standen Klimaanlagen daneben. Diese Folien drumrum waren nicht nur sonnenreflektion, sondern damit die Klimaanlagen funktionieren. Es war Isolierung, damit die Brückenlager gekühlt bekommen, weil sie Angst hatten, dass in diese Brückenlager platzen.
Also das war alles jedenfalls ganz furchtbar. Der erzählte dann auch, da hatte er leider keine Fotos von gehabt, dass sie Sand auf die Straßen gestreut haben, weil der Asphalt schmolz.
Die Fotos habe ich auch gesehen.
Und dann denkst du so, was zur Hölle? Und wenn das jetzt im Sommer normal wird, dann kannst du auch mal eben vergessen, Sachen aus dem Lager zu holen. Also das bröselt sozusagen auf allen Schichten, nicht nur die Supply Chain. Also ich meine, wir sind ja schon im Grunde durch die Kriege zu den Rohstoffen durch. Wir haben ja jetzt schon so das irgendwie seltene Erden, gibt es halt nur noch in China und dann haben wir hier Poster hängen, Werbeposter für Smartphones, ohne irgendwie Konflikt, Kobalt und so Sachen. Da sind wir ja schon durch. Jetzt haben wir als nächsten Schritt gehabt, dass das Wasser alle wird.
Was auch in Brandenburg.
Was übrigens bei der Chip-Fertigung auch ein Riesenproblem ist, der Wasserverbrauch, je höher die Auflösung wird. Ja und ich denke, der nächste Schritt wird sein, die Schiffe haben wir gehabt, dass jetzt aber auch einfach Straße und Schiene bald irgendwie einfach Ausfälle haben werden, weil wir haben jahrelang, jahrzehntelang auf Verschleiß gefahren und auf die Temperaturen ist das einfach nicht ausgelegt, die wir jetzt haben. Ist ja auch bei uns so, dass der Asphalt anfängt, irgendwie weich zu werden, wenn es zu warm wird.
Ja, das ist nicht so schlimm. Ich meine, im Osten hatten wir irgendwie nur einen braunkrohlen Teehahn, der war immer weich im Sommer. Da gab es dann diese fetten Spuren an der Abend.
Nur weil du das kennst, dass es nicht so schlimm war.
Das haben wir auch überlebt. Nein, also tatsächlich habe ich diesen Eindruck, dass es irgendwie so langsam... Meine Ost-Sozialisierung und Erfahrung hat langsam Vorteile.
Ja, jetzt kommt ihr langsam, es zahlt sich aus.
Wieder relevanter werden. Also bei sowas wie Handwerker und so. Also dieses ganze Umgehen mit den täglichen Katastrophen, es fällt einem einfacher, weil man das schon mal gesehen hat, wie die Umgangsmechanismen damit sind, die funktionieren, nämlich sich primär halt irgendwie mit Leuten, die man kennt oder zu denen es eine Form von sozialer Beziehung gibt.
Ich finde es halt richtig scheiße, dass du wirklich an jeder Ecke sehen kannst, dass wir das selbst verursacht haben, entweder durch Fahrlässigkeit oder beschissene Planung.
Gier. Gier. Kurzfristige Gier, das ist der Hauptgrund.
Da kannst du echt niemanden bringen, außer uns selbst.
Effizienzwahn dafür sorgen, dass immer alles viel effizienter wird.
Wobei natürlich das Gegenteil der Fall war.
Kapitaleinsatz effizient.
Ich glaube, es war eher, was effizienter war, als wir konnten uns mehr Management-Schichten leisten, weil wir anderswo eingespart haben. Die Bullshit-Jobs musste halt jemand bezahlen. Ja, das stimmt.
Na gut, wir wollten noch auf einer hoffnungsvollen Note enden.
Das sehe ich ja nicht.
Doch.
Ich sehe, ich habe hier noch Staatstrojaner und Überwachung, was ja auch weitergeht. Das war das Scheiße.
Ja, ich meine, die situation, die wir da haben, ist, dass der Staat inzwischen ernsthaft Angst hat, die Kontrolle zu verlieren und...
Ja, zu Recht.
Wenn man halt irgendwie...
Also das haben die Querdenker ja echt gezeigt, dass die Kontrolle im Grunde, ähm, na, wie heißt das so schön, bei der Gibson hat diesen irgendwie, diesen Begriff geprägt für Cyberspace, es sei eine kooperative halluzination. Na, wenn sich alle Seiten darauf einigen. Und im Wesentlichen haben die Querdenker Demos und die Impfgegner gezeigt, dass auch die statische Kontrolle im Wesentlichen eine gemeinsame halluzination war. Und wenn da nur einer Dolge noch gegen tritt, wenn genügend Leute dann nur ein bisschen gegen treten, dann fällt halt auf, das ist gar nicht.
Ja, wobei halt, also ich meine die Querdenker und die Impfgegner sind da glaube ich nicht, also die haben den Threshold nicht erreicht, aber die haben gezeigt, dass es wackeln kann.
Sie haben nicht den Threshold erreicht, dass das platzt, aber sie haben den Threshold erreicht, dass die Leute gesehen haben. Also ich kann bei mir ganz klar ein Umdenken diagnostizieren, dass ich mir denke immer mehr, so wieso zahle ich eigentlich Steuern? Ja und so und die Frage kommt ja von den Querdenkern, wieso zahlen wir eigentlich GEZ-Gebühren? Oder kannst du bei jedem Solidarsystem die Frage stellen? Und je mehr du einzelne Leute siehst, die halt nicht am System teilnehmen, und zwar bei Covid-Masken, ist es ja eine Sache, wo aus meiner Sicht sich das so darstellt, dass die mir sozusagen ins Gesicht zeigen, ist mir egal, ob ich dich anstecke oder nicht. Also das heißt, nicht nur nehmen die nicht am System teil, sondern meinen Wohlergehen ist ihnen egal. Ja, weil sie das Problem leugnen oder was auch immer. Warum, ist ja egal. Aber damit ist auch aus meinen, ist für mich plötzlich der Gedanke, legitim zu fragen, warum zahle ich eigentlich einen. Ja, und das ist so ein Gift, was sich so von langsam durch alle Schichten der Gesellschaft teufelt, ist mein Eindruck.
Ja, gut, der kann ich nachvollziehen. Also ich habe ja schon irgendwie länger den, also was diese Masken angeht. Dieses Konzept des Fremdschutzes bei den Masken war, glaube ich, ein Fehler.
Hätte man nicht sagen sollen, meinste?
Nee, weil zum einen ist der Effekt halt irgendwie so stark abhängig von dem Sitz der Maske und der Qualität der Maske, dass das halt irgendwie bei irgendwie diesen typischen blauen Läppchen, die sie da halt, die medizinische Maske nennt, war halt völlig egal und dementsprechend halt auch einfach diese Idee, dass man keine Masken mit Ausatmventil benutzen soll, weil man ja damit die anderen nicht schützt, glaube ich, war ein Fehler.
Das hat, glaube ich, eh nicht genug Leute erreicht. Aber ich habe das am Anfang selbst verbreitet, weil mein Eindruck war, es ist gar nicht klar, ob die ihn bauend genug schützen. Und dachte ich, dann reicht ja auch, wenn sie Ortbauend schützen. Und das konnte ich nachvollziehen, selbst wenn die Maske nicht gut sitzt, dann geht der Luftstrom an der Seite raus und nicht nach vorne, mit dem du redest.
Ja gut, okay. Also jedenfalls letztendlich ist es halt aber diese, also vielleicht mal meine Sicht da schon immer irgendwie viel zu zynisch genug, wie auch immer. Also ich habe halt Maske nur als Eigenschutz betrachtet, weil irgendwie alles andere. Ich meine, keine Ahnung, ob da jemand seine Maske mit Stecknall-Stichen behandelt hat, damit er leichter atmen kann. Weißt du, da habe ich mich noch nie drauf verlassen, aber ich sehe deinen Punkt zu sagen, dass die Bereitschaft zum solidarischen Handeln dramatisch abgenommen hat und dass Corona da auf jeden Fall so ein Wendepunkt war, weil es plötzlich so sichtbar wurde.
Ich glaube, das ist auch noch selbstverstärkend, ist mein Eindruck. Wenn es anfängt zu bröseln, dann denkst du plötzlich nach, wo das denn noch ist.
Ich sehe das halt immer in der Bahn. Da hast du halt immer dieselbe Demografie von Leuten, die mit so leicht trotzigem Blick irgendwie ihr blaue Läppchen als Kinnhalter runtergezogen haben.
Also ist ja eine Sache ohne Maske, aber die Maske zu haben und dann nicht über Mund und Nase zu ziehen, ist doch ein Stinkefinger.
Und dann halt auch dabei immer so zu gucken, was ist so dieser, sprich mich jetzt gleich jemand an, ich würde gerne meine ganze Wut ins Gesicht schreien, einen Blick so und ich denke mir so, okay, ihr wart ja schon immer da, ihr wart schon immer da, aber ihr wart nicht so sichtbar, wir wussten nicht so viel, wie viele ihr seid, jetzt wissen wir es. Ihr seid nicht so viele, aber ihr seid ganz schön lästig.
Ich glaube auch, dass die nicht schon immer so waren, sondern dass sich das auch gesteigert hat.
Viele sind über die Schwelle gepusht worden.
Ich glaube, früher waren das Fußballfans, die dann immer von der Polizei rausgezogen und kontrolliert wurden und irgendwie Bußgelder und Platzverweise. Das hat sich auch durch die Gesellschaft geeitert. Und jetzt mit dem Covid haben die so ein Ventil gehabt.
Die Demografie sind nicht Fußballfans. Ich kenne viele Hooligans.
Nicht Hooligans, sondern einfach Leute, die ein Fußballspiel sehen wollten, was da teilweise an Sicherheitsstaaten hochgezogen wurde. Dann gab es irgendwie einen Sonderzug und der wurde dann irgendwie random komplett am Bahnhof alle einmal durchkontrolliert und so Sachen. Also es gab schon...
Aber es passiert doch, ich meine jetzt, ich meine, ich war gerade am Wochenende auf einem Festival und da hat die Polizei an der Grenze zu Polen, das ist ein Polenes Festival, auf einem Parkplatz eine riesige kontrollstation aufgebaut mit so richtig mehreren Dutzend Beamten und haben alle Reisebusse, mit denen sich halt irgendwie die Leute ökologisch korrekt zu diesem Festival chauffieren lassen wollten, alle Reisebusse flächendeckend, also hunderte von Bussen, flächendeckend gefilzt mit aller Aussteigen.
Nach Drogen gesucht, oder was?
So und ich denke mir da so, ja.
Warum? Auf unserer Seite meinst du jetzt?
Auf unserer Seite, um die Statistik voll zu machen. Sagen die auch, also ist halt so deren...
Boah, ja dann darf es sich echt nicht wundern, wenn die Leute keinen Bock mehr haben, an dem Staat teilzunehmen, oder?
Genau, so und der Punkt ist halt, deshalb ist es sozusagen dieselbe Spiel, halt wie bei den Fußballfreunden.
Weißt du, es gibt ja diese Webseite, Web3 is going great, wir brauchen mal, War on Drugs is going great, einfach mal diese Art von Meldung.
Der Punkt ist, das ist ja eigentlich schon erledigt. Ich meine, wann halt irgendwie, dass halt irgendwie Hartisch-Legalisierung passiert, ist jetzt eigentlich nur noch eine Frage der Zeit, und wann irgendwie diese bekloppten SPDler irgendwie endlich mal verstehen, dass sie einmal das Richtige tun könnten, was möglicherweise sogar populär wäre.
Aber dann kann sie nie auf die SPD verlassen, dass sie noch nie die kippen. Die sehen, wenn es mal kurzzeitig so aussieht, als wenn sie versehentlich das Richtige tun, kippen sie noch um vorher.
Right. Anyway, jedenfalls ist es ja zumindest ein Fall, wo der progressive Teil der Gesellschaft und die Polizei einer Meinung sind. Also muss man ja auch mal so sehen. Aber anyway, also die...
Aus anderen Gründen allerdings.
Aus anderen Gründen, natürlich. Aber diese Art von offensichtlicher in-your-face-repression. Das war so ein Punkt, wo ich, als ich... Ich hatte irgendwie einmal, zweimal irgendwie während dieser Corona-Geschichte und nicht nur ich, sondern auch Freunde, so Run-ins mit dem Ordnungsamt. So und wegen, als diese Bekloppte, du musst auch draußen nachts Maske tragen, wenn du allein bist, weil die Straße als Geschäftsstraße klassifiziert ist. Und ich dachte mir, was für eine Sabotage. Wer sich diese Regel ausgedacht hat? Der einzige Grund, den ich mir für diese Regel vorstellen kann, ist Leute over the edge zu bringen. Die Leute wirklich dahin zu bringen, dass sie sagen, okay, jetzt reicht es nur mit diesem Staat. So und ich meine, meine Grundhaltung gegen über diesem Staat ist ohnehin jetzt nicht so flauschig freundlich, oder danke Finanzamt, aber das waren halt so Punkte, wo für mich halt so der Punkt erreicht hat, wo ich dachte so, nee, das ist jetzt so eigentlich kurz vor offener repressionsgesellschaft, wenn da diese Tottel von Ordnungsamt-Schnuffies da stehen mit irgendwie ihrer angezogenen Machtuniform, die sie verliehen bekommen haben, wissend, dass was sie da gerade tun, völliger Bullshit ist und nichts weiter tun, als ihre Macht ausüben. Das ist ein Punkt, wo ich verstehen kann, wieso Leute auf Demos gehen. Auch wenn ich sie sonst für komplette idioten halte. Also wo ich halt irgendwie keinerlei Verständnis für diese Impfgegner-Spinner oder diese irgendwie Blauläppchen auf dem Kinn tragen in der Bahn Leute habe. Weiß Gott die Leute, die ich wirklich nicht mag, aber an diesem einen Punkt war ich dann auch an dem Punkt so, okay, das ist jetzt wirklich so, jetzt hat der Staat das Letzte, den letzten Rest an rationalitätserwartung bei mir verspielt. Zu meiner Erwartung an den Staat war eigentlich bisher, ich kann sein Handeln nachvollziehen. Also er handelt zumindest, wenn nicht immer effizient und auch nicht immer rational, aber ich kann zumindest nachvollziehen, wie es dazu kommt. An diesem Punkt war die einzige Erklärung, die ich hatte, die wollen die Leute jetzt wirklich in den Wahnsinn treiben. Die wollen jetzt wirklich, dass selbst Leute, die eher gutwillig sind wie ich, kurz davor sind, diesen Ordnungsamtschargen in die Fresse zu hauen. Und das ist halt so ein Ding, wo bei mir ein bisschen was zerbrochen ist. Also wo für mich so der Punkt war, wo ich dachte so, okay, mein Rest ist Rest an Vertrauen in diesen Staat. So war noch der allerletzte Rest ist jetzt weg. Also der erste Breakpoint war, als sie gesagt haben, ne Masken braucht ihr nicht, weil die könntet ihr falsch aufsetzen. So, wo die Studienlage vollkommen klar war. So da dachte ich, okay, das wird nichts damit, dass ihr euch auf dieser Pandemie und euch an diesem Staat so erwartet. Dass sie dann flippen und sagen, du musst nachts auf offener Straße draußen, wenn du alleine unterwegs bist, ne Maske tragen. Sonst kriegst du Ärger mit dem Ordnungsamt. Da ist meine Erwartung, ein rationales Handeln des Staates vollständig zerbrochen. Die wird, glaub ich, auch nicht wieder herstellbar sein. So und das hat so ein Ding, wieso ich glaube, dass die eskalationsgeschwindigkeit nimmt ab jetzt zu. Das ist ja egal. Irgendjemand hat die Dienstanweisung geschrieben. Irgendjemand hat nicht verhindert, dass diese Dienstanweisung geschrieben wird. Irgendjemand hat dann ein Gesetz draus gemacht. Irgendjemand in der Stadtverwaltung hat diese Straßen designiert mit hohem Aufwand. Irgendjemand hat diese Schilder dahin gedübelt. Das sind Schilder, so richtige Schilder, die hängen da. Mit hier musst du jetzt Maske tragen. So zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo der wissenschaftliche Konsens vollständig klar war, dass Outdoor die Gefahr so gering ist, es gibt kein Problem. Und anstatt da mal für zu sorgen, dass mal einer durch die Bahn geht und sagt so, jungen Mann, könnten Sie vielleicht Ihre Maske wieder aufsetzen? Haben Sie Ordnungsamtsschergen nachts auf die Straße geschickt?
Da gibt es Nachtzuschlag, wenn du nachts auf der Straße stehst. Und natürlich machen die das.
Klar, wenn die den Befehl kriegen, machen die das. Wir sind in Deutschland, hier werden Befehle befolgt. Deswegen glaube ich, weil die Fähigkeit des Staates, politische Entscheidungen in rationell nachvollziehbares Handeln umzusetzen und…
Ne, andersrum. Ich finde, der Staat hat zumindest die Aufgabe, glaubwürdig zu simulieren, dass es einen Hintergrund hat. Und das haben sie halt verkackt bei Covid. Sondern sie haben einfach irgendwie panikaktionen gemacht. Und selbst, als sich dann die Faktenlage geklärt hat, haben sie die nicht zurückgezogen.
Es gab zu diesem Zeitpunkt keinen Zweifel mehr an der Faktenlage.
Ja, eben. Das meine ich ja. Aber die Regelung kam bestimmt von davor.
Nee, die war danach.
Dann verteidige ich das nicht.
Also ich meine, sowohl wir brauchen keine Masken, da war die Sache klar, dass wir Masken in den Räumen brauchen, als auch wir müssen draußen Masken tragen. Da war bereits klar, dass draußen kein Ansteckungsgefahr besteht, die relevant ist. Also das ist jetzt nicht so, das ist halt irgendwie dann da so eine, der Punkt ist halt, das ist wie bei sowas wie Staatstreuern. Es gibt so eine Phase, wo der Staat und die Politik nicht weiß, wo man ihnen zugestehen muss, sie verstehen es noch nicht, sie haben die Wissenschaft noch nicht zu Erkenntnis genommen, sie haben eine Expertin noch nicht zugehört, sie sind noch nicht in der Lage zu verstehen, was die richtige Entscheidung wäre. Bis der Zeitpunkt, wo ich sage, okay, helfen wir gerne, erklären wir gerne.
Ja, aber dann handelt noch nicht, wenn ihr das noch nicht verstanden habt. Das ärgert mich ja immer, wenn die dann so einen Kurzschluss-Scheiß machen.
Das ist der erste Punkt der Handlung. Der zweite Punkt der Handlung ist, wir haben es wohl verstanden, wir wissen genau, worum es geht. Wir haben die Studien gelesen, wir haben den Experten zugehört. Und jetzt machen wir trotzdem Staatstreue.
Na, da erzähle ich ja immer die Story von meiner, also ich war mal als Experte im Bundestag geladen und die Begrüßung war, vielen Dank, dass Sie wieder gekommen sind, nachdem wir Sie das letzte Mal schon ignoriert haben. Das war der erste Satz, den ich zuhörte. Ich dachte so, okay. Und so war's. Das wird nicht gemacht, damit Sie irgendwie die Wahrheit gehört haben. Das wird nicht gemacht, damit irgendjemand danach informiert ist, sondern das wird gemacht, damit du nicht aus formellen Gründen den Beschluss anfechten kannst.
Genau, es sollte Demokratie schauen.
Das ist die simulation.
Im Bundestag.
Aber ich erwarte, dass du zumindest irgendwie glaubwürdig zu erklären versuchen kannst, wie es zu der Entscheidung kam. Aber das ist halt inzwischen weg.
Diese Erwartung nicht mehr. Ich habe wirklich keine Erwartung mehr, dass der Staat in irgendeiner der kommenden Krisen halt derjenige sein wird, der die Sache rettet oder auch nur irgendwas tut, um es zu verbessern.
Die werden sich selbst retten.
Ich habe diese Erwartung nicht mehr. Diese wahrscheinlich sind sogar dazu zu blöde. Weil du gerade für einen Staatstrainer ansprichst. Einer von den Leuten, die dieses Staatstrainer-Thema treiben. Der ist klug. Er ist ein schlauer Mann, der schon seit vielen Jahrzehnten im Staatsdienst ist, in unterschiedlichen Verwendungen, in unterschiedlichen Varianten. Er ist einer von den wenigen Leuten im Staat, die wirklich wissen, wie das mit den Computern und der Computersicherheit und so weiter und so fort geht. Der sagt dir dann halt, deswegen sage ich den Namen mal nicht, ja, es gibt ein Missbrauchsrisiko. Ja, wir verstehen, dass es da ein Problem mit den Sicherheitslücken gibt und dass diese Sicherheitslücken, wenn wir die benutzen, so dann werden die möglicherweise nicht geschlossen und so. Da gibt es halt so ein Management-Problem, so dann muss man sich halt einen Prozess überlegen.
Aber wir machen trotzdem.
Moment. In meiner Abwägung ist das Risiko, diese Eingriffsmittel nicht zu haben zu groß, weil wir Angst davor haben, die Kontrolle zu verlieren, weil wir Angst davor haben, dass uns irgendwie Reisbürger, Terroristen, Kinderficker, ausländische Nachrichtendienste und so weiter, also die ganze Litanei von Bedrohungen, Nazis, die immer wieder durchiteriert werden, dass wir da nicht mehr hingucken können und deswegen blind sind, deswegen nicht mehr handeln können und deswegen die Kontrolle verlieren. Dieses Risiko ist signifikant größer, aus seiner Sicht, und der ist damit repräsentativ für einen großen Teil des Staatsapparates, als das mit rechtsstaatlichen Mitteln und Transparenz und Prozessen managbare Risiko des Missbrauchs von diesen Mitteln durch Geheimdienste, Polizeibehörden. Da bist du dann halt in einer beschissenen position. Da bist du in einer position, wo du sagst, okay.
Dem kannst du auch nichts mehr sagen.
Meine Welt sich deine Welt sich. Du sagst ja nicht, es gibt hier kein Problem, sondern du sagst, es gibt ein Problem, aber es ist nicht so groß, dass wir es nicht managen können. Und ich sage, okay.
Naja, ich finde immer, das ist ja das, was Wissenschaft und religion unterscheidet, ob deine Sache falsifizierbar ist. Und wenn du auf so einem Weltbild agierst, dann will ich aber mindestens einen Sunset-Klaus haben, dass das Gesetz nach einem Jahr automatisch verfällt. Aber machen die halt nicht.
Natürlich nicht, was er macht.
Ja, und das ist halt das Problem, dass sich Macht irgendwann nur noch darum kümmert, den Machterhalt voranzutremmen.
Auf der anderen Seite hast du halt die Linke, die halt irgendwie so eine panische Angst vor Macht hat.
Wobei ich würde dem inhaltlich sogar zustimmen, dass sie ohne Trojaner irgendwann nicht mehr in der Lage sein werden, da Strukturen aufzuklären. Nur ist es ja nicht so, dass sie in den Zeiten, als es einfach war, ohne Trojaner diese Strukturen aufzuklären, signifikant was gegen irgendeine dieser Gruppen getan hätten. Daher ist das für mich kein gültiges Argument. Und ich finde, der Staat darf auch einfach einige Sachen nicht. Das ist dann halt hinzunehmen. Wenn wir zum Beispiel einen Lügendetektor hätten, also jetzt mal unter der Annahme, dass die funktionieren, was nicht der Fall ist, aber nehmen wir mal an, es gäbe einen Lügendetektor, dann haben wir immer noch das Recht in der Verfassung, dass du dich nicht selbst inkriminieren musst. Das heißt, du könntest dann sagen, will ich nicht. Ich sage nichts. Und das wird hier halt abgeschafft mit diesen Staatstrojanern. Jedenfalls was mich an den Staatstrojanern geärgert hat, dass eigentlich egal, wie viel wir die Händere mit anderen Sachen voll hatten, mit irgendwie Covid, mit inflation, mit Supply Chain, Chaos, mit allem, ja, trotzdem wird dieser Staatstrojaner-Scheiß vorangetrieben. Das finde ich immer krass, ja.
Das hat aber...
Dass es offensichtlich nichts mit dem Druck zu tun hat, von dem, die da immer reden. Sondern du hast in der Zeit vom Ukraine-Krieg nichts über irgendwie Kinder-Pornoprobleme gelesen in den Medien. Es gab keinen Druck. Ja, hat die Schwelle nicht genommen. Aber das hat eben nicht dazu geführt, dass die Argumente, die darauf aufbauten, dass es da ein Problem gibt, dass das irgendwie gestoppt wurde.
Es hat nur die Aufmerksamkeit worden.
Und dann denke ich mir halt, okay, das ist nicht evidenzbasiert, was die hier machen. Und dann muss ich mir auch die Argumente nicht anhören von denen.
Nee, evidenzbasiert ist es halt nicht. Also überhaupt nicht. Na gut.
Aber ich kann das halt bei mir selbst beobachten, dass so einige von den zentralen Fragen der Querdenker, je mehr Zeit vergeht, desto solider erscheinen die Fragen. So warum zahle ich hier eigentlich ein? Und ich beobachte um mich rum auch, dass die Leute Solidarsysteme wie so eine Versicherung, Lebensversicherung betrachten. Die denken sich, ich zahle da irgendwie n Euro ein und dann will ich halt n plus k raushaben. Aber das ist halt kein Solidarsystem, wenn alle mehr rausholen, als sie einzahlen. Dann ist das irgendwie eine Lotterie. Nee, nicht mal, das ist gar nichts, das geht nicht.
Ein Prozeski.
Ja, genau, das ist ein Schneeballsystem, verfolge. Nee, aber diese Anspruchshaltung, dass ich da aber dann bitte mehr raushaben will, als ich eingezahlt habe, die ist halt Gift auf jeder Ebene. Ja, dann kannst du halt keinen Start mehr machen, wenn die Leute da so rangehen. Und ich glaube, das beißt uns gerade in den Arsch, dass wir da jahrelang nichts gegen gemacht haben.
Naja, was da halt passiert ist, das ist halt eben doch eine Verselbstständigung des Staates.
Ich übrigens von beiden Seiten, auch der Staat argumentiert ja so. Deswegen bleiben Autobahnreparaturen für 20 Jahre liegen. Weil bis sich das amortisiert hat, ist der nächste Typ in der Legislatur. Und das lohnt sich für den jetzt nicht. Der macht dann halt ein Schild, was die Höchstgeschwindigkeit senkt. Was ich ja immer, könnte ich immer reintreten, wenn ich so was sehe. Weißt du, so ein Schild irgendwie ab hier 30 kmh und dann so ein Schild darunter, irgendwie Straßenschäden.
Was richtig geil ist, hier vorne gibt's ein Schild, Tempo 30 kmh und dann darunter ein Schild, Gehwegschäden.
Huch, also was?
Und ich dachte mir so, irgendjemand hat da richtig Humor oder ist total verpeilt oder ist ein richtig harter Erissticker.
Ich hab ja neulich für einen Vortrag, hab ich ein bisschen Bilder gesucht, ob ich ein Bild von so was finde, weil ich für dieses Schema sieh's ja auch anders. Wir sinken lieber die Höchstgeschwindigkeit, als dass wir hier und dann hab ich ein Schild gefunden, da hat jemand irgendwie ein Schild drunter getan. Seit circa 20 Jahren. Weiß ich so? Straßenschäden seit circa 20 Jahren. Yes! Und so ist es halt, ne? Dass die Leute lieber irgendwie ein Antivirus installieren, als ihre Software sicher zu machen. Das ist ja immer dasselbe Muster. Nun ja, sag mal was Positives.
Was Positives? Ähm, was Positives. Oh, ich hatte am Wochenende ein erstaunlich positives Erlebnis zum Thema fleischlose Ernährung. Ah ja, genau, erzähl mal. Und zwar habe ich tatsächlich ein Produkt einer israelischen Firma konsumiert, die heißt Redefine Meat. Machen ja eigentlich keine Werbung hier, aber ich bin tatsächlich ein bisschen begeistert. Und die machen tatsächlich 3D-gedruckte Fleischersatzprodukte, also wo sie halt so aus diversen Proteinvarianten, ich glaube irgendwie so Soja und Weizen und Erbsen und so Zeug.
Whatever.
Whatever und Kokosfett irgendwie halt so Fleisch drucken. Und dieses Fleisch, dann lässt sich halt so bereit wie normales Fleisch. Und das war echt überzeugend. Also es war halt einfach so, also geschmacksmäßig war zumindest das Steak noch nicht ganz da, aber wie das Lammengehackte war, definitiv schon da. So also Geschmack als auch Textur mäßig. Und ja, und die sagen halt, ja, sie verbrauchen, ich glaube, sie verbrauchen deutlich weniger als ein Drittel von der Energie. Ich glaube, so was wie 20 Prozent oder so an Energie, CO2-Foodbrot und so weiter.
Das ist immer noch viel mehr als ein Salat übrigens, ne? Also laut diesem einen...
Naja, von Salat wirst du halt nicht satt.
Nee, aber ist so. Also der Unterschied zwischen, wie wir bauen hier Getreide an und wir bauen hier, wir ernähren damit ein Rind, aus dem wir Fleisch machen, ist irgendwie Faktor 100 an Wasser- und Energieverbrauch.
Was? Nee, also kalorienmäßig hast du...
Nee, nicht kalorienmäßig. Das ist halt sehr ineffizient, ein Tier zu füttern, was du dann fragst.
Achso, ja, ja, okay, ja, okay, also wenn du die, also wenn nicht nur...
Das heißt, wenn du jetzt also das Tier aus der, aus der Gleichung nimmst und direkt aus dem Soja einen Fleischersatz baust, würde ich schon erwarten, dass du näher dran...
Na die sind jetzt Prototype. Ja, klar, natürlich.
Aber also da muss noch einige sich bewegen.
Die sind halt, die bauen jetzt halt so, keine Ahnung, so...
Aber egal, wie teuer ist denn das im Vergleich zu Fleisch?
Die waren jetzt so bei ihrem Rindfleischersatzprodukt bei, ich glaube, weniger als, als Verkaufspreis, weniger als zwei Drittel von sehr gutem Rindfleisch. positionieren sie da. Was sie halt machen, ist die Tesla-Strategie. Und die ist halt auch richtig. Die sagen halt, wenn du halt irgendwie als fleischlose Ernährung irgendeinen Getreidebrei-teigigen Wuh verkaufst, irgendwie zu verkaufen, der nur oberflächlich frittiert wurde, dann wirst du halt kein Glück haben. Das muss halt geiler sein. Es muss halt mehr Spaß machen. Also genau das, was Tesla halt gemacht hat, sozusagen so Elektroauto wird genau dann gewinnen, wenn du dir lieber einen Tesla kaufst als einen Porsche. So, weil der halt einfach geiler ist, weil der halt mehr Spaß macht. Und genau das haben die halt getan. Also letztlich deren Lamm war so, dass Leute in die Küche gegangen sind, um zu gucken, ob da nicht wirklich ein Lamm irgendwo, also Lammhack versteckt ist. Das war wirklich gut. Also richtig so hätte man hier problemlos irgendwie auch im Wedding einfach in der Bude verkaufen können und die Leute würden dahin gehen, weil es so geile Lammhackröhrchen sind. So, das war schon beeindruckend und das Steak.
Also Frank hat mir Fotos gezeigt, das sah aus wie Fleisch.
Genau, das Steak war so optisch nicht zu unterscheiden. Das Steak hat halt wirklich einfach Textur von Fleisch. So Geschmack ist so bei 80 Prozent, würde ich sagen. Aber da kommen sie auch noch hin. Also jedenfalls gibt es da Hoffnung, dass man tatsächlich irgendwie das mit der fleischlosen Ernährung ohne allzu große kulinarische Opfer erledigen kann, was mich persönlich wirklich sehr erfreuen würde. Anyway, hast du noch was Positives? Du hast schon mit etwas Positivem angefangen, nämlich mit dem 9-Euro-Ticket. Das ist ja tatsächlich wirklich sehr positiv, muss man ja sagen.
Auch wenn sie uns das gerade kaputt machen wollen, jetzt gingen hier irgendwie Zahlen rum, dass es den CO2-Ausstoß nicht gesenkt hat. Ja, das war auch nicht die Frage, oder?
Na ja, ich glaube, es ging eher um inflationsbekämpfung.
Es war gedacht, um die Leute zu entlasten wegen inflation.
Aber das Ziel wurde auch offensichtlich erreicht. Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Ein Durchschlag. Die Bundesländer wollen jetzt aus eigenem Budget eine Verlängerung machen. Die ist dann halt nicht 9 Euro, sondern irgendwie 29 oder 49, wird gerade diskutiert. Die, die nicht mitmachen wollen, sind Bayern. Ja, super. Und der Linde hat wieder so ein paar Sätze rausgegangen. Egal, wir wollten positiv enden. Lass uns nicht auf Linde enden.
Es endet nicht positiv. Ja, okay. Ja, was haben wir noch Positives?
Das war's.
Das war's. Okay, na gut.
Wir haben mal wieder eine Sendung gemacht.
Freut euch, dass wir eine Sendung gemacht haben. Na gut. Ja, dann wünschen wir euch noch einen schönen Restsommer.
Hoffentlich nicht ganz ohne Alternativlos-Sendung, aber wir versprechen diesmal nichts.
Genau. Also ich vermute mal, wir werden auch was hinbekommen dieses Jahr, oder?
Also von mir aus auf jeden Fall.
Also wir haben eigentlich schon ein paar Sendungen und auch was mit Gästen. Das hat immer so ein bisschen koordinations- und Logistikprobleme, die jetzt insbesondere...
Also wir tun, was wir können....
insbesondere durch Corona auch nicht wirklich einfacher geworden sind, aber wir tun tatsächlich, was wir können. Und dann...
Zusammen schaffen wir das.
Das schaffen wir schon. Genau. Wir müssen zwar alle den Gürtel etwas enger schnallen, aber vielleicht haben wir dafür ein schönes, fleischloses Stack dabei. Ja, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Und dann bis zum nächsten Mal.